You are about to learn how to use .NET 5 to
create a Rest API. The creator of this course
is a Senior Software Engineer at Microsoft
and he is also an excellent teacher.
REST API allows your app or system to expose
its functionality to multiple types of clients
both inside and outside of your network, including
clients across the internet. This is what
you would use if you wanted to write a program
to collect data from say, Twitter, Yahoo,
finance, or even NASA. If you're looking into
building your own REST API, and you're considering
the dotnet platform for it, please stay with
me, as I show you how to do this end to end
using the latest innovations provided by dotnet.
Five, I hope you enjoy it.
In the first part of this tutorial, you're
going to learn the scenario to be used across
a tutorial, how to create a dotnet five Web
API project from scratch,
how to use Visual Studio code for building
and debugging the project, we're going to
work on
how to draw the development certificate installed
by dotnet. Five, and that's going to be needed
for HTTPS access
and how to use swagger UI to interact with
the API.
To follow the tutorial, you're going to need
a few things, including the dotnet, five SDK,
Visual Studio code
and some basic understanding of the C sharp
C sharp language.
Now let's talk about this scenario that we're
going to be using as a domain for this tutorial.
So let's imagine that we have some sort of
a catalog system. And we have a bunch of items
available in it. So in this sense, like I
am, video, video gamer, so I like to think
of these items as items that I will use within
a video game. So items like potions, swords,
shields and stuff like that. Right. So that's
a system that we have in place, it has a catalog.
And of course, we're going to have users that
are going to be a would like to banish this
catalog via their, their browser, right? They
have a browser, they want to manage these
catalog items, somehow.
So these are they would they would like to
do is well, how are we going to create items
in the catalog? A How can we retrieve the
list of items currently available in this
catalog? hunka. We update properties of the
items. And how can we delete items in this
catalog. So as it is today, we do have the
catalog available. But we lack we don't have
a way to expose this catalog to the internet
so that people can use go ahead and manage
it from the browser. So that's where we're
going to introduce our REST API for this catalog.
And during this tutorial, we're going to see
how to build this REST API from scratch using
dotnet. Five.
So here we are in business to recode. And
the first thing we're going to do is open
a brand new terminal. And this terminal, we're
just going to switch to the directory, where
we're going to create our project and create
a project, we're going to be using the dotnet
CLR.
So to do that, we're just going to say that,
that new and the type of product that we want
that we want to create for our REST API, that's
going to be Web API. And the name of the project
is going to be catalog, hit Enter.
And that creates your race all the files,
face it on the web API template. So now I'm
going to open that folder that got generated,
catalog.
And a, as you open a as usual, as you open
a dotnet project in Visual Studio code, it
will prompt you to add a few additional files
for building and debugging the project. So
I'm going to say Jess, and those files get
d rated under Ws code. So the left side, you
can actually see all the generated files.
And let's take a quick look at each of these
files
as a quick lack of love around. So the first
part we're going to look at is the ACS proc
file. This file is used is this is called
the project file. And this is used to declare
how we're going to build this project. In
this case, we're saying that we're going to
be using the dotnet web SDK to build the project,
which includes a bunch of tools and tasks
to specifically designed for web kind of projects.
The next interesting thing will be the target
framework, a monitor or target framework,
which in our case is net five. The target
framework defines the API's or face or what
kind of API's are going to be available to
your project. In this case that five is perfectly
good for us. And the next thing is going to
be a bunch of nougat packages that we're not
going to be diving into right now. But those
are just dependencies that we already acquired
on this project. Close that and the next we
are going to take a look at this program.
See
His pronunciation is what we call the entry
point of the application. And what this will
do is just pretty much race or stand up the
host. That I mean, the process is going to
become the host of our problem. And it also
declares a bunch of defaults. And it also
sets up what we call the startup startup class
for our project. So let's actually go to a
startup and see what's going on there.
Really, the main things and startup are that
we have this property called configuration
that we receive as part of the startup constructor.
This is you can use anytime you need to read
some configuration information from multiple
sources, like from a environment variables
or files, different kinds of files, or a bunch
of other places, a configuration that you
don't want to hard code is your service. The
next interesting method is configure services.
And this is the place where you would
register all the services that you're going
to be using across your application. And we'll
talk about this later on in this video. And
the last interesting piece is the Configure
method.
This is where we configure what we call the
a
pipeline that a request pipeline on ASP. net.
And so this just defines a bunch of typical
middlewares, which are
additional components that will execute before
your, before your, your controller or your
your code actually executes. So each of the
each of these can execute
as a request comes into, into the ASP. NET
process. And from there all the way into when
your code executes. But we're not going to
be exploring this part in this video.
A couple of other things are so we have a
weather forecast. So this is a model that
gets out generated for this sample application
here just have a few very simple properties
here. And alongside this a this model, there's
a controller. Now the controller in ASP. NET
is just pretty much the class that handles
the route.
Yeah, pretty much the routes that a your service
exposes, right, but we're not going to be
using these in this video. So let's not dive
too much into that.
A few other files a upsetted. json, this is
where you can declare configuration, that's
going to be that you don't want to use hardcoat
into your, into your, your program your your
source code. So And right now, it just has
some configuration for logging and the wholesaler
allowed in the app. There's also a variant
of appsettings JSON, which is absurd in development,
Jason. So development, I mean, the fact that
is that says a does say upsetting start developing
that JSON means that we're running in development
environment,
these settings will take precedence on top
of the opposite is Jason. So you could have
a bunch of these appsettings files for each
of your environment like production, test
integration, all of these environments.
And I'll be talking about environments may
be a good time to take a look at the files
era that VS code, which are a task Jason and
logic a lot Jason does, Jason is just a file
that declares the tasks with these key concepts
and pieces to your code, you can declare tasks
and a task is can be a bunch of things. And
in our case, the most interesting does is
the fact that we want to use run the dotnet
build command. So dotnet build, which is going
to be used for building our code. And in terms
of launch the JSON, this is the file that
controls what is going to be launched or executed
when we do like an f5. Or when we start debugging
the code in this case is already pointing
to the right DLL for start to start debugging.
Lastly,
we also have launch settings. So Jason are
really the only interesting part here that
they're like to take a look at is the application
URL. Here we are defining the URLs, URLs Imperial,
for our application, in which case in this
case, we're saying we're going to be serving
our server in localhost 5004, the HTTPS version
will be serving in which is going to be the
default version is going to be 5001. We also
declaring the actual a, a spinet core environment
environment variable. And we're setting it
as development. And so
also, in business to the code. This is not
the actual one that's been harder the one
that will is going to be harder eating lunch,
Jason. As you see over here. This is the one
that takes precedent if it was to recode.
So so that's good.
Well want to do now is actually to test this
this project just to make sure that everything
is running as expected. So what I'm going
to do is I'm going to switch to the debug
hub.
Hear me expand this a little bit. And so what
I would do is just click and start working.
Let's see what happens.
Right. So a browser pops up. And then if you're
getting these page here, a, what it means
is pretty normal, it means that we don't have
the self signed certificate that goes without
net, it has not been trusted. Right? So there's
a very simple way to go around decision and
to properly trust the survey that comes with
dotnet. So let me actually just close this,
and stop. And let's switch back to the terminal.
The actually let me open up a new terminal
here. Yeah, there it is.
So in order to trust a certificate that comes
bundled with the dotnet SDK, what you have
to do is just type dotnet, def cert, https
trust.
When you run this, you're going to get this
pop up, asking you to confirm that you actually
want to trust that cert, I'm going to say
yes. And then that we should do it. So I'm
going to run it again.
Let's see what we get.
Alright, so yeah, so we still are not getting
pretty much anything here. But we are not
seeing any trust issue anymore. Now if what
we want to see something meaningful here,
although it doesn't matter too much for us
at this point, what you can do is just go
to swagger.
And then you're going to get this this nice
UI. So this is what we call swagger are also
an open API specification. So this is a component
that is bundled now with dotnet, five, so
you don't have to do anything to make it available.
As you saw, we did nothing. So it's just there.
In the slash swagger URL. What this does is
allows you to easily describe all the operations,
all the actions, all the routes that are available
in your API, and allows you to also interact
with them easily. So for example, if I just
go to the get route, and I click a trade out,
click Execute, it will go ahead and run it.
And we can see already some results for that
route.
And then one thing that I like to do as I
work on these projects, is to really not open
the browser every single time that I run the
project. So let's actually switch a little
bit the behavior of VS code so that we just
keep this window open. And then anytime we
just hit f5, or hit Run, it will not open
more windows. So to do that, I'm going to
stop here. And we can go to launch the JSON
and close this.
The only thing that you have to do is just
remove this server Ready Action section here.
And that's pretty much it. If I run again,
and by the way, you can do this by just pressing
f5,
which I'll do right now, five.
That starts to host, as you can see, but we
did not he did not open any more windows,
which is fine. Because we have the browser
ready to call right there.
Then the last thing that I like to do in terms
of a practice set up is to simplify how we
build our project in pieces to record. So
for that, let me minimize this and go back
to business to recode. Stop this, close that
out I'm going to do is to go to data Jason.
And the only thing that I'm going to do is
to add this little section here under the
build task, which is just the what we call
the group, which is going to build and it
says is default true. What this does is that
allows us to more easily build a project.
So now I can go to let me just save this saved.
I can go to terminal room built tasks and
immediately builds. Without that, we're able
to just have a pop up yet another menu to
do the build. I can also now do Ctrl Shift
B and it will do the same thing. So yes, that
just speeds up our situation.
In the second part of the net five REST API
tutorial, we introduced the foundations of
our API, which includes the core entity used
to represent the items in your catalog, the
repository class responsible for all items,
storage related operations, and the controller
that will handle all the requests sent to
a REST API.
Here you will learn how to model an entity
via C sharp record types.
How to implement an in memory repository.
Sources
and how to implement a controller with get
route to retrieve resources.
Alright, so now that we are comfortable with
the initial setup of our project, it is time
to start setting up the the entities and a
repository that's going to be used to a store
and retrieve the items that are going to use
it across a service. So the first thing we're
going to do is well, let's actually just close
these and the terminal. And let's get rid
of a few of these classes that really make
no sense for our project. So I'll just delete
weather forecast here. And I'll delete the
weather forecast controller. So we can start
cleaner than that.
So let's introduce our entity, the item entity.
So for that, let's add a folder here called
entities. So people will say domain, as a
lot of people may see models, in our case,
entities should be good enough. Let's create
a file here, let's call it
item. That's Yes.
Let's follow the right namespace here.
So the next page should be catalog as he's
wearing the ntds folder, let's say entities.
And then
what you would usually do at this point is
declare a class, right, so you would say public
class and let's say it. However, since a dotnet,
five and a C sharp nine, there's a new option
here for you, which is what we call the record
types. So record types are pretty much a pretty
much classes. But they have better support
for immutable data, immutable data models,
right, which means that once you get a one
instance of this object, it is not possible
to really modify it. And that's pretty convenient,
especially for objects that you receive over
the wire. So all of these are coming from,
from the web, usually use one to take them
and do something with them, but you don't
want to modify them. Right. Also, record types
have this thing called with expression of
who you're going to see later on in this tutorial.
And then also a provide ability to compare
based on a value. So validated equality is
what they call, which this means that
when you compare a two instances of these
a of an item, in this case,
those instances will be equal, only if all
of the properties of that instance are the
same, as opposed to just the identity of the
object itself, which will be the case of classes.
So record types are pretty handy, I think
are a great option for the for the objects
that we're going to be using here, over here.
So
let's switch class for record. There, it is
time to introduce the properties for this
record. So let's add just a few properties
here. So let's see. So let's use a good for
our ID.
And let me import that system, your system
namespace was missing there. And then before
adding more properties, let me actually make
a small change here. So instead of using Get
set, let's switch to it. So why you seen it.
This is another addition in the in C sharp
nine in dotnet. Five, which it's a great fit
for,
for a property initializers. That where we
want to only allow a setting a value during
initialization, right. So this means that,
for instance, in the past, you could say you
could say, Get set. What this means is that
after you create the object, you can just
modify in this case, the ID a time. So that's
not really desirable, we want an immutable
property. So for immutable, we will have to
set
privates, right. So yeah, so this makes it
immutable. But now it is pretty challenging
to construct any set of these objects. Now
we have to introduce a constructor. And then
our customers don't have a really nicer way
to go through our objects. So to get into
a good middle ground there, they introduced
the the init accessor here. So this means
that
you can use a creator creation expression
to construct this item object, as you will
do with a with a set. But after the creation,
you can no longer modify these property. So
it's a very nice a balance between the two
words in there. I will see how this plays
out later on. So at this point, let's just
define our properties. So let's see. Let's
add Of course, name.
Name.
It's great to be studying name
Oh,
Also in it, let's add,
let's add a price for our item.
Price, also in it.
And finally,
let's add
a time offset. This is
great.
So this is going to be the date and time where
the item got graded in the system. Let's also
not forget to change this to it.
Now it is time to introduce our repository,
which is the class that is going to be in
charge of storing the items in the system.
To keep things simple For now, we will only
use an in memory repository. And a few episodes
later in the tutorial, we will bring in a
proper database.
So let's create a new folder here called depositories.
And here, we will add a new file. Let's call
it
hidden man itemtype was 30.
The writing space here not forget that it's
going to be catalog that people see 30s.
Right.
And now, let's create a class. So
holy class, I'll just grab the name from the
main file.
Right?
We're going to do here, like I said, this
is in memory. So we're just going to define
a very simple list of items that
are going to be the initializers that we're
going to be working with. So let's declare
a lease here. So let's see write rate and
make it read only because it should not change.
I mean, the instance of the lease should not
change after we construct this repository.
object.
It's good to be a list of item
we used to fight him.
And I think,
yep, so these the item items.
And yes, we need to import the
couple of namespaces their collection generic
for the least. And that other entities for
the item.
And we want to say this is new.
And we want to declare the list. Now these
one another addition in C sharp nine.
As you see here in the past, you may have
needed to say okay, so this is new list of
item, right? But that's a bit redundant. Since
we already know clearly this is a list of
item. So why, why so much ceremony, so let's
just remove this. And that's all you need
to do at this point. So nice addition, C sharp
nine.
So let's add a few items here. So let's say
new item.
And let's, let's do
the initialization here. So let's just do
random go it.
You go it for the ID. Again, let's import
the museum a space. And so for the name. And
so
like I mentioned in the introduction, I like
to play with these ideas in terms of video
game items. So the first item that I'm going
to choose here is abortion. Super classic
in these video games. And let's say the price
for that one is going to be just nine. And
for created date. Well, I'll just say
they offset
it etc. Now. So that means right now in terms
of UTC, so not the local time, just the UTC
time.
And do assess we need these one, let's add
a
couple more.
So same a good. I mean, get a new GUI for
each of these ones. But let's call this one.
It's going to be a idles word, resort. And
let's say it's going to be more expensive.
Make it 20. And then for the last one, let's
say we're going to do
rose shoot.
Got to be a bit cheaper, let's say.
All right. Oh, there is we have our initial
list of items ready to go.
Now in this repository, we're going to have
to deal with a bunch of things, right. So
how do we get an item? How do we get a collection
of items? How do we create an item update,
delete all these things. So to get in simple,
let's start with a get. So we're going to
do to get metals here.
The first one is going to be get items for
getting items if we're going to do, we're
just going to return an ienumerable of item.
items. Right? So a nominal is pretty much
the very basic item, it is a basic interface
that you can use to return a collection of
items.
And then yeah, that's always got to be as
simple as say, well, as yours return, whatever
we have in items right now, it is
that sort of get items method. And the next
one is going to be similar. But this guy is
going to return just one item, it's going
to be named get item.
But this is going to need to know the ID of
the item to return. Right?
Start. And then. So in order to retrieve the
correct item, what we're going to do is you
say Okay, so let's return from the items collection.
And I'm going to say where these requires
important yet another namespace sit in that
link importing now.
And so we're going to say, okay, so from that
list,
where the item
ID
equals the ID that we got in the parameter.
And that's going to return a collection. But
we don't want the collection, which is one,
the one item that that he should find all
the folder where the file is going to be?
No. So if it finds the item, it will return
it. If it doesn't find it, it will return
null.
All right, so that makes up our repository.
And so the next thing to bring in is controller.
So like I said, the controller is going to
be a the class that receives a request that
has been sent by the client and handles it
properly. So let's add our controller class
then. So new file under the controllers, folder,
and
scenes, the reasons we are dealing with here
is a items. So the convention will be to just
name it. Items controller.
That's Yes. Right. And again, security right
namespace catalog, in this case is going to
be controllers, controllers. Alright.
So this controller is going to be
all the class items controller. And then the
interesting thing about controller classes
is that you always want to inherit from controller
base
that gives you and this also important namespace
here.
So that will effectively turn this into a
controller class, right? So let's always inherit
from controller base.
That's the first thing. The next thing is
to mark this class as an API controller. Right
there. Yeah, API controller. So this brings
in a bunch of additional default behaviors
for your controller class, that just makes
our life easier. So yeah, don't forget to
add API controller layer. And yeah, and by
the way, there's tons of documentation on
each of these a attributes, or the
next thing is to declare the route. So the
route defines a, to which a HTTP route, this
controller is going to be responding. And,
by default, what you would put here is just
the name of the controller. So if you do this,
this will mean that whatever the name of the
controller is, that's going to be the route.
Right? And so in this case, for instance,
let's say for a get,
it will do get slash items, right? That's
going to be part of the URL that we'll be
using.
So yeah, I mean, you can do it either that
way. Or you can explicitly declare a route
that you want to use, like, I could say, two
items, which is perfectly valid. And in fact,
let's stick with that.
And let's move forward.
Now, here in this controller, of course,
for any action, or any operation we're going
to do, we're going to be needing that repository
that we worked on a moment ago. So let's bring
in an instance of that. We're going to declare
private read only.
Again, because it's not going to be modified
after construction.
I suppose seat 3030. Right. And
Yep, for any space we have ready. Now, before
moving forward. Let me just tell you that
we'll be making a few not so ideal choices
as we move forward. Just to explain that
A bunch of concepts, right? So the fact that
I'm introducing explicit dependency into i
ng meme it suppository.
It's, it's not ideal, but I just want to do
to keep things simple and then improve as
we move forward. Right? So those just don't
take this as a final word on how you should
do this. Now, we're going to construct these
in the in the constructor of this controller.
So let's add a
high def controller as the constructor.
Okay, and then let's say yeah, so double storey
equals new name. It was, right. So boom, we
have a suppository right there, ready to be
used? So let's define our route state to find
a route. So let's see. How do we find a route
to retrieve all the items? On this storage?
let's declare a method called
Hi enumerable.
Item? Sorry, item, get items.
Okay, so these are methods that's going to
return an ienumerable of items just like the
repository. Let's import the right namespaces.
Are we missing here?
Okay.
But then also, in order for, for this method
to actually become a route and react to some
HTTP verb, you have to declare it the right,
the right attribute in this case, HTTP GET
is what we what we want to declare for this.
So by doing this, it means that when somebody
goes to perform a get against slash items,
this is a method that's going to be reacting
to that, right? I do see how
a few cases we pretty much have the same route,
but it is the verb that makes a distinction
into which method is going to be invoked.
Then what do we do in this HTTP GET? So fairly
straightforward, we're going to say, Okay,
so we have items is going to be a depository.
You remember, we created these get items method.
So we just invoke it, we have the items, and
then we return the items.
And that's all it is.
Okay, so with that, we should be able to test
this out and see how that goes. So I'm going
to hit f5 here.
Alright, going to go back to swagger. And
I'm going to use refresh the page that we
get open from the previous video. As you can
see, everything got refresh. Now there's no
more weather controller. Now we have an item's
controller. And we have our first route here
we use a get for items.
We not only that, we also have a schema that
describes a an item, how it will be laid out.
If we click on items. And let's see, try it
out. Let's see what we get.
And right here, as you can see, swagger will
show the the router boot executed, like we
said, it's a get on slash items. This this
is here, this is our host and the port. So
against localhost 5001 items. And
here's the result. So we have our three items
that we declared as static. Well, the initial
value for our items collection, right? Or
the potion, the sword and the shield, right?
This is working great.
Stop this and add our second route, which
is a route to return one specific item. So
this is going to be public
item, get item and then we receive good, right?
And then are we missing any space? Again,
let's see. Yes, focusing in a space. That's
where it is. And then just like before, we
just say, well, var item equals repository
dot get item. Okay, so here's the other method
that we added to the repository, we just pass
the ID, and we return that item.
Now, again, we need to mark a top like that
right bear here. So it is going to be an HTTP
GET. But in this case, there's a little additional
detail, which is the template. So we have
to provide a template where we specify
how we're going to treat another piece of
the route. Like in this case, the route is
not going to be just get slash items. It's
going to be good slash items. And the the
idea of the item, right, which is is that
piece of the big plate, I was just going to
put it like that. So would you request the
items is slash rF cific item ID then this
This piece is going to get executed. Right?
So yeah, let's see how that goes. I'll do
f5 again.
Okay, this is running back to swagger. Got
to just refresh the page. And as you can see,
now we have our second route available. Like
I said, this is slash items slash ID. So,
in order to execute that, let's Well,
let's actually execute the first one items
to get a list of all of our
items that we know about.
And let's grab the first one.
so dearly, we should be able to get that item
via the the other route. So gateway ad, so
let's try it out our basic item here, so these
how in open API swagger, you can introduce
values, right? And now execute that, see what
happens. So here's the executed route. So
you can see slash items and the slash the
actual ID. And then
interestingly, we are getting 204. Right?
So this means that something didn't go quite
as suspect.
What I'll do is I'll go back to Visual Studio
code, and I'll put a breakpoint over here,
see what we're getting. So go back to swagger,
UI, and execute.
Here, we got a breakpoint. And, right, we're
getting No, that's what's happening. So the
item has not been found. So why could why
would that be? Well, let's see. Here's our
items. And here's our get item. I made that.
And so, yeah, so really, what was happening
here is that anytime we make a request to
this to our controller to our, to our service,
we are actually creating, as you can see,
over here, a new instance of the in main items
are positivity. Right? So that means that
he's created, a brand new list is created
with a random set of new codes here. And of
course, when we try to use our previous use
it good, it will not find it, because now
we have a brand new list.
So I'm going to do a five, yesterday go and
this is a good actually a good thing, because
you have to realize that we need to deal with
that situation properly in in the controller.
So in this get item method, we should be a
not just returning an All right, so how do
we handle this? So let's stop it.
So I think that we probably want to do is
to return the proper status code HTTP status
code in the case that we can find the ID.
So
let's say so if item
is no all right, so let's return it something
different. So let's return
not far. So that's the way to actually ask
a dotnet to create the proper status code
for not found so we don't have to actually
figure out so I set a status code.
And then yeah, if it is found, they will just
go ahead and return the item. Now we do have
a problem here. Because now a in one branch,
we're trying to return this type, or not found
result in these other graduates right to return
just an item. So what is it going? I mean,
it's not like in it, right? We expecting to
always return an item. How do we deal with
this is a by the use of the action result
type. So if we do action result,
that actually allows us to return more than
one type from this method. So as you see,
there's no more errors, because now this is
saying, Okay, if if if you want to return
not found return not found, or if you want
to return the type that is in the a direct
tie right here, you're also able to do that,
right? Or we're going to also say something
like, Okay, if you wanted to, that's probably
fine. But now in this case, we can handle
both cases. So let's run this again, and see
what we get used to get the proper status
code for each of these actions to be properly
restful. So let's refresh this. Let's again,
let's get one of these items are going to
try it out.
Execute.
So good. Yeah, can you just get one of these
we know it's no good to find it. But get that
good. And then open up here, try it out
with ad and execute. So this time, we do get
a 404, which is the correct status code word
for not found, as you can see here,
in this third part of the dotnet five REST
API tutorial
We learn about the dependency injection technique,
and how to leverage it to properly inject
a repository instance to the items controller.
We also introduce the concept of data transfer
objects, and how to use them to establish
a clear contract with our API consumers.
Today, you will learn what is dependency injection,
how to register and inject dependencies in
dotnet. Five,
how to implement data transfer objects, also
known as dtos,
and how to map entities to details.
In a previous video, we were able to actually
create our entities, repositories and even
our controller to be able to get items and
our specific item. However, we find an issue
where we try to retrieve an item, we can retrieve
it, because as we found and just go back to
the code,
anytime we receive a request, in our items
controller, we are creating a new instance
of depository. And that's bringing a bunch
of new items in such a way that we are never
able to find, right. So how can we go around
it? I mean, how can we actually fix this the
right way?
So for these, there's a pretty important concept
that we need to learn here, and which is called
dependency injection. So let's talk about
that.
So what is dependency injection? Let's think
about our class, right, so we have a class,
which wants to make use of some other class,
where we have this kind of relationship, we
say that this other class is a dependency
of our class, right. And, in more concrete
terms, in our case, we have the itis controller,
which is constructor is a creating a new instance
of the repository ready in meme items repository.
Now, what we really want to do in terms of
dependency injection is flip things a little
bit. And instead of have a test controller
construct that instance, and I'll just open
up my highlighter here,
we will receive the repository in the constructor,
and then just take that, that, that reference
into the class. So at this point, we are injecting
the repository dependency into the IDS controller
class.
Now this is also brings in something very
important, which is the dependency inversion
principle, in which again, so we have a class,
and we have some dependency, let's call it
dependency a. And well, this class depends
on dependency a, but what we want to do is
just not take that kind of dependency, and
instead, have our our class depend on an abstraction,
which is, in this case, in C sharp, it is
an interface, right? So the class no longer
depends on dependency, it just depends on
some interface that dependency a will implement.
Right? So we have inverted the dependency
by having a class only depend on an interface
and dependency a implement that interface.
At the same way, I mean, as we do that, we
could bring in a dependency or any other dependencies
that also implement interface. But in this
case, you can imagine, now the repository
that I just control receive is just an interface.
So class in this case, has no idea of which
explicit dependency it is working with, could
be a B or any other dependency, as long as
they implement the contract, which in this
case, is the interface. And this instruction
class is very happy to work with it. Okay,
so that's, that is the dependency inversion
principle. And
well, the thing is, okay, so why why do we
want to do this? Well, really common reasons.
And yeah, like I said, like he says, right,
so by having our codependence dependent upon
abstractions, we're decoupling implementations
from each other. So it gives us much more
freedom in terms of moving around these dependencies,
without ever having to touch our class. And
this makes the coal cleaner, easier to purify,
and much easier to reuse. But I'm very wary,
so much easier to test.
But then, if we're going to do this, how are
we going to construct these dependencies,
right, because now we're just receiving them
in the constructor. So if we have all these
dependencies, dependency ABC, how are we go
the constructor constructor. So because our
class was to receive them, right? They were
going to inject them there. So comes into
play this thing called a service container,
which in terms of a dotnet five is an AI service
provider.
So what happens is that a during a application
application startup, we're going to register,
each of these dependencies are going to be
registered into the service container.
And then eventually, when the class gets instantiated,
the service, a service provider separate container
is going to take care of resolving any of
the dependencies needed by this class, like
it has a map of all the dependencies are needed
by each of our classes. So resolve the dependencies,
construct them, if needed. Only the first
time, of course, depending Well, actually,
depending on the application lifecycle that
has been set up for those dependencies for
the class. So if needed constructors, otherwise,
it will reuse it. And then it rejects the
dependencies.
And this is, in fact, what's going to help
us with little problem that we have right
now in the inner project where we want to
be constructed and constructing I mean, we
don't want to get a split dependency on the
regulatory, or we don't want to construction,
explicit construction of warnings as every
time we created the controller, we just want
to receive an East as if it's available, a
lot of constructed getting constructed first
time and get it all sorted by the service
container.
Let's see now how we can use dependency injection
to our advantage. So what I'm going to do
is I'm going to get back to the code. So let's
stop debugging close terminal. And so let's
fix the situation where we have this explicit
dependency on email it depository. So firstly,
we're going to need is some interfaces so
that I just controller does not really a operate
on concrete instances of the depository. So
let's go to a main idea posit Ori, and we're
going to do is just right click on the class
and
actually in the light bulb, and let's extract
interface. So that's going to create a interface
for us and makes it makes it possible to implement
that interface. Now, we probably want to take
the interface out into its own file. So let's
do that.
A new file,
let's actually call it a I items depository,
should be a better name for this.
Okay.
And so
thanks, space catalog, dipole stories. And
here's where we're going to bring in our interface,
I'm going to use cut
and paste here. It is a report a couple of
nice spaces, let's see, for the entities.
For CS for good. Collections generic, that
should do it. Alright, so we have our interface.
And here's the repository.
repository implements interface. So now that
we have the interface, let's go back to our
controller. And
let's switch this into I mean, this type into
i a items of repository
of policy
items.
For seat gaudy.
Make sure this is off. Yeah, we have to do
the right naming here for that
game. And now we've got the receive it here.
So I demonstrate depository. This is a boss
story.
And then just to not confuse things, let's
say this, that repository equals depository.
Alright, so yeah, so now we got the pennsy
injection working here. And no longer This
class has any idea of which repository is
going to use behind the scenes. Now, the only
thing we have to do here is to
what's going on here, actually, I was just
fixing that in our laboratory. The other thing
is that we have to do the registration, right.
So to do the hyperinflation of our depository,
or we're going to do is go to start up, configure
services. So this is the place where you register
all the services that are going to use it
across your service. And the service that
we need now is our history. So let's do services
that
add Singleton. Now there's a bunch of ways
to add a URI. To register your services here,
I'm going to be using a singleton so and a
singleton is nothing, nothing else, other
than just having one copy of the instance
of a type across the entire lifetime of our
service. So only one will be created. And
it will be reused wherever whenever it is
needed. So that's going to help us resolve
the problem that we have today. And so to
add the singleton fares, we specify the interface.
So
I added repository, which we may need to add.
Yes, we namespace. And then so that's the
interface. And then the concrete instance
is
in main items repository right?
That's it. So that's how you register your
dependency. And so
at this point, we should be ready to be ready
to go. So I'll do a five.
And now I'll switch to swagger.
So we have the same API as before, I'll refresh
anyways. And then let's try an exercise now.
So let's see, I'll try out our items, endpoint.
So I'll get one of our items.
And I should be able to find it now. So see,
items, Id try it out. I'll put it here and
there, let's try to find it execute.
You have a breakpoint here. Let's see. Yes,
this time, we can resolve no more, no, remove
that breakpoint, run back to swagger. And
then here it is, we got our response code
200, for the request of that item, and here's
all the body that is crucial.
So
as expected, now we only have one copy of
repository hanging around, which is injected
into the controller, and that allows us to
actually find the data we're looking for.
Now, there's one more thing to notice here
that we should fix right away. And which is
the fact that these
these routes that we have enabled right now
are enabling a or are exposing our item entity
directly to the outside. And we have to understand
that as we build REST API, we're also establishing
a contract with any of the clients that we're
going to be using, which is a contract that
we should not be breaking easily. And the
problem that we have right now is that since
we're exposing item, which is the item that
we're using for dealing with persistence,
we have versatility.
Anytime we want to add feel, I mean, anytime
we want to modify or remove any of the fields
that were that we're using in our inner storage,
right now, in the versatility, we can potentially
break our clients, right, break that contract,
which is really no goal for us to build these
REST services.
So how can we avoid exposing these item contract
there? So let's, let's take a look, let's
go back to the project. Let's actually find
that entity. So we have item here. And as
we said, we are returning it both in get items
and get the item. So what we're going to do
now is introduce what we call a DTO or a data
transfer object. So data transfer object is
nothing else other than the the actual contract
that's going to be enabled between the client
and our service. And to do that, we're going
to do introduce a new folder here. Let's call
it videos.
And let's add a new file for our item dt.
All right. All right in the deal. So again,
namespace catalog, in this case is going to
be videos.
And the identity is going to be fairly similar
to our item, actually.
So let's want to just copy
the item.
And so
going to add missing spaces.
here and there. Yep. And, yeah, I mean, in
this case, it happens to be that the item
that we want to return in our methods is pretty
much the same as the item that we will be
storing in a repository or retrieve the depository.
So we use, okay, seems a bit redundant right
now. But the benefits become evident as you
move forward as you start modifying your database.
You don't have to be touching this contract,
or you can be very careful with the contract,
or supposed to be breaking our clients anytime.
So this gives you a lot of flexibility as
you evolve your data store.
So now that we have, actually let's rename
this to item DTO. Sorry for that. Okay, I
think the deal. And now that we have that,
it is time to start using it right, so let's
go back to iTunes controller.
And so at this time, what we'll need to do
is to convert the iTunes or we're getting
started with good ideas, right, we have to
convert these in from item into identities.
One way to do this would be to just do a simple
projection with link. So we would do a select
and then maybe missing the link a space here
to add it. I'm going to say okay, so I tend
to
project into a new item DTO
and I may need to add any space here. There
it is.
So here we're going to bringing the properties,
right, so I'm going to say alright, so Id
is equals item.id.
name equals item name, same thing. Price.
Okay, so now we have a our items collection
is a collection of items, we do
think we're missing parentheses here.
And we return
those items, no longer item, there has to
be item B to
setting up the contract. Okay, so, yeah, so
that should do it, we have to inform the item,
do it and do. And as you may guess, we have
to do pretty much the same thing over here,
right?
This point, it will be a bit redundant, right?
So why will want to do this transformation
twice with exactly the same properties. So
one way that we can overcome this is by adding
an extension method. So let me show you what
I mean by that. So I'm going to add a new
file here, we're going to call it extensions.
Games. So good luck. And then what extension
does addition metal does is it just will extend
the definition of a one a type by adding a
sum a method that can be executed on that
type. So in this case, we're going to add
a class only static class or for extension
methods, you have to use a static class, there's
a way to go,
extensions.
And then we're going to declare one method
here. public static is going to return item
DTO.
And we're going to call it as DTO. What is
going to it's going to operate on the current
item
does, that's what this method means. So again,
let's add some namespaces here.
So this method receives an item right, by
by using this here, it means the current item
can have a method called as DTO, that returns
its identity or version.
So at this point, we can probably take advantage
of what we did here. So let's see, this is
what we used to create activity Oh. So we
can say well return new identity or out of
the item that we received.
Ladies, we have an efficient method ready
to be used. So now we will go to adjust controller,
what we can do is instead of all of this,
we can say so item is projected into it, and
that as the deal.
That's all it is. Let's collapse this a bit.
With that, we can also use the same method
over here. So when we get the item, we will
say as you do, of course, we need to change
this into our do contract.
And then the rest. Actually, I will do this.
So let's just get the item first. Check if
it is no, if it's not, then we do the CTO.
Okay, so now that we have done that, let's
see how that goes. So I'll do a five again.
Okay, back to swagger.
And I'm going to refresh this. And let's see
if this still works. So items, I'm going to
try it out. Execute. And yeah, just before
we can get the list of items. But this time,
if you scroll down, you will see the disclaimers.
The contract we're exposing to our consumers
is no longer an item but it is item to do
with the properties posted right here.
In these four parts of the dotnet five REST
API tutorial, we introduce additional controller
actions for creating, updating and deleting
items. We will also learn how to validate
the incoming dtos to prevent invalid data
from landing in the service.
Today, you will learn how to create resources
with post how to validate the values of DTO
properties,
how to update resources with good
and how to delete resources we delete.
It is time now to introduce the rest of our,
our routes, right so route for both to create
an item, route for update, delete, or update
the item and the route for Delete to be able
to delete a date.
So let's start with post. Right. And before
doing anything else, what we're going to have
to do is to update our repository to be able
to have that create that route for creating
an item right
So let's do that. And I'm going to start again,
by going to the interface, that's the first
thing to do. And so let's declare
void, create item,
item item. Okay, so this new method just returns
nothing. And it only just received the item
that needs to be created into the depository.
Now let's switch back to the concrete in main,
it depositories. And I'm going to say, implement
interface. So that brings in a new method
right there. And CNC turning memory depositories,
this is as straightforward as just saying
items that add
item.
That's all it is.
And then now we want to expose these into
the controller, right, we start to add a route
the controller. But before doing that, we
got to realize that so the client is going
to be sending these, these items. And we will
have to establish another contract for receiving
that, that item, it cannot be identity or
because we don't need as many properties as
in identity or for the creation of an item.
So let's see what I mean by that. So I'm going
to go to our details folder, I'm going to
create a new file, let's call it
create identity Oh,
and add the space
catalog that videos. And then.
Okay, just like before, we're going to be
using record for this pretty convenient for
the tiers. And so now I've looked back at
it to, let's see, so what will make sense
to be sent by the client as we create an item.
So normally, the ID is auto generated in the
server side, right? So we don't need to be
passing in that ID, we do need a name and
a price. And likely the created date is going
to also be generated on this service. So we're
only going to include in these two
lists. So we have name and price. And that
will be for our create item DTO.
And now let's see how we can use it in the
controller. So back to the controller.
Let's see how we declare these a post route.
So it's going to be
public action result. Because again, we could
return more than one thing in this method,
things could happen. And
they call the convention for a post or a create
method is to create the item and return the
item that got created. So if we're going to
do that, we're going to we should be fine
to return the identity. Now that the conventions
here are going to vary. So some people will
create their own response object here, it
doesn't have to get into to it happens to
me that it works fine for us in this case.
So that's okay. So it's going to be called
right in
grade eight MBT Oh, that's going to be our
input contract. Item BPO.
Okay, and then let's qualify these with the
right verb. So each HTTP POST, and then just
for the communication will say so yeah. So
this is going to be invoked when somebody
does a post into the items route with the
correct body, of course.
So how do we create an item? So very straightforward,
we're going to say, well, item,
item equals new, we will have to find the
type. So thanks for sharp nine.
And then yeah, so let's just say ID equals,
here's what we actually
generate the ID for the item. So it's going
to be good, that new good.
So the name is identical to that name, same
for the price.
Price, and then the created date, as as you
would expect
a time offset that UTC now,
that's the item. And now we have to build
we'll take advantage of the repository method
we just created.
Create item, and then it goes there.
And then once the item has been created, a
convention here is to Yeah, I mean to return
the items that were created and also a to
return a header that specifies where you can
go ahead and get information about that graded
item. So to do that, what we can do is use
Created add action, you can also use create
route, that's another way to do it. gradient
action will work fine for us. Because what
we can do here is say, Okay, so what's the
action that we want? What's the action that
reflects
the route to get information about the item.
And that's going to be our get item action
right here.
So what we can do here is say, well, there's
going to be the name of get item.
And then when you specify the ID, that's going
to pass it to that order route. So for that,
let's create just a simple anonymous type
here.
With ID equals ID and ID. So that's a generated
ID. And then finally, the actual object that's
going to be returned, which is a thing. And
again, let's take advantage of our extension
method as DTO. So we take the identical created,
and then we just converted yesterday to.
And yeah, that's it. Let's do f5. See if this
works.
So back to swagger. Let's refresh this. So
now we have our post route over here, as you
can see, and also our grade identity is showing
up as a new contract that we're exposing torque
lights. So let's go to post. Try it out. And
as you can see, now we only need to provide
a name and a price.
Let's see for the name. But let's see, let's
bring in something like another type of support,
I guess, for let's see, a
de neumes sort to be a bit expensive, let's
say 35.
And yeah, so let's start let's execute,
see what we get. So as you can see, here's
the request URL the same as the get. But in
this case, it is a post, we have guarding
201, meaning a created art route. So he got
created a new sort. And as you can see here,
we have a location here that specifies Where
is that we can find that item.
So if we actually take this a these code here,
we go to our collapses and go to our get route.
Go to try it out. We're going to paste that
here. Execute. As you can see, now this is
the route that was provided in the location
here for post. And it actually is able to
find a developer a new source we just created.
And in fact, his use case, get the full list
of all the items. Try it out, execute. So
now we don't have your three we have four
items, including the deadliness.
But then let's also try one more thing. What
happens if I try to create something without
a name? Does that make sense? Well, let's
try it out.
There's the V that that was accepted. And
now we have an item with a no value, which
is totally unacceptable. And and again, in
fact, we use code to the get route and we
say, execute, we can see
we have an item with no, which is pretty bad.
How can we protect ourselves against that
situation. So there's this thing called a
data annotations, which is something we can
add to our DTO in this case, to prevent that
situation. So back into create identity, oh,
what we can do is just request that this field
is required.
And I'm going to add the data annotations
namespace in there. So it name has to be provided,
and price has to be provided. For price, don't
just add, let's do one more thing, let's say
there's going to be a range of possible values
for price because we should probably not accept
a negative value or even zero here. So let's
say that we're only going to set values from
let's say, from one to 1000, that should be
a valid range for us. So just by doing this,
we are protecting the values are going to
be coming into the controller. So I'm going
to do a five again.
And let's see how that goes. So back in swagger,
I'm going to be collapsing this route. So
back in post, I'll just try to do the same
thing again. Try to execute this. And this
time.
Now we have a 400. So bad request error. And
clearly it says here the Name field is required.
So now data validations are coming into place.
And so we must provide a name. Let's actually
play with the price here. Let's say I try
a negative number. Right see what happens.
If you have price must be between one and
1000. Right. So data notations for valuations
pretty useful for relating dot r or D do
Now it's time to implement our update route.
So let's go back to source code, close terminal.
And just like before, let's go back to our
a repository, I identify the interface and
add the relevant method. So let's say this
is going to be a void. Again, update item.
And this is going to receive the item to get
updated.
Very similar to create item. Now, back to
the concrete implementation.
I'm going to say, again, implement interface
that brings in the method data item. So how
would we update this item. So since it is
an in memory list,
really, the only thing that we have to do
is use find the relevant item and update it
with the incoming item, right. So to do that,
let's do this is find the index of the relevant
item. So I'm going to say items, find index.
And then so this is the existing item.
So you're going to find the existing item
where existing item ID matches
item.id.
Okay, so that's just finding the index of
the of the ID that we're looking for. And
we've found it, we can do items, index equals
item.
That's all it is. So we will update the item
in the right location. So it's time to go
back to the controller, well almost like to
go back to the controller, because, as you
may realize, at this point, we do need some
video to receive the input for the update
route. And even when that disables, you're
going to be pretty much the same as with great
identity, oh, these are good practice to actually
have a another a video for this case, because
you don't know right now is the same thing.
But eventually, it could be that an update
means something different than accurate. So
let's use to update identity Oh,
that's a copy of great identity, oh, pretty
much has the same properties is the only thing
that you can verify the name and the price.
And required and the range, right. So now
let's go back to the controller, right this
controller,
let's create out of the drought.
So this is going to be again,
public action result.
In this case, a convention for output is to
actually not return anything. So use what
we call no content. So it's going to be no
type here other than action result, it's going
to be called update item, we receive two things,
the first thing is the good of the idea of
the item. And then they are new update item
DTO.
Let's call it item DTO.
And then, let's not forget to add the correct
verb here is an HTTP put.
And just like we did before, the route is
going to be just for documentation, when you
to put into slash items, and then slash that's
the piece that we're missing actually here,
we need to also specify here the template
which is in this case is the ID. So that means
that when when we do a put, we have to certify
the ad in such a way
like these, right, so put items slash the
ID, and they will hit this method here. So
let's see. So first thing, so how we will
do an update, first thing to do is a Find
the Item. So existing item, it will use a
repository for that we already have a method
for this, which is get item
passing the ID. And then it will be great
to verify if this ID if these items actually
exist. So if an existing item is no, then
well, we couldn't find it. So we will just
return not found.
And at the end of story for that that branch.
And then if we find it if we found it, well,
we're going to do is just proceeded to do
the
we're going to create a new item, which is
the updated item in our system. So in this
case, we're going to say is item updated item
equals it essentially our existing item.
But with
a couple of differences. Like we need to use
a the name
of the provided identity. Oh, and the price
of that also provided identity. Oh
So, now here, I just use one 190 of a record
types that I mentioned when I was talking
about record type, which is the width expression
here. So what's happening here is that we're
saying, Okay, so we're taking this existing
item here, are we creating a copy of it with
the following two properties modified for
new values. So that's a very nice addition
into
records, and allows me to use what is really
an immutable type. But still, I can go ahead
and modify a some properties on initialization.
So if the item is just a copy of existing
item with a bunch of properties, like nice
addition, in record types, where we have this
updated item, we can go ahead and say, okay,
so repository that updated the method that
we just created, and send the bladed item.
And like I said,
the convention is to return no content, so
nothing to report just returned.
Let's try this out. f5.
And back to swogger refresh.
So here it is, our put
our port route. And before doing a port, let's
actually get a one of our a items.
So try it out, execute. So let's say we're
going to modify our potion here.
Okay, so the potion, I'm going to collapse
these up and put, so for put, we have to provide
an ID, and updated values here. So this is
a potion, let's actually rename it to, let's
say super potion.
Let's bump the price to I don't know, let's
say
29. So execute.
And then just as expected, we get 204, which
is no content. And you can see the route that
was executed here. And then if this succeeded,
we should be able to get a
updated version there. So I just get the full
list of all the items that we have. Now let's
see what happens. And there is no longer potion
super potion with updated price.
Also, notice down here that we do have a this
update identity are available now here, the
new contract.
So we'll update really, the last thing to
add is our delete route. So let's go back
to controller. So back to the project. Just
before, back to the repository interface.
Let's do void. The title,
we already already know we need for the reading
item is just to know the idea of it. So back
to the repository.
let's implement the interface
for delete item.
And actually, the item is going to be very
similar to update item, first thing that we
have to do is find the item, I mean the index
of the item. And now we can just say items
that we move at.
Look at
that index.
That's all it is. Sorry, we have to say it
here.
We had the opposite already. And now we can
look forward to the controller.
In this case, we're not going to need another
DPO. Because the only thing that's needed
here is to use a simple ID. So let's use implement
the controller action.
So public action result.
Delete item, just like with update, we're
going to return no content. So action result
delete item, good ID.
And let's add the verb. So this is going to
be an HTTP delete. Again, documentation. So
these are going to haunt or delete slash items.
And then slash, let's not forget our template,
which is the ID slash items ID.
And to perform the deletion, similar, certainly
with similar to update. So let's try to find
the item first. And we'll just copy that base
there. So not found if we can't find it. And
then we go ahead and to repository, that delete
item and it
just like we did before, return, no content
and that's all it is so f5
and by
swogger refresh again. And now you can see
we have our delete action available. So let's
come to the name of one of our items and see
if we can delete it to execute this. So let's
try to delete that potion,
copy,
collapse, expand, try out,
put ad and execute. So here's the route. We
got 204 is expected, no content. So if I tried
to get the items again, let's see what happens.
All you have to, so no more potion habido
here.
And yeah, so that will be at the end of our
routes.
In this episode of The dotnet five REST API
tutorial, we will see how to start our entities
in a persistent store. Specifically in a MongoDB
database, we will implement a simple MongoDB
repository that can replace our existing emancipatory
with minimal changes to our service.
Today, you will learn how to implement a simple
MongoDB repository, how to run MongoDB as
a Docker container,
and how to use postman to interact with the
REST API.
Starting with this episode, you will need
a couple of other things to follow the video
step by step
Docker, which we will use to run a local MongoDB
instance.
And postman, which we'll use to interact with
the rest API's from Iran.
Now let's think about the scenario as it is
right now. We have our user who is trying
to manage his items via the browser. And he
will do that by reaching out to our REST API.
And more specifically, by reaching out to
the IRS controller, which is where or all
of our routes let at this point. Now, I just
controller will interact with the inmate item
depository
to manage these items. And the items are actually
stored inside the main depository as a simple
items collection right.
Now, what happens if the REST API for any
reason stops, either eat stops or is restarted,
and it could happen, either explicitly or
unintentionally. But it is a really common
scenario that a service would need to be restarted.
If this happens, of course, our items collection
is going to go away, because it's just a collection
in memory, right? This is all desired, we
need to figure out a way to keep these items
alive beyond the lifetime of the REST API.
So what are these, we have a few options.
And I can think of first very basic option
will be to using files. So you can think of,
well, I'll have one file for each of the items
in the repository.
But really, the most common option these days
would be to use a database. And in terms of
databases, we have 1000s of options. But you
can categorize them into relational and no
SQL databases.
In this tutorial, we will go for a no SQL
database. And the reason for this is well,
because of the benefits that it offers, beyond
the fact that no SQL databases are one of
the most popular options these days, there's
the fact that you won't need a schema or SQL
to interact with the database. I mean, you
don't have to learn SQL yet another language
here, you can just stick to your object oriented
programming. And in our case, today, she's
C sharp API's.
And you also have low latency, high performance
and these because
there's no need for strong consistency as
it as it would be in a relational database.
And also, these are highly scalable.
In our case, we'll go specifically for MongoDB,
which is it is a no SQL database, and specifically
is a document storage type of database. So
it stores a the entities as documents, specifically
as JSON documents inside the database. So
this is we're going to use for this tutorial.
So you can think that now we will have this
database living outside of our race API.
And now, when a controller receives a request,
it will actually hand it over to a new repository
called a MongoDB. I just have visited it,
that's what we're going to create here.
And even if our services stopped and restarted,
the database will not be restarted at all,
our data will be saved in there. And that
way, we can keep our items beyond the lifetime
of the REST API.
Before we start implementing our MongoDB repository,
I wanted to show you one more tool that you
will probably find useful as you interact
with your API's and they want to so is postman
and you can get it in the postman downloads
page. If you had no
done already?
And why would you use postman for. So if you
remember, so far we've been using this page,
the swagger UI for interacting with all of
our API's.
However, the problem here is that eventually
you may not want to be opening, you know,
web pages do interact with each of your API's.
And these API's may not even be in your host,
they may be somewhere. So what else were you
there may not be a swagger UI. So you do need
a way
to interact with them.
Plus, you may need some additional capabilities
that are just not available in this page.
So that's where postman can help you. So in
this case, let me open a postman right here.
So how we can interact with your APIs in postman.
So it's as simple as clicking the plus sign
here. And the first thing that you have to
do is pick a verb that you're going to use.
In our case, let's just try I get that you're
going to read the request URL, all of those
URLs are going to start with your host. And
so in our case, let's see what's your host,
let's do an f5 in VS code. And as you may
recall, our host Ace and is one of the last
lines here for the HTTPS endpoint is going
to be localhost 5001. I'm going to copy this
back to postman, paste that. And then if you
remember, our route, going back to VS code,
now, our route is a
starts over route, start with items right,
right here. So that will be the route that
we want to use in postman. So just type here,
items. And that should be enough to perform
I get. So I'm going to just going to see click
Send.
And then if you get this problem here, this
issue that says SSL error, unable to verify
the first certificate, this is because of
the SSL verification that postman is performing.
But this such verification will just not work
with the self self signed certificate that
comes with dotnet five. So in this case,
what you want to do is just disable SSL verification,
and that should be fine. So you can just click
here.
And that will run the request. Again, as you
can see, it ran the request. And we have the
resource over here. Same results that we had
in swagger UI before. But now, we are interacting
more directly more directly with that API,
the same way that we need to get you can do
post put and a bunch of other verbs here.
We will do so as we move forward with this
with this episode of the tutorial.
So now let's go back to VS code.
And I'm going to stop the host here and close
terminal. And I'm going to close it with controller.
So the first thing that we want to do is to
implement a new repository
to be able to interact with a MongoDB database.
For that, I'm going to create a new file.
We're going to call it Mongo DB. Items repository.
Right.
Thanks space.
Got a look. depositories
game. So it's going to be called for league
class MongoDB. depository. And just what are
your sweet as with our email it suppository,
we are going to implement items repository.
We may need to import a namespace here, I
will implement the interface.
And just by doing that we have VS code has
scaffolded all the methods that need to be
implemented to comply with these interface.
Now in order to interact with MongoDB, we're
going to need a what is called a MongoDB.
client. So the client is
is a component provided by the creators of
the owners of MongoDB that you can use to
interface will be kind of the adapter that
used to interact with MongoDB.
So we'll need to inject that a as we as we
everything else, we need to inject that dependency
into our repository so that we can interact
with it. So the first thing I'm going to introduce
here is our constructor. So let's see. folic
MongoDB is capacitor.
And here is where we need to receive an instance
of our MongoDB client.
Where do we get this MongoDB client from?
So to do that, we'll have to add a nougat
package. Plug the nougat package what I'm
going to do is open up a new terminal
and here I'm just going to die
dotnet package MongoDB that driver, enter,
that's going to go to noget, grabs the MongoDB
nougat package. And if you go to catalog CS
Pro, you're going to see that now we have,
we have the dependency right here.
Oh back to the repository, we are able to
start doing the injection.
So let's see, we're going to receive here
in the constructor is what we call an eye,
Mongo client,
to listen port import the correct namespace
here MongoDB driver, and we will call it Mongo
client.
And now what is it that we're going to store?
We're going what we want to store here is
not really the client, but what we call a
collection. So the collection is the way that
MongoDB associates all these entities together.
So I'm going to declare a variable here.
I wrote it with only
because we only modified in constructors is
read only variable, I Mongo collection. And
that you have to specify the type that that
of the items, the type of the entities or
documents, actually in this collection, our
type is going to be our item entity.
And his colleague, items collection.
However, before we can get a collection, we
need a couple of other details, which is the
database name, and the collection name. So
usually, like all of your document, yeah,
all of your documents are going to be a grouped
into collections. And you can have one or
more collections in a database. So the first
thing we have to add here is the name of our
database. So let's just add a constant here
is call it database name.
And probably a good database name here would
be use catalog.
And now let's add a collection name. So private
string,
collection name.
collection is going to be called items.
Now that we have these available, this go
back to constructor,
and we actually close the terminal for now.
And what we can do is the following. So first,
let's get let's get an instance, let's create
a reference to the database. So I'm going
to say I Mongo database database equals Mongo
client that get database. So database name.
So that will get us a reference to that database.
Now we need a reference to the collection.
So items collection,
is the variable that we say that we declared
before equals database that get collection,
and then the type of the item
and then the name of the collection.
And then the good thing about this is that
both database and the collection will be created
the first time that they are needed. So it
doesn't matter which API we use to interact
with the database and collection MongoDB.
Or I guess the driver will detect if we don't
have them, and they will be created automatically
for us to we don't have to worry about it.
So we have a few a few methods to implement.
So to get started, we'll go for the Create
item method. And we'll start implementing
one by one and exercising each each one as
we move forward in this video. To implement
create item, what you want to do is just make
use of that items collection. So you can say,
items collection that insert one, and then
you just pass the reference to the item. So
in this case, it will be just item.
So at this point, you may be wondering, where
is this database is MongoDB database that
we're going to interact with?
Because Yeah, I mean, we have the code here
ready to create an item, but we don't have
a database. So there's a couple of ways to
get a MongoDB database into your box. So you
can either install the database via the MongoDB
installer, or you can run the database as
part of a Docker container.
We're actually going to go for the second
one. And the first concept to understand on
that side is a Docker image. And
I mean, we're not going to go deep into Docker
concepts here where we're actually going to
talk about that in a future video. But for
now, you can think of our Docker image as
a standalone package of software. That includes
really everything needed to run an application.
This application in our case is MongoDB. So
everything is packaged in this Docker image.
Then, when we run or when we execute this
Docker image, it becomes what we call a Docker
container. So is a running instance of a Docker
image.
That Docker container is going to run in the
Docker engine.
So how do you get this Docker engine into
your box. So you just go to the Docker download
page, which I can show you now, right here,
did you go to this page, you pick your platform,
and then you can go ahead and download and
install Docker in your box. Then you have
a Docker engine.
And you're able to run any of the Docker images
available publicly, like MongoDB, or perhaps
some private Docker images that you may be
storing in your own Container Registry. In
this case, we're going to go for the A MongoDB,
a public Docker image, let's see how we can
acquire it, we can run it. So first thing
we're going to do is go to terminal, say new
terminal,
we're going to type the following
Docker run,
then we're going to use the dash d dash dash
RM modifier This is so that we don't have
to attach to the process. So we just let it
go. And RM is so that if the image is actually
sorry, the container is destroyed after we
close the process. So then, we're going to
give it a name, Mongo so that we can easily
recognize which image is this. And then we're
going to open a port, that port is going to
be 27, zero 1727, zero 17. So this syntax
here means that we want to open, let's say,
we're going to open kind of a window or a
view into the Docker container. MongoDB usually
listens in Port 27, zero 17.
So what we have to do is we have to open some
local ports as in the local machine, we have
to open some port that can be mapped into
the MongoDB port inside the Docker container.
So this is the way that you would do it, you
could assign actually any other port externally
on the left side. But on the right side, you
have to point to that to the MongoDB port.
Finally, we're going to specify a volume.
And the purpose of this is so that you don't
lose the data that has been stored in MongoDB.
When you stop the Docker container, okay,
if you don't do this, then you will lose all
that data as you start getting the content.
So let's declare this volume MongoDB data
is going to be the name
that is going to be mapped into data dB. Here,
slash data slash dp is the usual location
where MongoDB
is going to store the data inside the container.
And we're just saying where we're going to
map this location called MongoDB data from
our local machine into the slash data slash
dv directory inside the Docker container.
And finally, we have to specify the a the
name of the image, in this case Mongo,
then I'm going to hit enter,
perhaps I can expand this terminal a bit.
So the very first time that you run a Docker
image is going to pull it down from in this
case from Docker Hub, into the machine. So
that may take a while depending on your internet
connection. But as you can see, there's there's
multiple lines here. Each of them represents
what we call layers. So each of them has some
piece of this Docker image, including all
the dependencies. So like I said, this is
just the first time next time is going to
be blazing fast on as long as you have those
people's lives already in your box. So now
we have the Docker image both into the box,
and even Docker container running. If I actually
do docker ps, I can see that I have the Docker
image up and running and listening in this
port 27, zero 70.
I'm going to close the terminal. And so
what we need to do now is to be able to point
to that to that Docker image. So to do that,
we need to write a little bit of configuration.
So I'm going to open up settings Jason.
So the basic two pieces of information that
we're going to need in order to talk to the
database are the host and the port. So for
that,
I want to introduce a new, a couple of new
settings here. And let's call these MongoDB
settings.
Like I said, we're going to need a host
and we're going to need a port.
So, in the case of a MongoDB instance that's
running in your in your machine, you can refer
for the host you can just call it localhost.
And as we said, the port that we opened in
the Docker container was 27, zero 70.
Those are the details that we need to talk
to them to the to MongoDB. Now in order to
read these settings into our service, I mean
there's a
bunch of ways to do it. But I think the best
way is to declare a class that represents
the settings so that we can easily interact
with the multiple settings from our C sharp
code. To do that, we're going to introduce
a folder here, let's call it settings.
ukoliko, call it configuration options. There's
a bunch of ways, I'll go for settings. So
let's add a file here, let's call it
sorry,
Mongo DB settings.
And, again, namespace, got a look that settings
in this case, this declared a class.
Let's call it MongoDB. settings. And here,
we're going to declare those settings that
we saw in app settings, Jason this, this declared
them as properties. So our first property
is going to be
prop string cost.
And the next one
public int port, so this is an integer.
And then, let's actually take advantage of
this class here, to calculate the connection
string that's going to be needed in order
to talk to MongoDB.
So what we can do here is actually a read
only property.
So let's see.
Let's let's do this
string, let's call it connection string.
Okay, we're going to remove the set, we don't
need to any sailors in there, this gate, we're
going to open up.
So that becomes a read only property here,
we can just return the calculated connection
string. So we need to do a little bit of string
interpolation here. So what I can say that
they connect normally, a MongoDB connection
string looks like this. So
MongoDB,
lashes lash, and then here comes a host, and
then comes abort.
So those are going to get from the properties,
host and port, the properties that we declared
over there.
So with these, we have an easy way to grab
the connection string, as long as we have
populated host and port. Now that we have
this, it is time to perform the registration
of that a MongoDB, a client, a Mongo client,
that we injected into the MongoDB, it was
30. So this client here
has to be registered somewhere, right? And
as of right now, what we know is that we do
that stuff in startup. So just open up startup.
And here, let's go to configure services.
That's what you register all your all your
services, we're going to do this services
at Singleton because we only want one copy
of the Mongo, the IMO client for the entire
service.
I'm Mongo client. We made it important namespace
here. Yep.
And then here, instead of just declaring the
type of the explicit type of the dependency
to inject, as we did over here, in this other
thing, you don't, what we're going to do is
actually construct explicitly that type.
So that it is injected with the additional
configuration we do this week, because we
have to specify a connection string that that
a client is going to need. So to do that we're
going to do is say, Okay, so we're going to
say service
service provider,
we're going to receive that service provider.
And then we open up braces, going to add column
there. And then over here, we can do things
like First, let's actually grab the A, the
the settings. So an instance of those settings
that we have populated in app settings. Jason,
let's grab them via our MongoDB settings class.
How do we do that? So back in startup, it's
two bar settings.
You can use your configuration property, the
one that we have over here that has been populated
by the runtime, you can use that one to say
get section.
And then
so now you need to get a one of the sections
in the opposite is the case and we name it
MongoDB settings, which is the same name as
our MongoDB settings, settings class. Therefore,
what we can say is
just name off
MongoDB settings
sorry,
Let me type this properly DB settings. And
then we need to import that namespace.
Alright, so that will get us a section. And
then let's actually turn that an object which
is returned as I configuration section, let's
turn it into a proper MongoDB settings
like this.
So now we have a setting subject. And now
we can actually construct our Mongo client
instance with
return new Mongo client. And then we will
do settings that connection string, the property
that we calculated in that class.
So we that we should be ready to register
and inject the client into the repository.
Now that we did that, it is time to actually
flip our service to start using our new MongoDB
depository. So that we can do in this line,
you remember, we previously registered the
email it was it already. So switching to this
other depository is as easy as you're saying
here.
Mongo DB items repository.
That's all it is.
And then one more thing that we're going to
do here just to make our lives a bit easier,
is to tell the MongoDB, a client, the driver,
how to serialize a couple of types in this
case is going to be a the codes and the date
time offsets. If you remember our entity item,
it has both agreed on a date time offset.
And I think our MongoDB is that if you don't
tell it, how exactly we want to reflect this,
these types in the database, they may end
up with
a representation that's not very friendly,
at least not for our learning purposes. So
what I'm going to do is say, let's say these,
so I'm going to do
these on serializer.
See if I can get the right namespace,
register serializer. Today, we're going to
say new COVID
serializer.
And it's going to be
be some type.
Let's collapse this coordinate space, that
string that tells delsey that anytime it sees
a good in any of our entities, it should actually
serialize them as a string in the database,
we're going to do something very similar with
our date, time, date time offsets. So just
copy that line. And I'm going to say, date
time offset to your laser
based on type string.
And we'll see how these properties how the
data actually looks like in the database in
a moment. But for now, we should be ready
to start testing this out. So I'm going to
hit f5 here.
And I'm switching again to postman.
Here we're going to start logging in again.
Because we have not implemented that we can
start with a post.
So to do a post, just, I just opened a new
tab, and I'm going to switch the verb to post.
We need the request URL. So we can grab that
from our previous proper use right here.
Should be that same URL localhost 5001 items.
But what we're going to do, we're going to
need in this case is a body, right, so the
body the payload that we're going to send
to our API. So we'll switch to row here. And
then we're going to switch here to Jason.
Let me minimize this a bit.
So here, we will just a type, the JSON that
represents the entity that we want to create
that JSON is going to be composed of a name,
if you remember, it's just going to be a name
and
a price.
So trying to pick a name and a price. So for
our first item in their database. Let's say
we go for a
great x, and price is going to be let's say
22.
So that's all we need for a post. And then
we're going to hit sent.
And as you can see, the item got created 201
created.
And we can see the response that we got from
the API. We got an ID, how to generate it
in MongoDB and a created date created via
our controller.
We can also check out the heaters that we
received here. And as soon as we returned
a created at action. You can see how the location
heater has been populated as
With the proper URL to retrieve the details
about that item, but then also how does this
item actually looks like in the database if
you're curious. So how can we tell that. So
let's go back to VS code. And let's stop this
and close terminal, what we can do is install
a MongoDB extension for Visual Studio code.
So I'm going to open extensions hop over here.
And I'm going to type MongoDB,
in this case, is the first entry over there.
So just click Install.
And with that, we have a way to talk to our
MongoDB instance, I'm going to close this
one. And if you see, there's a new item on
the left side MongoDB when you click it,
and then there's a connection to already establish
or defined there for localhost. 27, zero 17.
This may fail the first time you try to connect.
So if it does fail, what you can do is just
not going to do it, I'm going to remove this
connection, or I'm going to add it again.
Add connection, localhost 27, zero 17 is the
default, and
close the STS and that, and then we're not,
we're not using authentication at this point.
So let's say no.
And then hit Connect. And you're going to
see on the left side that you have a connection
to your local instance of MongoDB
going to collapse these and these.
As you can see, there's a few databases here.
And some of them are really default databases
for MongoDB. The one that we cared about what
those are closest, now that we care about
is the catalog database that I'm going to
open. As you can see, we already have both
the catalog database and the items a collection
over there.
We disband these. And you can see that we
have one document for us open up that and
these good here should match the good of the
item created. So let's see FCO 27, open up
postman is right here.
Sorry, the body of the response, FC 27. So
that's the item back to VS code. And if you
click over there, you can see the actual data
that's stored in there. So as you can see,
this is suspected as as of our document database,
it is storing the data as Jason directly into
the database, we have an ID, the name, price
and degraded date. If we had not done these
two lines here, these reducers realize it
lines here, the data you would see either
for ID and for created date would be in pretty
much in a different format, that will not
be very human friendly. But you may want to
play with that decision a little bit depending
on on your requirements.
I'm going to close this.
And I think it's time to implement a tournament
winning auto route. Where are other methods
in the depository, let's actually go for the
get items route. First,
how to implement get items,
the only thing you have to do is this. But
let's say return scope to our collection,
I just collection, we're going to say find.
And here, since we want all the elements in
that collection, we're going to just say new
visa document.
Oops, there will be some document, I'm going
to import namespace.
And then that will find all the documents.
And then you're going to say to list.
So that will give us a list of all the items
in the in the collection. So we found on respected
a way to request all the items. But this is
just one of the ways to do it. There's a few
other ways. But yeah, this will get all the
items in there. So with that, we can try to
get items. So I'm going to do a five again.
Back to postman.
And happens do we already have the gate for
is open here. So it should be as easy as running
these again. So just going to click Send.
And there it is. We're getting our collection
of items. And
see if you only have one right now, why not
create a few other ones just to have a small
list here, as we had before. So I'm back into
the post page, the post tab, and I'm going
to add a couple of other items. So let's say
How about an antidote
as this let's make it 15. So he'd sent three
if he created and then one more let's add.
Call this worked
for the golden sward is going to be more pricey
say 40.
It sent
created and then if we go back to get it sent.
Now we have those three items available. As
you can see
Okay, now what if we have to get just one
item.
So that's what we,
for that we need to implement our get item,
or our get item method here.
But before we can implement this, there's
one thing that we're going to need is what
MongoDB calls as a filter definition builder.
And that's a way that you can kind of filter
the items that you want to return as you find
them in the collection. Since this is a pretty
common object that we're going to use across
multiple methods here, I'm going to actually
just declare it up here as its own local variable.
Sorry, class variable. So I'm going to say,
private read only filter defini shim builder,
then we have to specify the type in this case
is going to be item. Let's call it filter
builder.
And then we're going to use the builders object
MongoDB. of type item, again, that filter,
so that we have a reference to this filter
object that you will to see how we use it
now. Forget it.
So but to get item,
we're going to do this. So first of all, to
build this a filter. So we're going to say,
bar filter
equals filter builder that equals So where
the item
item that ID.
So the ID of the item has to match the ID
that we have received as a parameter. That's
the filter. And then we just have to do similar
to before items collection, find, we passed
a filter.
And then we don't want all the items, we just
want the one item that they should find. So
we're going to say, single or default.
That's all it is. With that, I'm going to
say five again.
And back to postman.
So this time, I'm going to open up another
tab, I'm going to paste the route forget.
But now I have to specify one of the items.
So from our previous exercise, let's say that
we want to look information about the last
insert. So I'm going to copy this
ad. And I'm going to paste it in the route
item slash the item ID, and I'm going to hit
send.
And here is we were able to query for one
specific item, as opposed to all the items
back to VS code is time to implement our update
method update item. So similarly to suit ticket
item, we need to introduce a filter so that
we can tell which item to update.
Here. Now, we have to really find these slightly,
because we don't want to have so many variables
named item. So to avoid confusion. So the
item the existing item is going to be named
existing item.
Existing item that Id should match the item
that we got that ID, which is the item to
update.
And then what we do when we find it is items
collection,
replace one
filter item. So that we'll go ahead and replace
that item into the MongoDB database.
Let's look at five and try it out.
Five, back the postman.
And then what are we going to copy the gate
route and open another tab here
and use our put.
So basic there.
And then we have to switch, switch to body
row. I'm going to be again, Jason. Then we
bring this down. And we have to put the body
here. So if we use if we do this, we're going
to be updating our golden sword. Right? And
so I'm going to get the body of our athlete.
Yeah, I mean the the format of this a put
request, I'm going to grab it from post.
And so let's see what can we say about this
call this word? Let's call it actually.
But in insert.
Let's say that the price is actually much
more pricey. Let's say it's 35. So this should
turn into a platinum. So with this change.
So let's see we're going to the output, click
Send.
We get a tool for no content as expected,
and then the item should have been modified.
So if you go now, back to
Or get route for that item, I'm going to run
it. And then as you can see, he has changed
noticeably newsworthiness art price 75, we
get all the items, hit send, and we see that
we have the readiness sword as the last item
is great.
So finally, it is time to implement our delete
method to back to VS code.
Let's see delete.
And
yeah, the filter is going to be again, very
similar to our get item filter. So just copy
that here.
In this case, it's as simple as saying items
collection that
delete one, here's the filter.
And that will do each.
So I'll hit f5. Once again,
back to postman.
And then again, I'll copy the router and use
input open a new tab, switch from gate to
delete.
Basic route, we don't need a body because
this is a delete. And I'll hit send.
We got our tool for no content as expected.
And if you go to the get route once again
and hit send.
Now we don't have that bloodiness. You see
there's only two items. The other one has
disappeared. If you wanted to delete yet another
one, let's say the great x call to delete
40. There it sent no content back to get get
all the items and there is no great x.
So yeah, looks like it worked. And then I'll
just go back to VS code studies and close
that what I want you to realize is that we
did not have to really touch that our items
controller at all. The only thing that we
need really here, besides adding a few configuration
and
you know, registering the MongoDB client,
the only thing that we did is use create this
new identity depository that was plugged in
into the service. And that is able to by itself
do all the logic of interacting with interacting
with MongoDB, the rest of the service has
not changed at all. And that's a great the
great benefit that we get from dependency
injection and in this case, the repository
pattern.
In this episode of The dotnet five REST API
tutorial, we will talk about the synchronous
programming model in dotnet. Five, why you
should care about it, and how to implement
it in your REST API by using tasks async and
await.
Today you will learn what is a synchronous
grabbing model and how to use tasks async
and await to add the synchronous programming
to your REST API.
To understand the concept of a synchronous
programming, you can think of common scenario
which is say preparing a breakfast.
So when you prepare breakfast, you're going
to do a bunch of tasks. So for instance, you're
going to prepare your pan
you're going to heat it in order to after
that, you will go ahead and freezer max. And
that will be followed by perhaps
toasting some bread. And after that when the
bread is toasted, you may want to add some
peanut butter or use butter or jelly which
you prefer. And finally, perhaps you also
want to prepare a glass of juice. So a bunch
of tasks that in this case you have executed
sequentially.
If done in this way, it could take let's say
30 minutes to complete. But is that the way
that you will usually do this?
What about something like this is that so
you go ahead and you hit the pan. But instead
of waiting for the pan to be heated up, go
ahead and immediately start tossing the bread.
Right, you don't have to wait for the retest
to complete. And not only that, after pulling
the bread to toast, you could also start preparing
your class of use. That's totally something
that you can do at that point.
And then yes, eventually, the pound would
be heated and you can go ahead and fry your
eggs. And also while that's happening, you
can if the the bread has been toasted, you
can go ahead and put a peanut butter jelly
what you're going to put in in that bread.
So things are happening, a bunch of things
are happening kind of in parallel.
And as opposed to sequentially. With this
kind of sequence of events, you can reduce
significantly the time it takes to prepare
your breakfast, let's say all the way back
to 15 minutes. These two models is what we
call the first one is what we call the synchronous
programming model. I mean making an analogy
to our programming models that will be synchronous
and then the other world will be asynchronous.
So in a synchronous manner
model, you are not waiting for every single
task to complete before starting another one.
So you started when you can, you will go back
to the previous task when it's time to do
so. So then thinking back to our current scenario,
we do have a database, a MongoDB database.
And then we do have a repository class that's
interacting with that database. Now interacting
with the database is an expensive operation,
because you have to perform input output,
right, you have to go over the wire and talk
to that database, that database may take time
to give you back results, depending on where
it is, depending on how much load it has at
that point in time. So it may take time, so
you don't want to be waiting for that database
to finish the work to where you're going to
do is instead of doing a synchronous call
to database, you're going to do an a synchronous
call to the database.
So you start the work. And then you let it
finish work and work. While that's finishing,
you just go ahead and do something else, if
you have to do something else. And the same
way, we will have our controller talking to
the repository. But now we're going to turn
it into an async call. So the controller will
talk to the opposite, it will not wait for
it to finish doing whatever work it has to
do with the database, it will just keep going
doing anything else that you can do. And then
eventually it goes back to that task to complete
the work. And the same way, whoever calls,
our controller should also be able to call
it in an asynchronous way, so that they don't
have to wait for our controller to finish
whichever work is performing in order to continue
doing some other work. So this is what we
call basically async all the way. So all your
calls a chain a is is when doing in an asynchronous
way. And that provides a lot of performance
and efficiency to the execution of your code.
In order to to reuse the asynchronous programming
model to our REST API, we will need to introduce
a few changes to our depositories and our
controllers. Let's start by making the necessary
changes to our items depository interface.
So let's open up the depositories items capacity.
And here, there are two things that we need
to do. First one's going to be
make sure that each of these items return
dusk, as opposed to item or ienumerable or
void.
And the other one is to rename each of these
methods to have an async suffix. Because that's
a convention when you create an API or interfacing
says in this case, and you have if you have
an synchros better, you should be fixing it
with async that tells the consumer that the
method is Nic Nic method. And we will actually
start by doing that, because we're going to
take advantage of the refactoring capabilities
of VS code. So that this renamed habits across
the board as opposed to having to go to each
of the files and make the changes. So let
me show you what I mean. So I'll just right
click on Get item. And I'll do rename symbol.
And then we'll do is just type the new name
here. It is amazing. I'll hit Enter.
And as you can see, not only the name, change
it here in the interface. Also if you see
it, I just controller has been modified. And
if we see here, where we're calling the repository,
get itis async is a new name that it is using
already. Without us doing anything else he
may might have suppository is also now it
has been renamed the method to get item async.
And the same for MongoDB. depository,
get item async. So that factoring actually
goes all the way. So we're going to do the
same thing for all of the methods. And then
to make things even faster, instead of a right
click, and we're going to do is use heat f2
we use a shortcut for this. So you do f2 and
then just type pacing. And I'm going to copy
this suffix here, enter F to base a seeing
enter F to a Singh enter F to async.
So with that all of our a or four methods
have haven't changed.
Now, like I said, the only thing that we have
to do is make sure that each of these methods
return task. And this is because a that is
a way to signal that this is not going to
be a synchronous method anymore, but it's
going to be an asynchronous method. So what
you do is you do
task of item in this case. And let me import
the namespace system three tasks.
And so like I said, this, this is saying that
when you get an item from this method, you're
not going to get the item right away, it's
not a synchronous method anymore, you're going
to get a task that represents an asynchronous
operation that eventually is going to return
an item whenever a we have finished retrieving
that item from the from the from the database
in this case. So that turns the metal internet
synchromed we're gonna do the same thing for
the other methods here. So task of ienumerable
of item and then for the void cases, we just
turn into desk
And that is it for this interface, the interface
is ready to operate as an a synchronous interface.
Next, we're going to go to our list open up
this a little bit
MongoDB items have auditory.
Okay,
so let's see. Let's go one by one.
So the first one in this list is great items
async. So I'm going to turn again Boyd into
task.
And then I'm going to import a way to import
the namespace, right namespace. And
at this point, what we have to do is start
invoking the a synchronous version of the
methods that in this case, MongoDB is item
collection offers. And this is a common a
pattern, like in this case, I'm actually going
to open up the IntelliSense here, and you're
going to see that for insert one, there's
an alternative insert one async method. And
for in this case, for insert, many there's
insert many AZ met, this is going to be a
common situation for many of these libraries
that have to a reach out to some external
service. Since those operations can be expensive.
And they represent input output operations,
you want to offer the capability of executing
the operation in an asynchronous way, as opposed
to an asynchronous way.
Where you do a C synchronous operation, like
we had before just insert one, you're actually
doing a blocking call, where you're just you're
making it so that this method just stops there,
nothing else can happen until the call comes
back into the method, right, in this case
from the database. And that's exactly what
you don't want to do. So just turn turn into
using the asynchronous method. And you will
not have to wait I mean, the code will not
have to wait for that call to finish. And
and that will make your entire application
way more efficient. So that is one piece of
whatever we have to do here to make that a
synchronous call. However, we still have a
little problem here. And the fact is that
we're missing one thing, which is the async
await keywords. So by doing async, here, just
next to task and then await here, when we
made the call, we're kind of adding a little
bit of a syntactic sugar around the whole
method to tell a dotnet five, the compiler
that this is going to be an asynchronous call.
And that it please help us to not have to
write even more code to tell it that how we're
going to go to go around this asynchronous
call. So a sink and a weight, it really helps
us a lot in terms of defining that the methods
are going to turn into async. So that we don't
have to write even more code to deal with
task and how to break it. And that will be
it for grade item async. So now let's keep
going with the other methods. Or let's go
with delete imazing. So same way, we'll do
async task.
And in this case, we're going to do a here's
the line where we call database. In this case,
the lid one will do a weight is collection,
delete one async.
Yep, and that's it for delete. Next one, get
item async. In this case, we're going to do
async task of item, because we had to return
that item, but it as part of a task. And then
we're going to do return await, I just collection
find foot by filter single or default async.
Next one get is async will do async task of
ienumerable of item
and then return await.
And then here to list async.
I think this is the last one update is async.
Once again
async task.
And then we just await here,
we say we base one async.
And that's all you have to do. Like I said,
By doing this, you're making sure that every
time that you talk to the database, you're
not making a blocking call anymore, you're
actually letting a framework, I mean, giving
back resources, I mean, giving back the chance
to the framework to keep doing work while
we wait for the database operation to complete.
And like I said that, that gives a lot of
more efficiency and performance back to Europe.
Now Now we did this, as you can see, we still
have the problem with a with a meme is a possibility,
which is, this is the original repository
we're using in the first videos. So we could
choose to just delete really this repository
at this point because we're not going to be
using it anymore. But as a learning exercise,
we can actually turn this guy also into an
async a
class, I guess, even when we're not going
to be calling anything external, right, so
in this case, we're just dealing with a with
an email list of items. So there's not really
that much of a need for async stuff here,
but we need to
We need to handle the interface that were
implemented. So let me show you how we can
do this.
Let's start with a get is hazing. So same
thing we did before, this has to be async
task of ienumerable item. And then we have
the important space.
What we do here, we say return await. But
in this case, since we don't have anything
to call noising, close by to to call, but
we have to say, say, Hey, I just want to do
tasks that from result.
And we're going to pass items. What this means
is that we want to create a task that has
already completed. And we want to introduce
the value of these items collection into that
task. So it's kind of the equivalent to saying,
hey, go ahead and execute this, execute this
is this other method and wait for it to complete
and then return the results, right. But since
we don't have anything to call, you say, hey,
just return a complete task with the items
in it. And that's, that's always, so that's
how you can handle this situation where you
don't have something else to call. Let's see
what we can do about get item async. So we'll
do
a scene async, task vitam.
And in this case, we're going to use capture
in the case of a dynamic thing we're going
to capture ID equals items where we capture
the item that was found, we do something similar,
as before, await does that from result.
Item.
Yep, same thing, we return result, complete
task with the item that we that we found.
For create item async. Again, we're going
to do async task.
And in this case, we don't have really anything
to return. So the only thing that we have
to return here is some some sort of a task,
right? So we're going to say is a weight task
that in this case, we can do a completed task.
So this means just create some task that has
already completed and return it without returning
anything inside it, because there's nothing
to return. Now let's move to update a item
async. So async task.
And then once again, copy this await task,
that completed task. Finally, we'll do the
Delete. So async task
and await task that completed task. Yep. So
it's as simple as that. Now, just to let you
know,
it is not necessarily it is not necessary
to use async and await in every single case,
you could go around and avoid a avoid this
combination. In some cases, however, I would
consider that to be a bit of an advanced concept
that I will not like to dive into that right
now just because it has some pitfalls that
you have to be aware of. And it is not trivial
to know them beforehand. So for now, I would
recommend you to stick to async await anytime
you have to run an asynchronous INVOKANA synchronous
operation and define your own method as an
asynchronous operation. And now let's go to
our itis controller and do the final set of
modifications that we need to introduce here.
So let's start with a get items. Right so
same thing.
Let's turn this guy I mean this is a sink
all the way right so we have to turn everything
async now async task of ienumerable identity
all these forget items. So again, importantly
space.
Let's not forget that this method now should
be suffixed with async because it is an asynchronous
method. Now here what we have to do is again
do and await
and await for the get a get is async call.
But it's it's a bit more problematic here
because
the weight is separated from the from the
actual method, and we're trying to chain a
select right away, that's that's not going
to work, we have to wrap this into into these
parentheses to tell it that first go ahead
and do this. And when that's completed, then
go ahead and do the Select right so that is
just to comply with the with the syntax that
the compiler is expecting from us. I'm actually
going to put this in this in a second line
to look at it better. And just before we go
ahead to get is async await for it and when
that's done, we select the items that we got.
We turn them sto and then we just return them
back to the caller.
When we learn to get item, we're going to
do now
a sync task of actually sold it to and
it should be get item async.
And here when we call get item async we used
to await
That will do it.
When we don't do the next one post, we will
do
async task.
grade item pacing.
And then here is where we create the items.
So we will do a weight, create animation.
And then remember that now the method is actually
named the get item async here, so we have
to do the proper rename.
Next one update item.
So let's say async task.
Action result update item, a sink.
And let's see, here's what we call it. So
we will say await get item async. And over
here, we also have to await for the call to
update item async. And finally, let's go to
our delete item method. It's going to be again
async. task, action result list item async.
And then await
and then over here,
wait suppository, delete item async. So now
our controller is all async and is calling
methods that are all async. And the depositor
is also calling methods are always in. So
we're doing async all the way basically. So
let's see how this goes. So I'm just going
to do f5 now.
And I'm going to open postman.
Let's see, let's start trying out the API's.
First one here, the first one that we had
is a the items. So let's try to get the full
list of items. So I'll hit send.
And as you see, we do have the antidote from
the previous video still hanging around, that's
working just fine. Now let's try to create
a brand new item, right, so how would we call
it let's say this is going to be
high potion. So a potion that provides increasing
strength to the player. And so the price is
going to be, let's say 30.
And I'm going to hit send. Let's see if that
works.
So we do have an issue here, we're getting
a 500 internal server error, and no route
matches the supplied values. So this here
is actually unexpected situation. This is
because of a breaking change in ASP. NET Core
three. And let me let me show you why this
happens. Let me go back to items controller,
I'll use a stop this, close that. And if you
remember, what we just did a in grid item
async method is that we updated or created
an action call here, to use a name of get
items get async as opposed to get item because
we just rename it that method over here, get
item async. It was get it before. And now
the breaking change that interested in ASP.
NET Core three zero is that at runtime, the
framework is going to actually remove the
async suffix from from the mid range at runtime,
this actually looks like just get it as opposed
to get Iam async.
Given that when we try to do the greatest
add action call here, it is not able to find
the route that represented by that action.
And so that breaks things. So there's a couple
of ways to fix this. And what I'm going to
do is to actually tell a dotnet that I don't
want that behavior, I just want to keep using
the async suffix. So to do that, what we can
do is just go to startup
startup, what you want to do is find your
call to our controllers. And there, you just
have to specify a one option, which is options.
Let's see options, open curly braces, and
then you want to do options that suppress
a theme suffix in actual names
equals false with that, that that will not
remove the async suffix anymore from any method
at runtime. So let's see how that goes.
like five,
back to postman.
And now the one thing that you want to keep
in mind is that the creation actually succeeded.
It just happens to be that we were not able
to be a we were not able to create to invoke
the created our action a call, right. So just
to confirm that if you go back to get a return
to do a get here, you will see that we do
have the high potion created. So it is there.
But we will not we were not able to complete
the creation. I mean, we were able to call
the Create action successfully.
So let's actually create something else here
to not confuse these with a high portion.
So let's call this one mega potion, or mega
potion is going to be more expensive. Like
let's say 45
So now I'm going to do sent.
And this time, they actually it was actually
created successfully.
No issues there.
Now let's use the A this item to actually
try the get route. So just to get a for that
item, let's see if that works.
That works just fine. And now let's try our
put our put route for that item. As so let's
see, we're going to use the same name, perhaps
make a potion. But let's put another price.
Let's see what price we have. Here we have
45, let's say it's even more expensive 50
for the mega potion.
So I'll hit send.
And that should have updated the mega potion.
So let's go back to the gate, make sure that
the price changes. So hit send again. And
as you can see, price is now 50.
And
let's see, let's actually not delete that
makeup in we're going to try to delete route.
But let's delete something else. Let's say
we want to delete this high portion. Actually,
he's kind of our favorite experiment. So I'll
copy that ID. So I'll try to delete that.
Anil he'd sent two or four new content back
to the target route. Let's see what we get.
And as you can see, Hypatia is gone. So we
only have the antidote and the mega portion.
You want to configure that things are actually
getting read into the database. It's as easy
as going back to VS code, and close. And I'll
open up again, our MongoDB extension here,
catalog items. And we do have let me refresh
this. We do have two documents, one for the
antidote.
And whilst they make a push, and yeah, now
you have fully a synchronous
REST API, which is going to give you great
performance and great efficiency. And from
here on.
In this episode of The dotnet five REST API
tutorial, we will talk about secret management
and health checks. We will see how to securely
store secrets during development that your
REST API can use easily as with any other
piece of configuration. We will also learn
about health checks and how they are a great
way to report the health of our API.
Today, you will learn how to store and use
secrets via the dotnet secrets manager and
how to use health checks to report the health
of the race API and its dependencies.
So let's talk about secret management. As
you know, at this point, we do have a REST
API that is able to talk to a database or
MongoDB database.
And in order to be able to talk to it, we
have defined a configuration service where
we have specified details like host and port.
So to be able to connect to that MongoDB database.
The configuration source that we've been using
so far is our app settings, that JSON file
right
there, we have host localhost and Port 27,
zero 17.
But now we are going to enable authentication
to the MongoDB database. So you're going to
need a username and a password in order to
be able to connect to it. We have to tell
our REST API how to how to use this information.
So for the user, we're going to add our user
another user is setting in top settings JSON
for are going to call it just MongoDB admin
for the username. And then we also have to
specify a password. So should we just specify
the password directly in the app settings
JSON file? Well, the answer is no. You don't
want to add any sort of secrets into app settings
JSON or into any of the files that you have
that are part of your service. Right. So that's
a basic, good practice in terms of security,
never introduce secrets in there.
If we cannot do this, then how are we going
to pass that information into the service.
So it tends to be that
app service JSON is just one of the possible
set of configuration services that can feed
into your REST API. There are other options
like you could use a command line arguments,
you could use environment variables, or you
could even use a bunch of other cloud searches,
searches coming from the cloud that can provide
configuration information into your REST API.
In our case, we're going to use one that's
called the secret manager. This is just one
more configuration source that's built in
into dotnet. And that is already pre configured
for you, for any new brand new web API are
in that secret barrier. We can securely store
our password, let's say pass in this case.
And without having to put that password within
our REST API. So it's not going to be in any
of the files that compose our REST API. It
will be in some placing our machine securely
stored, but yet, they are REST API is not
going to have any trouble reading that. That
password because just as as anything else,
it is coming just as a new piece of information.
majorly from our configuration service. And
the rest the REST API can easy to consume.
We are now going to enable authenticated access
to our Mongo database. There are a couple
of ways to do this. But to keep things simple
and safe, this is just a development database
for learning purposes, we will delete the
volume where Mongo container currently storing
all the data. This allows us to start a new
container with a brand new Docker volume with
authentication will be enabled.
So the first thing that you may want to do
is verify if you're running the container
already or not. So we're going to do is open
a new terminal.
And I'm just going to do docker ps, that will
tell you if you have the container running
already. And you are indeed, in this case,
I am. So what if the first thing that I have
to do is to stop this container. So I'm going
to do Docker stop Mongo
that stops the container. And now what I want
to know is, which is the volumes that I have
available here. So Docker volume, LS, that
will give us the one volume that we care about
right now MongoDB data. And now what I'm going
to do is just delete it. So Docker volume,
RM MongoDB data.
So now the volume is gone, we are free to
restart the container with a brand new volume.
So what I'm going to do now is just a grab
the initial set of a, the initial command
to run the container, just as we did before.
And then as you can see, the same volume is
here, there's going to be a new one, since
we deleted it already. And what I'd like to
do is just add a couple of environment variables
that represent the username and password that
are going to be used at a within the database.
So if I just do dash E, and this is the file,
the name of the variable, in this case is
going to be Mongo in it.
dB.
Root username.
And here we specify the name for our user,
you could use any name here, I'm going to,
I'm going to use Mongo admin.
So that goes for username, and now the password
for the password, you have to use Mongo ini
dB,
root, password,
equals, and then you got to pick a password.
So I'll pick something here, not super strong,
but still
something like these.
And finally, the name of the of the Docker
image that we want to use in this case is
Mongo. So with this, it's a hit Enter. And
now we do have docker ps, we do have a database
that has authentication enabled with a user
of Mongo admin and a password of pass bout,
we're one.
So at this point, our database requests authentication,
but our service does not know about it yet.
So what happens if we try to query date at
this point, what I'm going to do is just hit
f5, the service.
Okay, and then go into postman. And I'll just
try to query for a few items and see what
happens. So these are items query it sent.
And yes, command find failed command phi requires
authentication, right? So just good. authentication
is working. It's just that our service does
not know the correct credentials to talk to
the database. So how can we make a how can
we make this service a aware of the user and
password needs to use. So let's go back to
VS code. Let's stop and close this. And what
I'm going to do is, first I'm going to declare
a a configuration setting for the user. So
I'm opening up series Jason. And in this section
where we have MongoDB settings, I'm just going
to add a one more section here.
For for user, let's call it user.
And we know that the user we specify for the
database is Mongo.
Now, we also need a password. And of course,
I could specify a password right here. But
that it's not a good idea. You should never
specify a secret or confidential information
in your app settings JSON file, that's a security
kind of a security hole. So you should not
do that. Instead, we're going to take advantage
of the dotnet secret manager to store the
password security as still we should be able
to pull that secret into the service into
the REST API without any trouble. So to do
that, again, I'm going to open a terminal.
And here's what I'm going to do. First, let's
initialize the secret memory for our project.
And that we can do via dotnet user secrets
a bit
And if you take a quick peek into catalog
CEUs blog, you're going to see that there's
a new entity there. User secrets ID. So this
represents a identifier of this secret configuration
for this project.
From here on, we can start actually adding
secrets to the for this project, and do a
secret what you can do is.net user secrets
set. And here you have specify the name of
the secret. Now for the name where we want
to do is follow the convention of the settings,
the settings property that we have defined
already, and yours a add to it in the in,
in the in the format accepted by the net.
So in the in our case, that means is specifying
MongoDB settings, and then we do colon, and
then we specified the actual a property that
will represent the password, this case is
going to be use password.
And after that, we specified the actual value,
in this case for the password, and we know
that the password is pass bound word one,
or one.
Okay. So just like I did here, what I'm saying
is, is that the, the, the name of the secret
is going to start with MongoDB settings, which
matches a MongoDB series right here. And password
is one of the properties that is going to
follow the other properties that we already
have in the MongoDB settings class, and the
actual values passed
out word one, hit Enter. And the secret has
been add. What we need now is a way to read
both username, the user and the password into
a our service. To do that, we're going to
go into our settings, settings class MongoDB
settings.
Absolutely, let's close this.
Let's add a couple of new properties here.
So let's add
string, user.
And string
password. So these are the two properties
that will be populated at runtime by dotnet.
into into our app.
Now,
the other one that we want to define is a
modified connection string because now it
is not going to be enough to provide us whole
support. We have specify user and password.
And the way that you do that for a MongoDB
connection string is by saying
user colon
password. And then we'll say at host column
port. So that's the same text that MongoDB
is expecting from us. So just by doing that,
let's try equating again and see what happens.
So I'll do a five.
And I'll go to postman now. So let's see if
we can query for information sent.
And yes, we don't get anything because remember,
these are brand new database because we modified
the volume, but we are getting a 200. Okay,
oh, things seem to be a running just fine.
And just to be completely sure, what we're
going to do is do a post. And we'll switch
into the post tab here and see if we can actually
recreate this mega portion with price 45.
And not just that, let me actually put a breakpoint
over here. And to see how these values look
at runtime. And Cynthia Singleton, I'll have
to stop and restart our, our service. So let's
hit f5 again.
So the first time that the connection is needed,
we should hit this breakpoint. So go to postman.
And I'll do send here.
And I suspected we have a breakpoint here.
So as you can see, the user has been read
from our app settings JSON file, and the password
has been read from the secrets manager. So
password is not at all reading, updating JSON
is just coming from secrets manager. And
really that that that magic that takes that
does running here is being driven by program
CS when we do create default builder, that
piece takes care of injecting the secrets
barrier as one more configuration serves to
our service. So you don't have to do anything
special for that to happen. So if this happened,
and we just let it keep going.
Go back to postman. And in fact, yeah, the
mega portion has been created. If we create
it for them. We'll see that it is right there.
So moving on to the next topic. Let's now
start talking about health checks and how
to enable them. So But first, let's learn
about health checks.
So as we know, we do have a REST API at this
point that is talking to a MongoDB database.
However, it is not uncommon to face issues
as time goes by, right? So a REST API could
go down for a variety of reasons. Or it could
be a good intention, right? We may be redeploying
these REST API to our, to our server to our
cloud service or to our server wherever it
is going. So even if temporarily, that REST
API could go down.
And there will also be issues on the other
side with talking to our database, right?
So for any reason, that database, we may lose
connection to the database, either temporarily
or for a long time.
Or something could be going on, and we're
really talking to that database, right? So
communication issues could happen. So with
this, we may start getting equations like,
is our REST API alive? So is it alive? Ganga,
we actually talk to this REST API. Right.
So you may start wondering this, or you may
start wondering, Well, can we reach a database?
So is it there? Is that connection in a good
state?
So but really, what you're asking here is
the broader question, is it healthy? So is
our race API healthy? Is it ready to receive
quiz? Is it ready to do the job the right
way?
And to answer that question, the right way
to do it is to enable what we call health
check endpoint. So so you don't have to guess.
So we will have, you will have a natural endpoint
that you can call is part of our universal
API. And you can call to it and it should
be able to tell you if the service is healthy
or not. Right. And, of course, there will
be a person or people interested in that information.
So us as, as a developer, as an engineer,
that increases service may want to query for
that help endpoint as either services healthy.
But really the most important case, the most
useful and original a scenario is when you
have an orchestrator system, that will be
in charge of knowing when your service is
ready to receive requests. So we will talk
more about this in a few episodes in the future.
But
having a health check endpoint is a key piece
of any REST API that you have think about
right away.
Now that we learned about health checks, let's
see how we can enable them for our REST API.
So the first thing that we have to do is to
add the services for health checks and that
we can do within startups. Yes. Before that,
let's stop debugging and close terminal and
open up startup CS. And I'm going to head
into the Configure services method.
In this method, we're going to go all the
way down.
And we're going to add just one line here.
Services dot add health checks
in now, so that's the services and now we
need to add the middleware for it. And that
we have to do inside the US endpoints method
inside Configure. So here, we're going to
say, endpoints that map health checks. And
then here, you get to pick the route that
you want to use for your health endpoint.
So in my case, I'm going to go for health.
But feel free to choose something else, like
you could do something like hc, or you could
do health See, it's really up to you, what
do you want to use, I'll go for those held.
And now I'm going to do a five. And let's
try it out. So that should give us a very
basic health check endpoint for service. So
back to postman. And the way that you query
for this health check is really very similar
to what we do for the iTunes route. So we
just have to open up in a new tab in postman
for the get burb. And I'll go for my localhost
colon 5001. And then you just add the URL
to route our case is held. I'll hit send.
And here's you get a result, he says healthy.
So with that, you have a way to almost like
being your service to see if it's in a healthy
state. So this means that yet the services
is up and running, and everything should be
fine.
However, this is actually not super useful,
because even if the service is up and running,
it means nothing if the database is down,
right, if the service is down, or if we cannot
reach it.
Our service is not really that much healthy.
So how can we tell if we have any dependent
service like a database in a not in a healthy
state? And how what how can we take advantage
of health checks for this? So let me show
you what we can do.
Going back here, stop that close these are
going to do is add a nougat package.
That's called ASP. NET Core healthchecks MongoDB.
That will allow us to add health check is
specifically designed to verify if MongoDB
is running properly. So I'm just going to
open a new terminal here. And I'm going to
say dotnet, add package, ASP. NET Core health
checks MongoDB.
So this is an an open source project, it's
not part of ASP. NET Core or dotnet. Five,
but it is a very handy project. And with these
with this package, the let me show you what
we can do.
Close the terminal again. And then.
So here, what we want to do is add some options
to this call to add a health checks. But before
we can do that, we need to pull out our MongoDB
settings in such a way that we can reduce
them later on. So to do that, I'm just going
to grab this, this line here,
outside and into, let's say here,
and we will call these MongoDB settings.
So now those MongoDB settings can be used
over here for our MongoDB client Singleton.
But also for our purpose right now, after
saying a uthealth checks, we're going to say
that at MongoDB. And here we will use MongoDB
settings,
that connection string
to specify the connection string that needs
to be used to connect to the MongoDB database,
right or health check is going to be based
on can we reach this database or not. We will
also add a couple of things here, like a name
used to define this specific health check.
And we will just say MongoDB. And one more
thing is a timeout.
This is because we don't want this healthcheck
to take a long while to tell us if the database
is is just down. Right. So in this case, we'll
say timespan from seconds, let's give it three
seconds. If after three seconds, we cannot
connect to the database. But we'll consider
that this has failed write the check has failed.
So now that we did that, let's try it out.
So I'll do f5.
And let me actually remove this breakpoint.
And back into postman. So here, yeah, I'm
going to say hello again sent. And it is healthy.
And I suspected because our database is up
and running. But if I go back into VS code
into our terminal, and I use a stop our
MongoDB container. So let's see Docker stop
Mongo that will is Docker container, which
is equivalent to just stopping completely
our database, right and the entire database
services going down. So let's see what happens
as I go back to postman. And I tried to check
her health
will take like two seconds. And then yes,
right here. So now health check is reporting
as unhealthy. Which is great, because now
anytime a database is down, we can easily
tell that that as part of the health check
that we're using right here.
Now there's one more thing that we can use
to improve the scenario. And is the fact that
we may want to have more than one endpoint
to verify not just the fact that the services
is up or not, but also if it is ready to receive
requests or not. And the typical pattern here
is specify both a ready endpoint and a live
endpoint. So our ready endpoint is going to
tell us if we are ready to well, if a service
is ready to receive every incoming request,
right, which in our case really means so is
the database up and running Ready to go? Can
we use it? While the live endpoint is just
going to tell us if our service a justice
service is up or not? Is it alive or not.
So to do this is these two endpoints, let's
actually go back to VS code. I'll stop this
again.
And back to startup.
First thing that we have to do is going back
to our health check configuration, we have
to assign an attack to our health check to
let me show you what I mean. So actually put
these things down a bit so that we can do
the easier. So I'm going to open up a
One more line here. And I'll say tax.
So I'll create a little array here.
And here, I'll say ready. So here I am attaching
a tag that I'm calling ready. That will help
me a group, every single health check for
which I want to apply are ready endpoint.
So the endpoint that specifies if I'm ready
to start receiving requests,
how do we use this. So now let's go back to
our map health check section.
And I'll add a line here.
So now we know we need to specify in our two
endpoints, one for ready and one for life.
So let's go for the raven first. So instead
of just having held here, I'm going to say
okay, slash ready, it's going to be our ready,
ready endpoint. And now has specify health
check.
Health Check options, see for museum a space
right there.
Okay, open up this. So at this point, we have
to specify what we call the predicate for
the predicate is the way that you can filter
out which health checks you want to include
in these in this endpoint. So remember that
right now, we only have one really, our that
one has been tagged with ready. That's one
form of MongoDB. So in the case of the radium
point, we want to include that MongoDB endpoint.
So to do that, what you do is is this, you
say check.
And then we'll say check tags contains.
And then the tag name ready
that you have already endpoint that will,
will will only include those a health checks
that have been tagged with ready.
And then we have to define another endpoint.
So I'm going to actually copy, copy these,
these one is going to be just live.
Really, for the live case, we don't have to
do much, we actually don't want to, we don't
want to include any health check, we just
want to say a kind of the response over pink
rice. In this case, we're saying just false.
By doing that, we are excluding every single
health check, including the Bongo DB one,
and so that it would just come back to us
as long as as long as the REST API is alive
as the service is alive. So that's the way
that you can do the life. So ready, we'll
make sure that the database is ready to serve
requests, life is just going to make sure
that our site, our service is up and running.
So with this, let's run again. So I'll do
f5.
And I'm back into postman. And this time,
so let's, let's see. So I'll query for, let's
see, health, life.
see what we get.
So he says healthy, is expected because the
service is up and running.
Now I'll try ready.
see what we get.
So after about three seconds, we do get unhealthy.
And this is because our database Docker container
is still still down, right? as we did before.
If I go back here,
and I go back to my terminal, let's say this
one, and actually restarted the Docker container.
For Docker, Ron, Yep, sure, do it. That starts
a container again, go back to postman. And
he'll sent and I get held up because the database
server and the database are they're up and
running.
And usually that's good enough. So that's
what you want to do to enable your your health
checks. But if you happen to want a little
bit of more information about
the health check that you have configured,
you can actually customize the message that
you're getting here. This gives us the basic
thing healthy, but you can get more if you
want to answer Let me show you how to do that.
So back in VS code, open close,
we're going to look for our map health checks
function. The red one in particular is interesting.
And what we can do is take advantage of what's
called the response writer.
This is post writer you can use to specify
how to render the message that you're getting
as you're collecting the results of the health
checks. So I'm going to say
async context.
Sorry for that
context report.
Let's do this and then open curly braces,
and then here I'm going to collect the result
of the of the checkout.
So for that, I'm going to say sold equals,
I'm going to use the JSON serializer.
The one that comes with dotnet,
I'm going to serialize.
Now we're going to create an anonymous type
here. So I'll just say new. And then we have
to give it a shape. So this is the shape of
what we're going to return back into postman,
to the collar. So the first thing that I want
to show is a status started, we can get from
report
dot status, just to string.
And then we want to get the array of checks,
which should include our MongoDB check. So
in this case, I'm going to say report entries,
select.
And I'll say, so I project each entry into
a new anonymous type.
And in this type, I want to show first the
name,
which is going to come out of entry that key,
then I'll get the status of this very specific
check,
which is going to come from entry value status
to string.
And then there could be an exception coming
from the database. So let's actually capture
that too.
Oops, sorry.
exception, is going to be empty that value
that exception, but we may or may not have
an exception, depending on the status of this
check. So we're going to say is that if the
exception is not No, we will get an entry
value, exception message. But if we don't
have any exception, if it is no, we will just
say not.
Finally, one last detail could be interesting
is the duration that will tell us how long
it took to do this health check.
And three value, duration to string.
game, so to taste.
And now one more thing that we can do here
is to format that output. So I'm going to
say, context, that response that content type
equals
media type names.
And using something
that application that Jason,
that will let us render as a nice JSON string,
back in postman. And finally, I'll actually
write this information out. So await context
response. Right?
Right async
result
using one new spacer.
And that should do it. So now we have customized
how that message should be rendered. So I'm
going to do a five once again.
And back into postman. So let's see what happens
when I tried my radio endpoint now, sort of
hit send.
And now as you can see, the result is a bit
nicer. So we do have a status of Lt. And then
we can see the array of objects. In this case,
we have MongoDB, with a healthy state nociception
and a duration in there. And if we wanted
to get the sample with an actual exception
to this, you can just stop your local Docker
container again.
stalker stop Mongo
container stopped. I'll try again back in
postman sent.
And after three seconds, we should get Yeah.
So now, as you can see, here, the entire health
check is unhealthy. The specifically MongoDB
is unhealthy. And yeah, the operation has
been canceled. So that's what we're getting
from, from dry dock to MongoDB.
Now one last thing that I wanted to show you
is that there's actually a bunch of health
checks already available for you. And so just
like we did a MongoDB one, let me stop and
close this. If you remember, we did
this here, we did the MongoDB. One, just like
this, there's a bunch of other ones already
available for you to try out, depending on
the service that you're using. Let me point
you to this page here, which is a page for
the open source project that I mentioned that
has these health checks. So over here in this
GitHub project, you're going to see that so
this will tell you everything about how to
use these health checks. But I wanted to show
you that there's already health checks built
in for a bunch of providers, right, so SQL
Server, MySQL, a bunch of things Cosmos TV,
send sendgrid, a few Azure services, Amazon
services, Google stuff, here's the one that
we use MongoDB. And
so yeah, so there's
A bunch of providers already available. And
there's even an here's a nougat package that
you can use. And there's even support for
let me show you the support for for a UI.
I don't usually use this one. But if you wanted
to show a very nice UI with all your health
checks, with a breakdown for for each of the
checks, you can actually enable these, these
health check UI. Sorry. And yeah, and that
will just stand up another endpoint in your
in your service that you can go to, and get
all these nice UI rendered. So that's something
that you may want to try it out. I usually
find there's some old ways that I quantify
the help of my services, as we're going to
see as we move forward with these videos.
But this is another option that you can try.
In this episode of The dotnet five REST API
tutorial, we will start our path towards getting
our API deployed to our production environment.
We will learn about the relational challenges
involved in getting the API beats deployed
outside of our developer box, how Docker can
help us address these challenges, and how
to turn our existing API into a Docker container.
Today, you will learn the challenges of deployment,
how Docker works, and why you should use it,
how to turn the REST API into a Docker image,
and how to run your REST API as a Docker container.
So the way that things are at this point,
you know that we do have a REST API up and
running in our local box. And there's also
a MongoDB database running next to it as a
Docker container.
But now we need to figure out how we're going
to share this REST API with the world, right,
either how to share the REST API with people
inside of our local intranet, or how to share
the REST API with the world perhaps in the
public Internet. And that place where we're
going to share things is what we're going
to call the production environment. The production
environment could be anything from some server
running in your in your building, or your
house. Or it could also be some server running
software in the internet, right. But for all
cases, this is the production environment,
this is a place where people will be able
to access the a REST API without having to
get access to your local box, your developer
box. And one of the first things to think
about when we want to pick this, this server
for production is the operating system. So
we will need to figure out when to find
the right server with the correct version
of the operating system that our REST API
is able to support. So in the case of for
REST API is not really that much of a big
deal, because that five is cross platform.
So what we have built so far is to be able
to run in really in a bunch of operating systems.
But still, we need to sell install operating
systems. So if we say that we're going to
be running this on on Linux, then we would
need to go ahead and make sure that we have
Linux available the correct distribution and
version of Linux available in that production
environment.
Then, we also know that we do need the dotnet
five runtime to be able to run a REST API,
the REST API is built on dotnet five, therefore,
we do need the dotnet, five run time, and
all the corresponding files of it, they need
to be placed in the right place in that production
box. On top of that, our app may have a bunch
of dependencies, like the MongoDB driver that
we've been using to talk to one MongoDB. So
like that, it may have a bunch of dependencies
that they also need to be placed into the
production box. So that finally,
our REST API can be placed alongside all of
these other components, and it can run happily.
So it is at that point that we can, we can
continue that we have all the files and sorry
for the REST API to be running in production.
But then also, we have to consider that we
also have database requirements, right. So
we have a database that we need to play somewhere
in this production environment. And it will
have its own requirements in terms of operating
system, and dependencies that MongoDB may
have the MongoDB and Gene, all these things
that we need to run the database in production.
So that by itself presents another set of
requirements. So as we think about all of
these, these things that we need to that we
need to happen to get our production up and
running. So we need to think about a few challenges
right. So the first thing is going to be preparing
a box. So what you really want is to make
sure that whatever box we use for production
has everything that we that we have had so
far in our developer box, right. And then
but you also have to think about so are we
going to pick a physical machine Are we going
to pick a virtual machine or virtual machine
is really just average the latest version
of operating system running on top of some
other physical machine. So any regardless
if office
same physical machine virtual machine, we
need to figure out well, where are we going
to get this machine from? Where are we going
to host it? Who is going to be taking care
of this machine? A bunch of questions just
regarding this this machine. But also way
to figure out okay, so is it going to be Linux?
Or windows? Who's going to put the right version
of the always in there? Who's going to make
sure that he has the right set of patches?
And who's going to maintain these? Really,
somebody has to take care of these things?
But also, how are we going to take the files
to the production machine, right? So we have
all these files in their box? And somehow
they need to land in production? How are we
going to do this? If we're going to be using
perhaps some FTP protocol, to be able to talk
to an insanely fast to production machine?
Are we going to put the files in some USB
or pendrive? And then just copy them using
it into the production machine? Are we going
to send the files to some person from operations,
B, perhaps some email and then the person
will place the files in there? How do you
make this happen? The first thing to get there?
So one way or another?
What happens? I mean, in this case, we're
thinking of placing, let's say that the database
server just next to the REST API, if we're
going to do that, how are we going to make
sure that all the dependencies of the database
and the dependencies of the REST API
have the right versions, even when we only
were placing everything in the same machine?
Right. So there could be version mismatch
between the things that are needed in the
MongoDB database? And the detail needed in
the REST API? Right, starting from the previous
system? How do we make sure that all the dependencies
are the right version for both of them? And
if they're, if they cannot be, we have to
figure out okay, so perhaps we need to split
his REST API into one machine and the database
server into another machine, which could not
be that uncommon. But we have to think about
all these things. Also, what if we eventually
decide to move to a new version of dotnet?
Right, so let's say that net six is out. We
have to we want to move to the next six. What
does that mean? Do we have to bring in a brand
new set of servers, physical rooftile, that
are already enabled for dotnet? Six? Do we
want to just update the version of dotnet
in this existing server, and then somehow
make sure that the app does not break by making
that change? How are we going to make that
happen?
Also, how do we start recipient the machine
because it is not just about copying the files
in there, right? So somehow, we need to start
the dotnet app into the server, somebody has
to do it right. So we have to bring in some
sort of automation, sort of a scripting, something
needs to happen in that machine, to be able
to start with API and not just started but
started fast. And we want to make sure that
as soon as we put the beats in there, the
application starts quickly so that it can
start serving our users.
And finally, what if one instance of the app
is not enough? So what if we start having
so many users and us having one web server
for a REST API is not enough? And now we need
to bring in yet another? Let's say VM virtual
machine for a recipe and then another one,
and then another one? So who's going to take
care of provisioning all these VMs? For us?
What about the database? What if we alternate
multiple copies of the database server to
be able to handle the load? So how is all
this going to happen? So do we need to think
about all these challenges? Do we need to
deal with all of this? Or is there a better
way? So luckily, here's where Docker can help
us.
So now, let's go back to our local box. So
yeah, so we have our local box has REST API
and the and the database currently, and we
need to get to production. But now, instead
of starting to worry about how to copy all
the things into production, or how to make
sure that production has the right things
already in place,
we can start using this thing called a Docker
file. So a local file is kind of a template
of
all the things that are needed by your a,
in this case, a REST API to get it deployed
into production. So in the Docker file, you
will declare things like the operating system
that we're going to need. So you're going
to say, I run in this specific version on
this specific distribution of Linux, let's
say, What is his version of Windows. So he
is already declared in that file. And so you're
saying as long as that version is available
in the production machine, I am, I am going
to run just fine. And not only that, you can
say, Well, I actually need the version five
zero of the dotnet, or ASP. NET Core runtime
available in there. And
by doing this, as long as I have all the dependencies
of the dotnet core runtime, I am able to run
my my REST API, right, so you can declare
the runtime that you're going to be running
on.
You can also declare or you can prepare all
the dependencies that are needed for your
app.
Right, let the ongole be driver and any other
DLL or any other dependencies that need to
be present in there, you can specify how to
place the files that you want to put in that
in that production environment, you can say
how we're exactly what to put them. And you
can also tell it exactly how to get started
or how to start that REST API. So that scraping
that is needed to say how to start it, it
can also be said in this Docker file. So just
by using the Docker file, you get, you get,
you're already handling a lot of the challenges
that we were talking before, because this
Docker file is clearly declaring exactly how
the how the environment needs to be built
for the REST API to run properly. And so but
then, it is not not enough to use have this
Docker file. So now that you have Docker file,
what you're going to do is use this thing
called the Docker engine to actually prepare
what we call a Docker image. So what happens
here is that the Docker engine, which is just
a process running in your in your box, the
Docker engine is going to take that Docker
file, and it's going to tag it and and build
what we call a Docker image.
Tagging is is really just kind of a synonym
for creating a version for your image. So
you're going to set a version on that image,
and then you're going to build it. So building
a Docker image means reading that Docker file
line by line,
or executing all those instructions to prepare
the environment where a REST API is going
to run. And that goes all the way back to
ensuring that all the exact dependencies are
in place, put the files in the right location
and starting the app. Right. So all of that
is encapsulated in that Docker image. But
then, once you have the Docker image, it is
not enough to just have it running in your
machine, right? what you really want is to
make it available in production. So how do
you take it from your box into production.
So enter the Container Registry, the Container
Registry is a place that could be anywhere
going from some server in your again, in your
internet, to somewhere in the cloud, it is
the place where you can place your Docker
image, you can push your Docker image
so that it eventually becomes available for
a your production environment. So this Container
Registry, I mean, you don't necessarily have
to be the one that pushes the Docker images
in there. There may be some some other images
already available in the registry. So for
instance, in the case of MongoDB, there, we've
been using
an instance, the Docker image of MongoDB.
Since a few episodes back, we did not actually
create that image Damon was already there.
And that image is actually available in a
specific Container Registry called Docker
Hub. So Docker Hub is a public registry, where
many vendors place their Docker images for
public consumption. But just like there's
a Docker Hub, there's also other container,
private cul de registries like a Azure Container
Registry, or Google a registry. Amazon ECR,
I think is the name. There's also these days,
GitHub have a registry. So there's a bunch
of versions of these available. But all of
them are able to operate with your Docker
images in the really the same way. So what
you have Porsche Docker image into the Container
Registry, then you're able to have your production
box in the physical box, virtual machine,
whatever it is, it is able to pull your Docker
image into it. And by pulling it and executing
that image, it turns into what we call a Docker
container. So the Docker container becomes
kind of living version, our executable or
running version of your Docker image, but
a Docker container. So
the Docker container just has it
has all the files and all the dependencies
that have been declared in the Docker file,
and executes the REST API the way that you
have declared it in the Docker file, and just
like what well, just like how we stand up
Docker container for the REST API, we can
stand out the Docker container for our MongoDB
Docker image. And then, of course, these containers
can talk to each other on all of these magic,
I mean, it only works just because you also
have the Docker engine of the same Docker
engine that you have in your box, you will
have it available in a production environment.
So
here, as long as you have the Docker engine
available in whichever machine, you want to
go ahead and run your Docker image, then your
Docker image is guaranteed to be able to run
as a Docker container in that environment
don't need that you need is a Docker engine.
And that brings a lot of benefits along the
way. The other thing is that you not only
just can just run one instance of your Docker
container, you can actually run multiple instances
of your local container. So as you need to
scale up more and more, perhaps because you
have too many users, then you can use to start
spinning up more and more copies of that Docker
image into Docker containers in production,
without having to incur into a lot of hassles
to be able to provision more and more environments.
So, lots of benefits about
Docker really here, started with efficient
use a resource usage. So as opposed to the
case of having to stand up new virtual machines
or new physical servers, you don't have to
really enter into a lot of new resources.
spinning up a new Docker image does not take
a lot of RAM does not take a lot of this space,
because there's a lot of caching happening
in there by by this thing called layers in
in Docker. So a lot of caching, memory is
going to is going to only going to increase
in terms of what, what exactly is needed by
for your,
for your, for your image for your service,
free REST API. And so you can really fit much
more instances of your REST API, in this case,
also have your database, many more instances
in the same production box.
As you could before, just feed one instance
of your REST API, or your or your MongoDB
container,
or a MongoDB database, in the same production
box, right, you can fit much more.
By using containers, there's also faster start,
because
because Docker, the Docker engine is able
to cache all these, these layers are only
the very first time that it needs to pull
down the Docker image, it will do that with
all the layers apart from their own, it will
be able to just pull only the layers that
have changed. And so that allows it to really
start very fast. So you don't have to also
you don't have to boot up an entire operating
system, just to put a your your app, right.
So the operating system is already in place,
you just need to start your app. And Docker
is able to do that very, very fast.
There's also isolation if each of these containers
is running in a in a completely isolated way.
So it doesn't matter what's going on in the
actual production host machine, or what's
happening in any other containers running
in the box. Each of the containers are running
in isolation. And so from their point of view,
they are the only thing happening at that
point in time in that environment. So that
that gives you a lot of benefits from that
side.
And then also you can you can think of these
containers have been able to run anywhere.
And because like I said, as long as there's
a Docker engine running in your production
machine, you're guaranteed to be able to run
your Docker container in there. So lots of
portability. And finally, scalability, like
I mentioned, in the same in the same space,
where before, you will be able to run just
one instance of your REST API, like in the
case of virtual machine. Now you can actually
run multiple instances of your local container
with using much, much, much less amount of
resources in there. So you can really scale
significantly by using Docker containers.
Let's see now what we need to do to containerize
or Docker eyes our REST API.
To create the Docker image for a REST API,
the first thing we need to do is create the
corresponding Docker file. However, before
doing that, and to keep things simple, we
will update our REST API so that it no longer
performs HTTPS redirection, and allows the
use of the HTTP address only. The use of HTTPS
from here on is a topic out of the scope of
this tutorial.
So what does this mean? If you remember, we
do have two URLs configured for a REST API.
And those are configured in our lunch settings
file on their properties. And you said Lisa,
Jason, application URL, we do have HTTPS localhost
5001 and HTTP localhost 5000.
And the way that things are configured right
now, if anybody tries to access HTTP localhost
5000, they will get redirected into HTTPS
localhost 5001.
You want to test this, what you can do is
just launch the app. So I'll do f5 here.
And I'll open postman. And normally we would
go to HTTPS localhost 5001. But I'll change
this into HTTP localhost 5000.
And in this case, I'll actually open the postman
console down here
to see what's happening behind the scenes.
And I'll do sent to query for items. The query
succeeded. But then if you see there are two
calls in here, the first one for HTTP localhost
5000 slash items. It returned 307 code, which
means a redirect. And then that was followed
by a call to HTTPS localhost 5001 slash items.
So that's a the redirect that has been configured
right now is what we want to change for the
Docker case, at least.
So how do we change this? Going back to VS
code, and I'll just stop the app and close
this for now.
This is configured in startup.cs.
In under the Configure method, we have this
line here, up that use HTTPS redirection
So he turns to me that when you run inside
the Docker file, well, sorry, inside the Docker
container, the ASP net environment switches
from development into production. And this
is what we can use to put a conditional on
this on this line. So we can say is, if, and
that is development,
then we will allow the HTTPS redirection,
but otherwise, we will not allow.
That's the only change that we're going to
make here. We will see how this works. Actually,
when we have the Docker container ready to
go.
This point, I'll just close this. And now
we actually want to generate or actually to
create this Docker file. So there's two ways
to create a Docker file, either you can create
it manually, or you can generate it. For this
tutorial, we will have to speed things up,
we will generate. So you need a Docker file.
Well, I would recommend if you're a business
to recode, is to use a Docker extension for
Visual Studio code. And that you can find
if you go to the extensions hub,
you can just type Docker here.
And then you will go ahead and install the
extension.
And now close this. And now what you can do
is just say, view command palette, and then
you can type Docker Docker files to workspace
is the first option there.
Now you get to pick the platform of the Docker
image we're going to create in our case will
be dotnet. ASP. NET Core,
then you got to pick the operating system
of the container, in our case is going to
be Linux, just because it's the most popular
option most of the time.
And then you get to pick the port that you're
going to release in in in within that container.
In our case, it's going to be Port 80.
And finally, if you want to generate a Docker
compose file, we will not use this in this
tutorial to hit No.
And now if you go to our explorer here, you're
going to see there's a couple of new files,
we have the Docker file and the Docker ignore
file. So let's start by looking at the Docker
file.
In the Docker file, each line that you can
see here represents a one set of instructions
that are going to be applied as the Docker
image or Docker image is going to be built.
And each of these lines will also generate
what we call a layer that represents the changes
that are happening from one line to the next
line. And that's what helps a lot in terms
of a caching of steps as we do subsequent
builds of this Docker image. So the first
time we will build it, it will take time.
And this was a good time. So silicon times
is going to be much faster. Now let's go one
by line by line here to understand what's
going on.
So the first thing that's happening is we're
saying that we will be building out our image
base it on the dotnet ASP net image, specifically
version five, zero, right. So that's, that's
the way that you that you start by saying,
Where do you want to go from by specifying
dotnet. asp. net, you're guaranteed to be
building a your image based on
working ASP net environment, in this case,
a five zero environment that has all the dependencies
that are needed to run an ASP. NET app. And
not just that the ASP net image has a has
a at the same time has been built based on
the correct always based on wait where you're
running your image on in our case, since we're
going to be running it in a Linux machine.
That will include all the dependencies to
run an ASP NET Core app, or the net five app
in Linux.
Now, we're also saying this is five zero as
base. This means that this is going to be
a our first stage of the building the container.
This is
a good segue into the concept of multistage
builds, which is what's enabled here. This
means that there will be more than one stage
on the build process. And in each stage, you
can specify a different set of instructions
that may have nothing to do with the instructions
executed in some other stage. So for instance,
here we're saying, so this is the first stage
and we'll call it a base. And in this stage,
we'll go from a dotnet. asp. net, which is
the runtime image for ASP. NET five work there
is going to be slash app means everything
that happens after this will happen in the
in the app directory. And then that we expose
a port 80 this line actually means does not
mean much is just a kind of a documentation
field. The way that you expose a port is a
bit different actually. But it is a there's
a convention to specify the port that they
are policing in. Now that temporarily finishes
that first stage and in the next nine
In line five, we are going into our next stage
that we're calling built. And the interesting
part about this stage is that it comes from
a another base image, if you notice this is
coming from dotnet, SDK
to dotnet. SDK five series are supposed to
dotnet. asp. net. So SDK is the image that
has all the build tools, and all the libraries,
everything that's needed to build
and dotnet five app, which is not the saying
that you need to just run other than five
AP, right. So this, whatever is coming in
this ACP image is potentially much bigger.
There's a much, much more files, compilers
and stuff in there that are needed for building
the container, but not needed for just running.
So that means that your final image that's
going to go actually from the base image is
potentially going to be much smaller than
the image that we're going to use to build
your container.
So we start with this stage, in this case,
it worked there is going to be a slash src.
So that's where we're going to place any files
from here on. And that's exactly what we're
doing. Then in the next line, we're saying,
Okay, so let's copy the catalog, that CS profile,
the one that defines our project into the
root of the current location.
And they will run a dotnet restore, on that
break. So that brings in all the nougat packages
that are needed, then we say, OK, so we have
restored all the packages, now copy every
other a file that's needed a folder up. So
that includes all the files that you can see
on the left side, except for a few sections,
but most of the files are included here. And
we'll talk about that in a moment.
And then there's this line here, that's actually
not that much needed. Because as you can see,
it's pretty much the same as the as line six.
So we will actually delete this in a moment.
And then we go into the actual build process,
where we say, hey, go ahead and perform a
dotnet built on catalog that says Prague,
we're modifying a Korean configuration to
not be the bug anymore, we want to release
version of the app to optimize it for the
production environment. And the results of
that build should go into the slash app slash
build directory.
So currently, that finishes our build stage.
So it's this section here. And then we're
switching to yet another stage that we're
calling it publish. In the bullish stage,
what we saying is, actually, we're going to
go from the build stage. So notice, now we're
going from build is the stage that we just
created. And we will go from there and name
it as bullish, and just execute the dotnet
publish command. with similar set of parameters
and the previous one, just changing the output
directory. So that then polish, what it does
is
it creates a new folder, in this case called
Polish with all the files are needed in the
right shape, to just execute the app. Now
at this point, I'd like to point out that
I find a few of these lines are a little bit
redundant. So we could simplify things a little
bit here. So I don't think we need to separate
both a build and abolish stage. So I'm going
to make a couple of changes here. So I'm going
to actually remove these a warfare source
line, because we already have these in line
six. So I'm going to remove that. And I'm
going to also remove dotnet build just because
dotnet Polish also performs dotnet build for
us. So there's no need for two separate lines.
And I'm actually going to completely remove
the Polish stage because their build stage
should be good enough for what we did here.
So now we just have one stage called built.
One second stage called built, that will end
up by running duct and polish. And all the
files that we need should end up being in
Polish.
Now in 912, we go back to our initial basic
stage, build stage, and we're going to be
calling it as final. Right. So now we're pretty
much finishing what's what's going on here.
So we switch again to the app directory. And
then we're saying what we're saying is, okay,
so now let's copy from the foolish build stage,
we net, which in our case is no longer there,
we actually opted for built. So I'm going
to actually copy this and change it into build.
So from the build stage, go ahead and copy
whatever is in the app slash Polish directory,
the one that will replace all the files, copy
all of that into recording directory, which
will be slash app.
And finally, we'll define the entry point
for our app. So this is how we define how
to start our REST API. And in our case, that
will be just by hitting the we're executing
the dotnet command with the catalog that dll
file. That's all that's needed to start our,
our REST API.
With this Docker file, we're pretty much ready
to build our image. But before doing that,
what I wanted to do is just show you about
the dot Docker ignore file.
So this Docker ignore file, what it does is,
it defines a series of files and directories
that you want to exclude from the Docker image.
So there may be a one or more files that you
don't want to include in the Docker image,
because it makes no sense to close. For instance,
the stuff that we have on there that VS code
is really only useful for development purposes.
But it means he has, it makes no sense to
include that into the Docker image. So for
instance, this line here specifies Hey, use,
go ahead and exclude everything under slash
that VS code. And the same thing for a bunch
of other files and directories. So a good
file to not forget to keep in mind, otherwise,
your image will end up being bigger than it
is.
So with that, we should be ready to start
building the array image. So what I'm going
to do is just open a new terminal.
And to build the image, what you do is use
a Docker is Eli.
So what we're going to say is Docker build,
then you, you have to specify attack, I mean
the name for the image and attack for it.
So that you do be the dash D, qualifier. And
then we will give it a name, the name will
be catalog, and then you give it a tag, which
in our case, let's say is going to be v one.
And finally you specify the directory from
which you're going to execute the command.
In our case, that's going to be
the current directory, which is specified
by the.so. I'll hit Enter.
And that's going to go ahead and build the
image. So first thing we need to do is go
ahead and download any of them base images.
In our case, that will be the dotnet ASP net
image, the runtime image will go ahead and
do that. And then for the second layer for
the second build stage needs to pull in the
dotnet SDK, a five zero SDK, a five zero image,
which may take a little bit more because it's
speaker, and then it proceeds to perform the
actual build process within the the image.
So Docker restore,
and they are to publish, and then all the
other steps that ended up creating that image.
So at this point, we have an image ready.
And like I said, each of the lines going back
to a local file, each of the lines here represents
one layer that maps to each of the steps that
you see here. So he says step,
a bunch of steps here.
So step one of 13,
to 13, three of 13. Each of these will correspond
to each of the lines that you can see on the
Docker file. So these are the layers that
will be cached from here on,
so that you don't have to do them again. So
in our case, if we don't have it, if you don't
make any change, if you've tried to do Docker
build dash D, the same command again, I hit
Enter, really mostly nothing happens because
everything is cached. So only if you make
some changes, then those some of these layers
may need to be executed again.
Now, one thing to remember is that this is
not the only container that we need for our
REST API. We also have the MongoDB container,
which is the one that handles that access
for us our database server, right and which
is the one that has our database. So we need
to make sure that our new container for the
REST API is able to talk to the MongoDB container.
And the way to do that, at least in the local
box, is by setting up what we call a Docker
network. And having both containers join that
that Docker network. So how do we deal with
this network to create a network, the only
thing that you have to do is just say,
Docker, network, create, add use, give it
a name. So we will say that five tutorial
and that crazy network
if you want to see the the existing networks,
you can do Docker network LS.
And you will see we have the our net 530 network
already created.
So now when we run our containers, we should
take advantage of that network. So what I'm
going to do is first make sure that I'm not
running the MongoDB container yet. So I'll
do docker ps, the MongoDB container is running
right now. So I'm going to stop it
Docker stop Mongo
to that stopped, and I'm going to run once
again, the same command that we've been using
so far to run our container.
let me paste that here. Same command.
But I'm going to add one modify here that
says network equals and the network name that
you use was defined in this case, net five
tutorial.
So that makes a disk container a joint that
did work. So I'll say Mongo,
the name of the Docker image, so hit enter.
And then the MongoDB container is running
in that network. After doing that, we're ready
to actually start running our a catalog container,
which by the way, if used to Docker images,
you should be able to see our created image.
As you can see, we do have catalog be one,
ready to be executed, as well as the Docker
images for the dotnet. SDK, and the dotnet,
ASP net, runtime, and Mako.
So to run our Docker image, we're going to
do something very similar to what we did with
MongoDB. So we'll start by saying, Docker
run.
And then instead of doing dash D, for the
dash, we'll do dash ID for interactive, that
allows us to keep our terminal connected to
the Docker run process, just to see whatever
whichever logs are coming out of that container.
And then we will do the RM so that whenever
we stopped the container, it actually it gets
deleted, so we don't keep hanging around.
And now we specify the port, similar as we
did with MongoDB. Now we have to specify which
is the port that's going to be mapped from
our local machine into the container. In our
case, let's pick ADHD, it doesn't have to
be it, you can use any other body port. And
that is mapped to the internal port in the
Docker image. Now, for ASP net, and that five
images. The base image itself, it's been a
runtime image defines or overwrite the port
where the app executes, at least for HTTP.
So that port is 80. So regardless of the fact
that we've been using Port 5000, for local
development, when we base our Docker image
in the ASP NET Core runtime image, the port
is overrated into 80. So you will have to
specify 80. And if you don't want to use 80,
there are ways to specify the port that you
want to use in your degree in your Docker
file. But in our case, the Port 80 will be
just fine.
Now we have to remember that in order for
our app to connect to MongoDB, we have to
specify a series of settings, right. So if
you remember when we go to app settings that
Jason, we have this MongoDB Settings section,
where we specify host, port and user. And
not only that, it will remember going back
to Settings MongoDB settings, we specify host
port user and also password which is coming
from secret manager.
So in this case, since we are trying to talk
to Mongo to MongoDB.
From within the container, we can no longer
use just localhost to reach out to it.
They remember that each of these,
each of the apps running inside of the container,
both arrest API and MongoDB are running in
an isolated way. And they can no longer resolve
things by localhost. So for our REST API to
talk to the MongoDB container, it has to do
it via the name of the container of MongoDB.
In our case, remember that we gave it the
name of Mongo.
So we have to override the host name. To talk
to Mongo, we don't have to touch it update
the JSON file for this, what we can do is
just take advantage of the configuration system
of 35 to be able to override the settings.
So this one going to be setting section can
be totally overridden by environment variables.
And that's what we're going to do now. So
as long as we follow the convention, we should
be able to make that happen. So I'm going
to say dash E, that's the way that you define
an environment variable in in Docker,
I'm going to say, I'm going to use MongoDB
settings. So just copy that. And then we'll
say colon host. And that host is going to
be Mongo, the name of the Mongo container.
So that's how you can override this localhost
as specified here. Now the same way that we
did that, we need to specify a password because
the password that we've been using so far
is stored in the secret manager. And the secret
manager is only being used for development,
a development purposes is only available in
development environment, it is not available
in production, and the Docker image, the Docker
container is really going to be running in
a production environment. So how do we feed
that password, same thing that we did a, just
now we'll say MongoDB settings. Let's not
forget to also add dash in MongoDB, settings,
password, and then we specify the password
as bound word one.
And that's it. And then let's not forget that
we need to join also this container into the
same network as the previous container. They
won't go on the inner so that's going to be
network
med five tutorial, make sure this is exactly
the same network that you used before. And
finally the name of the container and
the name of the image and the deck. So that
will be catalog. Be one
and I think I may have a couple of mistakes.
Here. So the first thing might be, let's see,
yeah, so it should be dash dash RM as opposed
to a dash RM.
And the next one would be Yeah. So this one
should be equals supposed to column. And then
I'll hit enter.
So that has started our Docker container.
And as you can see, our hosting environment
has now changed from development to production.
So production is the environment that will
be reflected when you run the Docker image
as opposed to development anymore. Now let's
see if things are working properly, we should
be able to reach out to our REST API at Port
8080. So let's open up postman.
And now let's just switch from Port 5000,
to Port 8080.
And let's see what happens send.
And through to be told, the API keeps working.
But now as you can see, we're hitting a port
8080. So things are happening within the Docker
container.
Also, notice how we did not get a redirect
anymore. So instead of getting at 307, like
we did before, we got 200 right away. So there's
no more redirect happening in there, we're
just going to be at the HTTP endpoint. Now
to keep things interesting, let's actually
post one more item here via our post tab over
here. And I'll do the same thing. I'll switch
from HTTPS to http. And then I'll do Port
8080.
The 80. And so let's say let's say that we
bring in back that antidote for you. So sometime
in the past, and then I'll do price 15.
an hour heat sent.
And as you can see, I'll just close the console.
Now,
the audio has been created.
Now really, the interesting part about Docker
and Docker images, is not just being able
to create them, right, but also to be able
to share them so that they can be used by
either other persons or some other systems.
So how could we share this Docker image that
we have in our box now with some somebody
else, right, so use for the sake of this tutorial,
we'll do something very simple to see how
this can happen, we're going to take advantage
of a service called Docker Hub, which you
can find Let me open up the browser here.
You can find at hub that docker.com. So this
is the place that the creators of Docker offer,
so that people can publicly share their Docker
images. So creating an account here is totally
free. So feel free to try it out. So you'd
have to come up with some Docker ID, I mean,
some kind of a username and a password. And
then you can have your own account in Docker
Hub.
So how can I get my image Polish into Docker
Hub. So let's go back to Visual Studio code.
And I'll stop my Docker container now, by
doing Ctrl. C. And the first thing that I'm
going to do is actually logging in into Docker
Hub. So once you have an account in there,
you should be able to do a simple Docker login
to be able to start pushing image in there
are a way to do is just say, Docker login.
So this is going to ask me for my user username,
my case is, will you see it will ask for my
password.
And now I'm logged in.
So now in order to get our currently existing
image into Docker Hub, we just need to do
a little bit of retagging to tell it where
we want to place this image. So let's leave
our images that once again, local images.
So here's the mission catalog b1. So we want
we want to do is just retag these in in this
way.
So let's do Docker tag, catalog be one
that's the Korean, the green tag, catalog,
big one. And then our target tag is going
to be starting with our username, my username,
in this case, for you see, and then slash
the name of the of the image in Docker Hub,
when you get to Docker Hub is going to be
called a repository. And so that was during
August is going to be catalog.
It doesn't have to be you can choose. But
I'd like to give it just the same as we had
before. So you can typically see a slash catalog
be one, hit Enter. And like I said, this is
just a tag. So if I do Docker images again,
we're going to find it now you have catalog
B one, and who you see slash catalog B one.
But if you notice the image ID and you look
closely, you'll see that the ID that both
of these images have is pretty much the same
So it's really you can think of the stacks
as just pointers into one of the images. But
with this retag, we are able to now actually
push the image into Docker Hub. So what I'm
going to do now is just say, Docker push
our new newly written image, catalog b1, hit
Enter.
And this starts the process to upload, not
just our REST API dogri mesh, but all the
layers that are composing these REST API needs
to go into Docker Hub. So remember that our
Docker images Docker base is the ASP NET Core
runtime image. And that one, in turn is vetted
in some distribution of Linux in this case.
So all of those things need to go into Docker
Hub, so that anybody else got in the future,
just pull that image and start using. So these
may take a while because it's an upload,
upload task.
Alright, so the image finish uploading. And
now if I go back to Docker Hub, where I'm
going to do is actually sign in with my account
here.
And as you can see, I do have my image just
uploaded a few seconds ago, who you see slash
catalog.
And
here's the one fact that we have right now.
So that would be one.
So let's see that let's play the role of somebody
that does not have this image in their system
right now, and that they want to use it. In
that case, what they can do is either do a
Docker pull, or just run the image. So let
me show you what I mean. So the image is now
available in Docker Hub. So I go back to VS
code. And what I'm going to do is just completely
remove the image that we have currently in
our system. So let's do Docker images, once
again, and we're going to do is just remove
these two images, so that it gets completely
out of the system. And to do that, I'll do
Docker Rmi, will you see slash catalog v one,
and Docker Rmi,
catalog, v one. So now there should be no
catalog image anymore.
In my system, z only, I only have these three
images right now. So now, the only thing that
I'm going to do is use to Docker log out
to simulate somebody that actually has no
access to my Docker Docker registry. But since
the image is public, they should be able to
pull it. So in order to pull the image, you
can either do the local Docker pool operation,
so local pool, or you can run it right away.
So we can run it in the same way that we run
it before. So let me show you is going to
be pretty much the same command line, I'm
going to actually copy paste here.
But now instead of you're saying catalog b1,
what we can say is polisi, slash, catalog,
b1. So just keep in mind, so I am at this
point, I am somebody that has never,
that has never had access to the catalog,
REST API service, I have no access to the
Docker file or anything about how to build
this image, I just want to run it for the
very first time. So I do this command line
and hit enter.
It says yeah, I cannot find this image locally.
So we'll go ahead and actually pull it from
Docker Hub, and then run it. And as you can
see, it is already running. If I go back to
postman,
and I try to query for items again.
I get my items from this Docker image. So
that's how you can publish or push your Docker
image into what we call a Container Registry,
in this case, Docker Hub, and then it is pulled
back, potentially in some other machine. That's
how you can share it. So we may end up using
some other form of Docker registry in future
videos. But for now, I just wanted to show
you how you can do the sharing of Docker images
across systems.
In this episode of The dotnet five REST API
tutorial, we continue our path towards deploying
the REST API to a production environment by
using Kubernetes. We will talk about the implications
of running containers outside of the dead
box with no downtime and how Kubernetes is
a perfect fit for these and the many other
challenges of running distributed systems
resiliently.
Today you will learn why a container orchestrator
is needed. What is Kubernetes and which are
its basic components. How grenades enables
resilient distributed systems, how to stand
up a basic units closer in your box, how to
deploy your REST API and one of the
to coordinate this, and how to scale a Kubernetes
deployment.
So if you remember from the previous video,
we talked about these orange box, which so
far we've been talking about it is the production
environment, right? In this case, let's just
call it an old Indian, this is the, this is
the either the physical, or the virtual machine,
where we're going to be running our Docker
engine, right? These things to this Docker
engine, that were able to run a bunch of containers
in this dog, this could be either our API
containers, or also our MongoDB container
or many other containers, right, that we want
to run in this node.
However, a few interesting questions start
arising as we move forward with this approach,
right? For instance, who takes care of pulling
and running containers. So I mean, can imagine
that without any forter sort of automation,
somebody will have to come to this box, and
actually start doing Docker run for each of
the containers that we want to run in this
box? Right? So that's an interesting question.
So either some information somebody saw somebody
has to take care of this, how to run the containers,
right? So who knows? Or where do you see the
reading? All these different environment,
variables, secrets, and different common arguments
that we have to fit into Docker run, to be
able to run the containers exactly the right
way, for each of the cases?
And what if, what if we don't have enough
container instances? Right? So what if we
need more, so something or somebody has to
start spinning up more and more instances,
as as needed, both for a recipe containers
or for any other containers that we want,
we may have in this box?
Right? And then also,
we may win, we may not be able to fit, just
I mean, we can only fit so many containers
in a box, right? So at some point, we may
need to introduce get way more nodes, right?
And then somebody has to decide if the containers
are going to be created are going to go into
in this case to node node two, node three
and two, node n. Right? So who decides this
distance here? So do we have a person that
is looking at the different stats for each
of these nodes, and just decides to do Docker
run in each of these indices machines? How
does that work?
Also, a are the containers healthy? So what
happens if one of these containers crashes?
What do we do? Who is on point to make sure
that we bring back this failed container so
that we keep having as many as we wanted?
To start with?
Also, where do we store all the secrets? For
the restore to database files for MongoDB?
database? Where do you put all these? How
do we enable containers to talk to each other?
Right? Because we know that our REST API containers
need to talk to our MongoDB container. But
how do we enable that communication in so
far, we've been using these Docker network,
right to make them communicate. But as we
have more boxes, more containers, how to make
sure that they can all talk to each other.
And one more thing, how do we read this container
from the outside, right? Because all of these
containers are running in the box. But all
of them are running with some port a opened
locally. But then what if somebody comes from
the outside? What will be that public IP that
somebody from the outside will use to talk
to these containers? And if they talk to them?
Which of all the instances would serve the
request? Because we have so many instances
in there who decides which is the right instance,
for the request that's coming in? So all of
these questions? How can we solve all these
challenges? Well, this is exactly the reason
why we want to introduce an orchestrator tool
like Kubernetes. So enter Kubernetes
so
as we describe what goons can do, let's they
think again about this
These dots, right? So we have, let's say we
have these three nodes. And we need to start
placing containers in them. And we have to
do a bunch of things to get these containers
up and running in the right way. So instead
of having to have an individual person, or
some sort of a script that needs to run, to
be able to allocate, and to make sure that
everything is going properly in across these
nodes, we're going to be introducing this
component called Well, I've got a series of
components that we call the control plane
in Kubernetes. So the control plane has several
components that take care of all the the it's
kind of the brain of coronaries. So he decides
how to schedule the container into the different
nodes, he decides what to do if one of these,
one of these containers is destroyed, how
to bring back one, one more how to let them
communicate to each other, and a bunch of
decisions, right. So for instance, when we
want to get one new container deployed to
one of these nodes, or we can do is via the
control plane, we can create a deployment,
what this deployment is going to do deployments,
by the way, one of the resources inside grenades.
And so what is flaming can do is go ahead,
find the image that we need in the Container
Registry, and then allocate what we call a
port for that, for the container that will
be will pulling in now the ports are really
the smallest deployable unit of computing
that you can create, and manage inside Kubernetes.
Right. So the pod, it has a similarity to
what we call, if you think a pot of wealth,
right that I guess that's the symbol for Docker.
But it's a group of one or more containers
that are sharing, storage and network resources.
And it The report also declares how to run
the containers inside them, right. So you
will always be working more with bought that
with containers, you can read with the containers
directly, you will only work with bots. So
for instance, in this part, we will have,
let's say one container, which is a very common
case to use have one container per pod. But
you don't have to have one, you can start
standing up your deployment object, you can
start standing up more than one container
for let's say this is for catalog race API.
But in this first note, we don't have to just
have this catalog API, right. So we could
have some other port for some other service
that in this case has not one but two containers
inside of it. More than that, we will have
also a port for our Mongo for a Mongo container,
right that we need to also pull in, that has
access also to these database database needs
to get a granted access to some storage to
be able to store the database files. But then
the thing is that the this catalog posts don't
have to be using node one, right? So when
we run out of space, we may want to take advantage
of other nodes like no two here, right. So
again, the control plane will take care of
deciding where to put these these ports across
the entire set of nodes that we have here.
So in this case, we have seen three, but you
can think that this can be an entire form
of dozens and dozens of nodes, and then control
plane will decide which is the node that is
the perfect fit for the ports that need to
be allocated. Right, if Lemmon declares that
it needs three ports. So this may be Was it
the one way that the polls are distributed?
If deployment says no, I need four pots that
we may want to deploy get another pot pot
for into node three because notaries use free
at this point, right? Same way with some other
pod. He may want to be allocated somewhere
else. There's no space in node one. So let's
just put it in no tree. Let's see, just because
no tree has so much memory available, right?
The other thing is that what three, let's
say for three wants to talk to utterly all
of our catalog boards, we want to talk to
the database, right? So how do they do that?
So there's this object called the service
in coordinates. And the service allows us
to reach the other components that are available.
So what else in the cluster? So in this case,
I'm saying, well, I want to reach out to the
Mongo service via that Mongo service, I am
actually able to reach to the database. In
a similar way, if we have an external client
that wants to talk to our catalog, a REST
API, how can I reach it? So again, we stand
up a catalog service, which can reach in our
case for now ingesting the localhost, but
eventually it could be a public IP. And then
this client can reach to the to this service
and be at that service. It can reach not just
one but all of the pods that are running behind
the Behind the surface, right, so it's a way
to route to those to those bots. So all of
these is what we call a meet all of these
components is what we call The Goonies cluster,
right? The suit of all these components. And
now, what I'm what I'm showing here is really
just just the tip of the iceberg in terms
of all the possible resources. And, and the
series of configurations and the capabilities
that can be a use within coordinates. Really
it there's a lot that can be done with coronaries
and but here, we'll just explore just a few
of them to understand how it works. And so
in terms of benefits of using Kubernetes,
one of the main things about this is the ability
to turn desired state into active state. So
like I said, we create a deployment object
where we say, hey, I want three copies of
the catalog service. So that is a solid state.
So Kubernetes via the control plane, we'll
have to figure out how to make those four,
four instances of the catalog container available
as support somewhere in the series of nodes
that we have available. If you have three
nodes to find space in those two nodes, if
you just had one node, so figured out how
to allocate that in that one node, or we could
have hundreds of nodes, right. So decided
to stay in the Draco state is a key feature
of Kubernetes. Then, like I said, select nodes
to run the bots. So it the control Bay has
knowledge of the stats of features installed.
So depending on the amount of CPU, or the
amount of RAM available in each of the nodes,
it is able to allocate the port in the right
place. It also allows for self healing. And
so if he detects that one of the ports, let's
say port three is just easiest to destroy
for any reason, it should be able to automatically
bring back another part. So let's say that
a note to the entire note just goes down,
right? If that happens, then a control plane
will know that it is able to I mean, that
is missing one note, sorry, one port, and
then it needs to allocate that boat somewhere
else, either node one or node three in this
case. So this is the self healing capability
of Kubernetes. That's super handy. It also
is able to store configuration secrets. So
he has a it has a place to store all the configuration
that you need for your for the services, and
also to store to safely store sensitive information
and like secrets, so somewhere in there so
that they cannot be compromised. Like I said,
he provides service discovery and load balancing.
So when the client calls and talked to the
catalog service, it is able to be directed
to the right at one of these nodes following
following some algorithm to load balance across
them. It also ensures no downtime. Because
whenever it it, let's say that we want to
deploy a new version of our catalog, Docker
image right across all of these spots, it
will not just destroy all the pods at once
and bring back a bunch of pods with a new
image, it actually those will will slowly
roll out the new version of the of the image
as as new ports as it starts destroying the
older port. So only when it configures that
new, the new instances of the ports are available,
he will start getting rid of the older ones.
So that way it keeps I mean, it makes sure
that there's no downtime for clients. He can
also auto scale. So it can be configured to
say hey, if there's so much CPU being used
across the across all of our nodes just spin
up even a more pots in any order available
nodes to satisfy the demand. So, within this
tutorial, we will be doing scaling exercise
manually, but corneas can be also configured
be configured to do the scaling automatically
for you. It also disabled to on demand automatic
storage, so you can easily declare that you
want so much storage for your port, and granary
will I mean without having you don't have
to know exactly where that storage is going
to be. You'd have to say hey, coordinates,
I need storage and grenades will be in charge
to figure out where to find the storage and
make it available for the port. And finally,
it provides a what we call gradual rollout
and rollback use, just like I said, it will
gradually start bringing in new ports as needed.
And also if there's some issues with some
ports, it is able to roll them back to a healthy
version. So now that we know what Kubernetes
is, let's see how to get our catalog REST
API and the MongoDB database deployed into
a local Kubernetes cluster.
To get started with Kubernetes The first thing
that we're going to need is a Kubernetes cluster.
locally. If you're already using Docker in
your box, you already have it An easy way
to send up a simple local velocity for development
purposes. Let me show you how. If you go to
your Windows taskbar, you should be able to
find this Docker icon. You can right click
this I can select Settings. And this opens
Docker settings in your box, maximize this.
And here, what you're looking for is the q&a
section on the left side, and then enable
coordinators over here, so I'll just click
on it, and then click Apply, restart and then
click Install. Now this is going to take a
while if this is the first time that you're
enabling coronaries, because this is going
to set up a local cluster simple with just
one node. But still it is a local cluster,
and that Docker needs to download a bunch
of Docker images for all the components of
Kubernetes, into your box to that. So that
may take a while. In my case, I already have
all these images downloaded, so it was a bit
faster. What is complete we're looking for
is this message here that says grenade is
running, it should say running and it should
be green, and then you know that you're good
to go. So I'll just close this window now.
With the Kubernetes cluster up and running,
one of the first things that I like to do
is to make sure that I am connected to the
correct Kubernetes cluster. And that we can
do via the cube control command line tool,
which is the command line tool to interact
with Kubernetes. These tools should be already
installed for you with your Docker installation.
So you should be able to start using it right
away. I'll open up a brand new terminal. And
what I'm going to do is just type cube control
config. current context, hit Enter. And that
is giving me back Docker desktop. So indeed,
Docker desktop is the is the name of the cluster
installed by Docker, once we enabled the Kubernetes
cluster, so we are good to go on that side.
Now it is time to start creating or declaring
how we want to deploy the components into
Kubernetes. For our REST API and database,
do that we will need to write a few yamo files.
To make this simpler. What I'd like to do
is to take advantage of the granaries VS code
extension. So to do that, I'll first just
close this terminal. And I'll go to the extensions
hub. And I'll search for Grenada is this one
here should be the first heat, I'll just say
install should take a few seconds. And now
it's ready. So I'll close this. What I'll
do now is go back to our file explorer, and
I'm going to create a folder to start storing
all the files that we need to deploy our resources
to Kubernetes. So this is going to be our
Kubernetes folder, it can really be any name
as you please. And then the first one we're
going to create here is going to be named
catalog the job. And I'm naming it this way,
because this will declare all the resources
that we need to deploy our catalog REST API
to Kubernetes. And also to keep things simple.
To speed up the process, I'm going to take
advantage of that goodness extension that
we have installed to generate a little bit
of code here. So I'll just say deploy, and
that pops up a little bit of IntelliSense,
as you can see, and then we just have to click
it. And that will give us a basic shape for
our deployment resource. Now the plugin resource
is what you would use to declare the desired
state of the containers or specifically the
ports that you want to get deployed into Kubernetes.
For in this case for a REST API. So let's
understand what what this file means. So if
you see the first line declares what we call
the API version, this is something that all
the coronis resources will will have. And
this allows you to specify what is the API
surface that you want to take advantage of
in Kubernetes. So depending on the version
you pick here, you will have access to more
or less features of the resource that you're
configuring, in this case, a deployment resource.
second line declares the kind as as we know,
is a payment object. And then we go to metadata
name. Metadata name defines the name for these
deployments. So in our case, we'll use name
it
catalog. And then we go to the specs section.
The first part of the suspects section is
the what we call the selector. And the selector
is what we use to specify how is this deployment
going to select the port that is it is going
to manage. So in this case, it is saying Well,
I'm going to say to manage all the pots that
have the following labels. And in this case,
we just have one label, it is called app.
And then there's a value, the value that we're
going to assign here is going to be good.
So all the ports that have an app label name
with the value catalog, will be managed by
this deployment. Then we keep going into the
template section. So here is where we're going
to declare all of these containers that are
going to be included in the, in this deployment.
So one of the first things to declare here
is the label or the labels for these for the
bots. In this case, we're going to name this
this bot as catalog that's going to be the
label. So that's the way that we can identify
all the bots that are related to catalog in
this case, and this one has to match exactly
the label that we just typed a moment ago,
so that the deployment can actually manage
these bots. Then we will forward to the most
interesting section, which is a spec on the
template. And the first thing that we're going
to find here is containers. So here, we declare
the list of containers that are going to be
included in this deployment. And the first
thing that we have to do for this very first
container is we'll give it a name. So again,
to keep things simple, we'll just name it
the catalog. And then we have to declare,
which is the image that we are going to be
deployed. In our case, we're just going to
be using that image that we created in the
previous video that we deployed to Docker
Hub. And then in my case, it was blue sea
catalog, b1. So we are saying we are going
to be pulling down into Kubernetes, this image
named who you see catalog be one that we were
saying there, but you could specify any image
that you want here. Next, we go into the resources
section. So here's where you declare what
resources specifically in terms of memory
and CPU, in this case, what resources are
needed from the Kubernetes node, in order
to run your REST API. In this case, I'm just
saying, Well, I'm going to be needing 128
megabytes, which by the way, while may be
right will be equivalent roughly to 1024 gigabytes.
So that is the full value here, you could
change this according to your needs. And then
on the other side, we have the CPU where we're
saying that we want to use 500 million CPU.
So this is an interesting notation. And what
it really means is, this is similar to say,
I'll just type here would be kind of like
0.5 CPU, so roughly half CPU, just to understand
it better. So 500. So basically, we're saying
we are good to go with one half CPU for our
REST API, which would be definitely enough
for us. Next, let me scroll down a bit. We
have the ports. So here's the word declare,
which is the port that that our container
is exposing. And we can communicate to in
order to access the REST API. In our case,
we're going to do just as we did in the previous
video, where we mapped into the into port
80. Because we said that they are base ASP
NET Core image overrides our port, and by
using Port 80. So we will be using the same
port, or 80. So that's a port inside the container
where we can reach the REST API. The next
thing that we're going to need in this deployment
is a few environment variables. Because if
you remember, when we run our container, we
had to specify both the host to be able for
it to be able to talk to our MongoDB container,
and also the password for the user that connects
to that to that database. So how do we specify
environment variables in this case, it's fairly
straightforward. We can use the M section,
so you just type M. And then you have to declare
key app name value pairs for each of the environment
variables. The first of all we're going to
declare is
the one for host. And then if you remember,
in app settings JSON, which I'm going to open
right now quickly, we have this hierarchy
of settings, right we have MongoDB settings.
And in what we said is we have host or user
and password. So I'll go back to catalog jammal.
And we have to follow that same hierarchy.
So I'll do Mongo DB settings. And then the
way to separate add to go into the hierarchy
in in this java file will be be a double underscore.
And remember when we run will be passing variables
into the container, we use colon, one in this
java file, the convention we're going to use
is going to be double underscore. So that's
How you address these different settings.
And then we'll give it a value. The value
for the host in coronaries is going to be
MongoDB. service. And we'll see in a moment
how we define this MongoDB service. But for
now, so yes, this is how we can address the
MongoDB container that we're going to declare
later on. Next, we need an environment variable
for the password. But before we can declare
it, we actually have to create this password,
add ingredients. And luckily, coneys has this
built in support for secrets. sensitive information
like that. So in order to do that we're going
to do is just open my terminal. And I'm going
to actually use a shortcut here Ctrl J, that
opens up the last terminal we used and scroll
down a little bit. And then we're going to
type here is the cube control an option to
be able to create a secret. So that would
be cube CTL. Create secret. And then I'll
type generic. Generic is the type of circuit
that we can use in this case, but there's
a few other options that you that you can
also use here, then it's fine for us. We'll
name it, catalog secrets. And I'll use spooler,
just because you can actually put multiple
secrets in one of these secrets here. But
we're only going to be using one. And in order
to type it directly in the command line, what
you do is say from literal. And then you have
to specify the name and the value for the
secret. So the name is going to be MongoDB.
Password. and the value is going to be just
like we did before as bad bound word one.
And then I'll hit enter. So that created the
secret. Now that we have created the secret,
we can actually go ahead and declare it and
feed it into an environment variable. To do
that, we'll do something similar. So we'll
say name. And again, we'll follow the the
hierarchy, right, so MongoDB settings, in
this case, double underscore is going to be
password. And then in this case, we don't
want to use the value, we want to read it
from the secret. And to read it from the secret
what we can say is value from Enter. And we'll
say secret key ref. So we're referencing a
secret that's named name is going to be catalog
secrets is the name that we gave the secret.
And the actual key within that catalog secrets
is going to be Mongo DB. Password. So that's
how you can address a secret from the declaration
of an environment variable in Kubernetes.
That's looking good. I'll close this terminal
again, have more space here. And the next
thing that we want to specify here is our
our health probes. So the health probes is
a mechanism that enables coronaries to constantly
monitor the health of our race API, by using
the health checks that we already defined.
If you remember, a few episodes ago, we declared
some health checks in the REST API. So now
it's we're gonna we can actually, we can actually
use them to let us know if our containers
are in good shape or not. And he remember
we had both liveness and readiness probe.
So both of them we're going to be using here.
So start with the liveness probe, and to declare
it where you can use his liveness probe. And
then the kind of probe that there's a few
kinds of probe as well, what I'm going to
be using here is the HTTP HTTP GET type of
probe, which is just going to call some HTTP
path with the get verb into the API.
And so the path that it needs to use is, if
you remember, that would be held live. And
it needs to use Port 80 for that one. And
that's it, that will be the biggest probe.
And I'll just copy this to define our readiness
probe. readiness probe is going to be very
similar, but it ends in red. So if you remember,
we would use the liveness probe to tell if
our recipient is up and running, and the readiness
probe to tell if any dependencies of the REST
API are responding correctly are ready and
basically, REST API is ready to serve requests.
So with that we have properly declared a deployment
for our REST API. But it is not enough. So
this will go ahead and create the bots pull
this pulls the containers, and environment
variables and all that. But still, there's
no way to reach for anybody to reach into
this container from the outside. And to enable
that, we need to bring in another component
that's called service. So that service, we
could either create in another java file,
or we can use security right here, which is
what I'm going to do. And the way that you
separate these two different resources in
the Java file is by using three dashes. And
then you can go ahead and start declaring
your resource. So I'll do some IntelliSense.
Again here, so I'll just type service. And
that brings up the query service IntelliSense.
Here, so I'll click on it. And that will scaffold
a little bit of pieces in there that we can
take advantage of. So the service is the is
the type of resource that you use to be able
to address resource within Kubernetes, either
internally or externally, which is what we
need at this point, the service we need to
give, we also need to give it a name, just
like we did with deployment. So we'll name
it the catalog service. And then one piece
that's not listed here that, but that is important
for us is the type, there's a few types of
services. But in our case, we want to use
a tight named load balancer. Load Balancer
is the one that allows queries to request
natural IP, or a natural or not, I guess,
not an IP, in this case, because it's localhost.
But it requests a way for two to open kind
of a window to the to the outside, so that
people can actually reach out to our REST
API from the outside. So we'll see how that
that name resolves when we run this, but you
know, various responsibilities. Otherwise,
we cannot reach the service from the outside.
For selector, we have to specify the port.
Well, the label for the the ports that we
have declared before, if you remember these
ports, here, we declared the template, we
said that the labels for all the ports that
are going to be managed by the deployment
is going to be Catholic. So that same label
is the one that we have to use, what we declare
the service, or the color selector with, we're
going to say, well, we're going to this service
is going to be able to target any of the ports
that have the app label with the value catalog.
So that's how you connect the service with
the bots. And then you also have to specify,
okay, so which is going to be the port, that
that from the outside, people can reach into
our API from the outside, and that has to
be mapped into a port in the in the container.
So that port in this case is going to be we're
going to be using your ad just because it's
the default port for HTTP. So that will allow
our clients to not even have this Wi Fi port,
it will just be able to use call directly
into the API. So they will go into port 80.
And the target port has to be the port that
we have specified for the container to remember,
over here, imports, we declare container port
80. So container port 80 is the target pool
that we want to use here. So it's really mapping
80, to 80. But it doesn't have to be like
that, we could, we could have said, let's
say 8080 maps to 80, that will be totally
fine, just like we did with the container.
But it is more usual to use a port 80. So
now we should be ready to start deploying
these well, to deploy these bodies resources,
both deployment and the service. So how do
you deploy this into Kubernetes. So we have
to go back to our cube control tool to be
able to do that. So I'll open up my terminal
again, Ctrl J. And I'll switch to my release
directory. The command to apply this deployment
is called this this java file is
cube control, apply dash F, and then the name
of the file, hit Enter. And you should get
a couple of messages stating that they got
up the deployment has been created, and the
service has been created. Now you want to
see a which is a deployment or what's the
state of a deployment that should be created.
What you can do is to say cube control, get
deployments and that will give you a list
of all the created deployments this case is
saying we have a one deployment named Gatling
deployment and currently it is saying that
zero of one of the bots is it is ready to
go. So it means that it is not really ready
yet. So, let's dive in a little bit more and
get details about the actual bots got created.
So what we can do is say, cube CTL get bought.
And so as you can see all the with one pod
that we have declared here, the name is starts
with enable deployment. And then it gets a
name for what we call the replica set, which
we've not, we will not talk about in this
video. And then finally, some identify for
the actual pod. And then indeed, the port
is not ready. So this is saying zero of one
ports are ready to be used, right to be reached
by the outside. But still, he says running.
So this means what this really means is that
our our liveness probe, that you remember,
we have a liveness probe is is reporting a
healthy status, but our readiness board is
not reporting healthy status. So to find out
a little bit more of what's going on here,
and I'll expand this a little bit more. Let's
actually get some logs from that catalog board.
So to see cube control logs. And then the
name of the bot hit Enter. And then we're
seeing something interesting here. Let's let
me scroll up a little bit. Yes. So here, as
you can see, the our MongoDB readiness check
is failing with status on healthy dubray him
was cancelled. And as you can expect this
is well, this is not expected because we have
not really deployed any database yet. But
this is great. This This confirms that our
readiness health check, both have checks are
actually working properly. And we just need
to make sure that we fix this problem with
the database, we bring it up. And then we
should be able to have an REST API up and
running. Let's close the terminal. And let's
actually declare what we need to declare for
our database. So I'll go back to migrate this
directory. And I'll say new file. And this
file is going to be called Mongo DB. Because
everything we're going to declare here is
just for the deployment of that MongoDB database.
Now, the type of resource that we're going
to create for MongoDB is actually called a
stateful set. And see if we don't have a way
to generate the skeleton for a stateful set.
And yet, we're going to use the deployment
template for this. So let's use to deployment
select Windows deployment. And then what I'm
going to do is just switch from deployment
to stateful set. So let's say Phil said he
has similarities with the deployment. But
it is actually meant for stateful applications.
So a stateful set provides guarantees about
the ordering and uniqueness, uniqueness of
pots. So when you see the pots that are created
by a stateful set, they will not have random,
random names, they will likely have some very
specific order names. So for instance, in
the case of this one, it may be called MongoDB,
one MongoDB, two MongoDB, three. And more
than that, if one of these ports dies, let's
say MongoDB, one dies. And when it comes back,
he will come back as MongoDB one once again.
And this is very important in the case of
MongoDB. Because we will attach a persistent
volume to it, which will have the database
data files. And we want to make sure that
those files don't just get lost as as the
port is reconstructed in the case that it
needs to be given for any reason, right? So
we want to keep it around. So the right type
of resource to use for for a persistent service,
like MongoDB would be a stateful set. So just
like we did with deployment, one of the first
things to do here is to assign a name to a
stateful set. In this case, we will name it
MongoDB stable set. And then one important
thing that's not being generated here is what
we call the service name.
And the service name is used to give a some
identity both to the stateful set and to the
bots there are going to be a managed by it,
which is not actually needed for deployments.
But for a stateful set. It's it's a requirement.
The name that we're going to give here is
MongoDB. service. We see how the service is
died later on to the MongoDB service and back
to the catalog later on. Then also just like
we did with deployment, we need to define
which are the labels that the status is going
to be using at to select the ports that is
going to be managing. So in this case, let's
say that our bots are going to have the Mongo
DB later the MongoDB value in its app label.
And we're going to do that Then we have to
make sure that in the pod template down here
in labels app, we have to be using the same
value. So all our parts are going to have
an app label with a value of MongoDB. And
then the stateful set is being configured
to manage all those pods with the MongoDB
value in the app label. Now we keep going
down into the container section inside the
spec. And then let's just give the name of
the container listen this name it again MongoDB.
And then for the image will be we'll use the
same image that we've been using so far, is
just Mongo, latest version of Mongo, then
we keep going down into the resources section.
And we will leave these resources, they should
work just fine for us. But it's up to you
to modify how much memory and CPU you expect
to be using for your MongoDB server and the
MongoDB database. Moving on, we have to declare
the the port where the MongoDB container is
listening on. And by now we know that this
port is 27, zero 17. Right. So that's the
port that we have to use to, to connect to
that MongoDB service inside the container.
And once again, like we did with, with gadelha
yamo, we have to define a couple of environment
variables to be able to talk to that well
to be able to start up our MongoDB container.
And those are the username and the password
for the for the user configured for for MongoDB.
So let's declare and sorry, let's see clear
and M section. And here, let's start declaring.
So the name of this environment variable is
Mongo in it, db. root user name. and the value
that we're going to assign to it is the one
that we're using. So far more go admin. And
then for the for the password, we're going
to be using really the same secret that we're
using gatok. So I'm switching to catalog here.
And I'll just copy our password section into
MongoDB. base here and fix it a datian. And
then as you see we're reading from the same
location, but the name of the environment
variable is just a little bit different, is
going to be Mongo in it, db. root, password,
right, so that's a, that's a username and
password environment variables that the MongoDB
container is expecting. The next thing that
we need to define in the case of the MongoDB
container, is what we call the persistent
volume, right. So we need to declare some
storage way too, ask coordinators for some
storage space to place the data files for
our database. Otherwise, I mean, yes, a database
will exist within the MongoDB container. But
when the container and the port, the containers
container is killed for any reason, the data
will just disappear, right? So we don't want
that to happen. So to do that, we create what
we call a persistent volume, and greatest
persistent volume, we're going to use what
we call as a volume claim template. So let's
do that. And they make sure I pick the right
place for this. I should be here. So let's
say volume claim templates. And really the
balloon claim templates is a way to declare
or to ask Kubernetes for some space, some
storage space in the node, where the where
the pod is going to be executed, right, so
I need some space. And we have to declare
a some details about that space that we're
going to reclaim. So first, we're going to
set up some metadata. And we pretty much just
need the name here. So what's the name that
we're going to give to these to this volume,
that's going to be data.
And then we have to specify the spec specifications
for the volume that we're going to ask for.
So that goes into the spec section. And then
here, we have to specify an access mode access
mode. So access mode declares, which way is
this persistent volume going to be going to
be mounted into the note, and actually, this
should go into a previous line to do it like
this. And, for our case, the mode of READ
WRITE, once, once it should be good enough,
and really this one here, it means that the
volume that's going to be created that's going
to be mounted is going to be mounted as read
write, and for a single note, so meaning that
just one note can read and write to these
volume at a time. If you wanted to. You wanted
to have more than one node we able to write
to this volume, you will have to use a different
kind of access mode. And then finally, we
have to define the resources that we need
here. So in this case, we'll declare resources
and Then requests. And finally, storage. And
here's where we declare how much space we
want for this volume. And for our case, let's
go for one, I think the term will be gigabyte,
similar to one gigabyte, that's going to be
as much as storage, we're going to reclaim
for this volume, say this. So with this, we
have reclaimed space in the note, right? For
this form for MongoDB. However, we still need
to tell our container that such a space exists.
And we have to map that space in the in the
host machine to space into the container.
And to do that, we're going to declare a volume
mount, the balloon mount needs to be declared
inside the container spec. And so I'll just
type here, balloon mounts. And here, we're
going to specify a name for it. And this name
will have to match exactly the name that we
have specified for the in the balloon claim
template, right. So we said it's going to
be data. So data is the name that we should
use here. And then the mount pad is the part
where traditionally MongoDB is stored its
data files right inside the container. So
that that space is going to be slash data
slash dB. So what this really means is that
when MongoDB MongoDB container writes into
its data DB directory for the data files for
the database, those files are going to end
up into de a persistent volume that has been
declared on the site here, right, so the data
gets read in outside of the container and
into the persistent storage in somewhere in
the host. So this way, if the container goes
down is the port goes down for any reason,
the data is not is not lost, and they will
come back as the port comes about with the
same identity in the stateful set. The next
thing that we need to do, just like we did
with the catalog yamo is declare a service
write a service that allows us to address
or to get to the MongoDB service. And so I'll
just please, and then I'll type service for
cleaning service, so generates just like we
did before. And just like before, we have
to specify some name for the service, let's
call it MongoDB. service. And then one important
missing piece here is this thing called the
cluster IP. So cluster IP is what you would
use to specify the IP address for your service,
right. And so by default, any service will
get local IP that that can be used to talk
to other services within the cluster. But
in our case, we want to create what we call
a headless service. So we don't want to assign
an IP to the service. Because
in a stateful set, we want to address each
of the nodes for each of the pots individually.
So in this case, we're going to say none,
so we don't want an IP in this case. So it
turns it into a headless service. Now for
the selector, once again, we have to specify
how is this service going to be mapped into
the ports that exist for for MongoDB. Right,
so for that, we have to go back, once again
into the bottom plate, the bottom plate metadata
labels app, the label that we're looking for
is AP, and the value is MongoDB. So we go
back, copy that into this lector MongoDB.
So anytime a request comes into this service,
it will find the nodes that sorry, the ports
that have been tagged with the MongoDB a value
in the app label. And then that's what, that's
how it's going to find them. Finally, we need
to specify the ports. And so just like we
did with the container, we're just going to
do a simple mapping of 27 zero 17. So any
request that comes into 27, zero 17 should
go should be redirected to the port where
the container is listening on. And that that
port is again, as you can see here, 27 zero
17. I'll just copy that over here. Now that
we have done this, it should be ready to to
get to get started with this MongoDB container.
So I'm going to open up my my terminal again,
Ctrl J opens terminal. I'll scroll down this
a little bit. And then I'm going to switch
to the Kubernetes directory. And here I'll
just do cube control, apply dash F and then
our demo file MongoDB demo, and I'll hit enter.
So both the stateful set and this service
have been graded. And so at this point, let's
see, how does the stateful set look like right,
so let's do cube control. Get Data Sets. And
they'll give us the one stateful set that
has been created MongoDB stateful set, which
seems to be ready, it's healthy, it's in good
state, and it's ready to be used. Now that
we did that, let's take a look at all the
ports that we have right now. So once again,
cube control get hot. And as you can see,
now we have our catalog board, it is actually
ready. So it's no longer reporting 01 is reporting
one out of one. And that is because the ad
because the the ready the readiness probe
that was trying to reach into the, into our
MongoDB database, it is now able to actually
do it. And that's because we now do have the
MongoDB service available. If you remember,
when we were in catalog, Jamel, we declared
that the MongoDB settings horse was going
to be MongoDB service, it was not available
yet. But now that we have declared it and
we have deployed it, we do have the MongoDB
service that I can reach out to. And then
that allows our health check to pass so we
can connect to the database successfully.
I just like we have that board, we also have
the port, the MongoDB stateful, set zero.
So as you can see, it is not a random random
ID as a as in the case of deployment is more
of a very specific numbered and ordered index
for these stateful sets. Right. So if it dies,
it needs to come back with that same number.
Let's now see if our REST API is working properly.
Now that is running within coordinators. So
let's open up postman. And last time that
we did a get against our REST API, we did
it over Port 8080. So because that's the port
that we exposed when run it is as part of
Docker. But now we have switched to Port 80.
And we can either query the API like this,
or we can just remove ad because it's a default
HTTP port. So this should be good enough to
do a get against the API. So let's see what
we get. And sure enough, we don't get any
results. Because remember, this is a brand
new database that's now hosted inside Kubernetes.
So this effectively don't have any data. But
we can go ahead and create something in there.
And so I'm switching to the post up here.
And I'm going to also change these to just
be HTTP localhost items. And then for body,
let's come up with something quickly. Let's
say we're going to create a potion again,
price 12. And then hit send. And sure enough,
the potion has been created, we can create
a just one more thing, let's say an antidote.
With Price, let's say 17, hit send, and has
been graded to go back to the get it sent.
We are getting our two items now. So the REST
API is working properly. But everything is
now running within grenades. And so we talked
about this capability of grenades to self
heal, right. So it should be able to always
enforce that desired state, regardless of
what happens to the bots. So let's see how
how that exactly works. So I'm back in VS
code now. And what I'm going to do is just
to get a little bit more space here to be
able to visualize things better. So I'm going
to move this left side all the way to the
left. And then what I'll do is spin up another
terminal with the split terminal burden. So
that now we can have two terminals side by
side. And I'll move things around a little
bit like this, perhaps right there. And so
what I'll do is on the left side, I'm going
to be watching for the bots with cube control,
get pods, dash W. So that lets me see any
changes that happen across the the current
existing bots in there. And on the right side,
I'm going to simulate the killing of one of
these bots. So let's say that I mean, let's
imagine that the board had some bug, and that
causes the bot to crash. Right that then what
happens. So let's do cube control, delete
board. And so let's try our catalog board
or only catalog board. And I'll go ahead and
delete it. So I'll hit Enter, and see on the
left side, how right away. As soon as it starts
terminating that port, it immediately starts
spinning up a brand new container, right.
So that's the capability of coordinators to
always detect this discrepancy between the
desired state and the actual state. And as
soon as you detect the situation, it needs
to do whatever it needs to be done to bring
back things to consistency, right. So in this
case, the Newport is up and running, and then
I'll just do Ctrl C. And I'll do get pods
again without the W and you can see that now.
We have, again, our two bots. But now we have
a catalog but with a different identity, right?
You can see it's not the same identity as
before. And that's because deployment type
deployments, great bots are ephemeral, ephemeral
in nature, right? So they are just stateless.
Now, that's not the same case. As for our
stateful sets, as we said, Our stateful sets
should be persisting across the lifetime of
a pod, right? So if we just have these MongoDB
stateful, sets zero here, what happens if
we deleted right? More than that what happens
with the data that is being held by this MongoDB
bot, because we already have data in there.
So would it survive for the data to still
be there, with the port come back, so let's
try it out. So I'll do a wash again for the
bots. And I'll copy the name of our stateful
set. And so I'll do cube CTL, cube control,
delete bot, and I'll do MongoDB stateful.
Set, let's see what happens. And see on the
left side, the pod is indeed getting terminated.
But right away, Grenada is detects that it
needs to bring it back. And it needs to bring
it back with the same identity MongoDB safe
was at zero, because this is a stateful set,
right. And we don't want to lose the data
that's being held by the sport. And in fact,
if I just control CDs, and guys, I'll do get
pods, we have our two pods. And now we should
be able to verify that the data is not gone.
So it should still be there. So if I go back
to postman, and I query for the data, once
again, we can see that the data is still there.
So it has not gone anywhere. So so that means
that indeed, our persistent volume got created,
and the data is being stored outside of the
container and into the host. And that's enabled
by our stateful set. So I'll go back to VS
code now. And we also talked about this a
capability of grenades to easily scale the
ports and the containers inside them, without
really much, much stronger, right. So if we
are somewhere our network we need, we have
much more requests in our website, we do have
not just one port for catalog, but we need
to have three, well, what would we do? And
how can Kubernetes help us with that. So once
again, let's monitor what's happening on the
left side, get pods. And then what I'm going
to do here is just ask Kubernetes to scale
the deployment for discovery deployment, where
you can do is
cube control, scale, deployments, and then
it will be catalog deployment. And then you
have to say how much right right now we have
one. Now we want to have three. So hit enter.
I noticed on the left side that immediately
starts provisioning a bunch of new bots to
enforce this new decided state, right, and
this happens blazing fast, right. So if I
just do Ctrl C, now on the left side and get
bots, again, you can see that we already have
three bots, and we only had one just seconds
ago. So here you can tell, like the power
of the combination of Docker containers, and
Kubernetes, right, how we can bring in a much
more instances of our containers of our of
our REST API. In this case, without really
much trouble just running one line, we now
have three copies of the container running.
And now, the whole point of having these data
replicas of the pots is so that we can do
some good load balancing between them, right.
So when a request comes, it should land in
one or another of these bots. And how can
we verify that? Well, unfortunately, we don't
have good means to do that right now. But
I think we can easily introduce a little bit
of logging into the bots so that we can easily
tell which bot the request, the request is
landing. And so to do that, what I'm going
to do first is just I'll just close the terminals
for now. And then I'll go to our Explorer,
or go to our items controller. And here, I'm
just going to add a little bit of logging.
To add logging where we can do is bring in
the standard a logger interface. So I'll do
only a logger for items controller. Let's
call it logger. So I logger is, is a standard
object available in dotnet five, so pretty
much in any application dotnet five. And so
what you can do here, you just do dependency
injection, as you do with any other service
built in service of dotnet five. And I'll
come up to the logger instance right here.
Now that we have that, what we can do is just
pick one of our API's and do some logging.
So I'll go for the easiest one, which is going
to be our Get diverse API. So in this case,
I'll just open up here, one line. And I'm
just going to log a little message that says
how many items we found, right. So to do that,
what I'll do is just logger dot log information.
And then let's do a little bit of string interpolation
here. First year I'm going to put here is
the current current time. And I'll do that
via the date time class, I'll choose the UTC
time to string and then we'll show adjust
the time in the format of hours, minutes and
seconds. Okay, so type format there. And then
I'll just do corner just say retrieved. Items
that count items. Okay, so just for us to
verify that things are landing in different
parts. So I'll save these. And then they will
not change. What we have to do now is to create
a new version of our Docker image. So I'll
open up our terminal now. And I'll delete
one of these, so that we only have one. And
here I'll do what we did in the last video.
So I'll just run our Docker build command.
And I'll be publishing this into Docker Hub.
So I'll be I'll keep using the same format
as before, using the username first, and then
the name of the image. And then the one thing
that I'm going to pop here is the deck because
this is a new a new version of the image.
So we should be bumping it, let's say to be
two, this is necessary, so that coronaries
can later tell that this is a new image, or
that it needs to pull it down from Docker
Hub, otherwise, he will not be able to do
so then I'll say dot O, hit Enter. And then
I'll just miss I'll just miss one parameter
here, which is the dash D for the tag, you
enter again, this is going to build the image,
it's going to reuse some of the cache layers
and then it's going to be just a piece that
is needed. Okay, so the image is built. Now
I'm going to do me to login into Docker Hub
Docker login.
And now I should be able to just push the
image shorter. So I'll do Docker push, would
you see catalog, B to enter. And then again,
some of the layers are going to already exist
in Docker Hub. So only the layer that's missing,
which is my little change of one line change
here is the one that is included in this image
and this one that needs to be pushed into
Docker Hub. Okay, so with the image in Docker
Hub, we should be able to tell Kubernetes
that we want to start using it. So for that,
I'll go back to catalog Jamel and I'll say
hey, cornice, I don't want to keep using a
demonstration one, I want to use version two.
Save that. And then back in the terminal,
I'll switch to our coordinates folder. And
here, I'll just apply this file was once again.
So cube control, apply dash F, and then we'll
do capital gamma. Okay, and so life is if
we do cube control, get pods, watch, see what's
happening. So as you can see, the old the
old container dope bots are getting destroyed.
And new bots are getting immediately installed
stand up for the new image, the new misperception
that we need to be using. So this should take
us a few seconds. And so I'll Ctrl C now.
And I'll see the actual status of the pods.
Let's see what we got. So yeah, so we have
three new copies of our a catalog REST API,
the replicas of the pod. And so now we should
be able to tell if we're load balancing across
them. So to do that we're going to do is again,
I'll just make some more space here. I'll
expand this terminal has even more. And I'll
split the terminal now in three. So that we
can add Delta locks of the of the three pots.
So first here, now go back one directory.
And as they could control get pots, so we
get the names of all the pots, and then I'll
do one by one. I'm going to do cube control
logs for these one and then I'll do dash f
so that we can tell the logs and then I'll
do the same Here, which is our second part,
let's take a look is going to be this one
here, dash F. And then the third one is these
guy here for our third terminal to control
logs, dash F. Okay, so now we're tailing the
three parts. And I'm going to go back to postman
and perhaps we can accommodate this into here
just on top of the other one to see what's
going on. Yep. And, yeah, so one more thing,
actually that we have to change is postman
is our heater. So let me maximize this for
a moment. Because the default behavior of
postman is that it's going to send this a
connection heater with a value of pickle keepalive.
And what that's going to do is actually set
up a persistent TCP connection between postman
and our bot. And that will actually prevent
our little exercise from allowing different
subsequent connections to go into different
bots. So just for testing purposes, and to
see how things work, I'm going to disable
that, that heater here and see how these things
work. And, yeah, so with that, minimize these
in this way. And let's send one request and
see where it lands. You see, it landed in
the first part on the left side, between two
items at 704 52. Let's send again. And now
we landed in in our second part, let's send
the game loops. Again, in the second part,
and then at this point is going to be a little
bit random. I mean, the algorithm that's supposed
to be using is round robin. But really, things
can land in any pot. That is point. So there
you go, load balancing in Kubernetes, fairly
straightforward, without you having to do
really much work on it. And if you scaled
into 1000s of bots, then all of them will
be serving your requests appropriately. In
this episode of The dotnet five REST API tutorial,
we talked about unit testing, test driven
development, and how to implement them to
raise the quality of our REST API.
Today, you will learn what is unit testing
and why it is so important. What is test driven
development, also known as DDD, and why you
may want to consider it in your project, how
to retest REST API controller via the x unit
testing framework, how to mock dependencies
via the mock framework, how to write better
assertions via the fluent assertions library,
and how to implement TDD in practice. So what
is unit testing? This is a topic that I'm
very passionate about. And to understand it,
let me introduce a quick analogy. Imagine
that you're a member of the team in charge
of testing the SpaceX rocket for the first
time, the engineers have used dozens, maybe
hundreds of different parts and systems, some
not even produced by SpaceX. To assemble this
awesome vehicle. Everybody put their top game
to build a rocket. And now we would like to
see if everything worked as expected. launch
day is here. And then yeah, that didn't go
as expected, there has to be you can't just
assemble a bunch of parts and test them all
together the very first time the rocket is
launched. Fortunately, this is not how they
usually test a rocket before launching. Without
getting too technical about rockets, because
I'm definitely not an expert in the area.
I just wanted to show here a simplified diagram
of the parts of a rocket that I got from the
NASA website. All of the different components
and systems like the payload system, or the
oxidizer are also individual units of this
entire vehicle that all need to operate properly
before the rocket can lift off from it. And
the engineers don't just build this unit and
send them to the assembly team to put them
on a rocket and after everything is put together,
figure out if all the parts work or not. Each
part of the rocket is tested in isolation,
likely several times, where before being sent
to the final assembly into rocket. This gives
certainty to the teams behind each part that
as long as it is used according to specifications,
that unit will work as expected. And the same
goes for the team assembling the entire thing.
They know that they can connect all the parts
according to specification, and the rocket
should lie. This saves time and money for
everyone. Unlikely saves a few lives along
the way. So in terms of software engineering,
we can define the testing as a way to test
every piece of code in isolation without external
dependencies. Now coming back to our catalog,
REST API. Even with a simpler screen at this
point, we do have a few components that talk
to each other, like the itis controller, or
I didn't have auditory class, the Mongo client
instance. And finally, the MongoDB database.
Each of these components are made of a bunch
of methods that represent the behavior that
we can get out of them. For instance, the
ages controller has has functions like get
item, grade item, update item, delete item,
and we will certainly keep adding more in
the future. These are the different granular
units that must individually work correctly,
to ensure that the whole service provides
the expected functionality. Therefore, for
each of them, really to write a series of
unit tests that really exercise every aspect
and every corner or each of these methods
to give us enough confidence on their quality
way before trying out the whole service from
postman or from any other client. Beyond this,
unit testing has a bunch of benefits that
you definitely don't want to miss. With a
unit test, you can quickly verify your code
without having to worry about dependencies.
For instance, you can make sure that your
class can retrieve items from the database
without having to stand up or talk to a database
server at all. And such a test can give you
results in milliseconds as opposed to seconds
or minutes, you can make changes without worrying
about introducing regressions. After you have
a unit test in place. You can refactor your
code as much as needed without concerns of
breaking the service. Because you know that
the unit test will provide you with that safety
net unit this will catch box at the point
where it is easier and cheaper to fix them.
Which is before merging your code to the code
base on way before getting a deploy to production.
fixing something that is already impacting
impacting customers in prod can have an enormous
cost, both in human hours and of course in
the amount of money lost by anybody that use
it or service. And unit test. If don't Well,
can be the best augmentation of your REST
API, since every use case should eventually
turn into a unit test. And those tests can't
lie. They must represent the way that the
system works. Now that we know what unit tests
are, let's also talk about test driven development
or TDD. So what is TDD? Simply put, TDD is
a software development approach, where you
write a test before you write just enough
production code to make the failing test pass.
This translates into a cycle made of three
phases, a red phase where you write a test
that represents your software requirement.
This test fails because you have not implemented
any production code yet. In fact, the test
doesn't even compile at this point. A green
phase where you write just enough production
code to make the test pass. You don't need
to implement anything beyond what's needed
to pass a test. And inelegant or only code
is allowed at this point. Finally, if needed,
you refactor the code you just wrote while
you keep running the test to make sure that
they stay green. It is at this point where
you eventually arrive to code optimize it
for readability and maintainability. You keep
repeating this cycle for any new piece of
functionality. This is a basic cycle of DDD.
Why would you want to embrace DDD? Well, there
are a lot of benefits of embracing this practice.
But there are three aspects or like most we
did it, you start by focusing on the requirement,
not on the implementation. This gives you
a lot of freedom in terms of trying to properly
address the requirements, because you're not
constrained by an already implemented piece
of code. When you implement the code, first,
you end up writing tests that verify only
as much of the implemented code as you have
time or patience for because you already invested
a lot of time and effort in that code. You
can increase it this coverage, because by
definition, you would have not written any
more production code other than needed to
pass a test. Again, when you don't do things
the DDD way, you might end up with multiple
corner cases that might feel that you might
forget or might not have time to test properly
reducing the test coverage. Finally, clean
design is enforced from the start. As you
write a test, you will naturally start designing
the pieces of production code in such a way
that leads to a passing test. The classes
and methods emerge from the test, and you'll
naturally avoid the pitfalls of writing code
to Cobbold to be tested. There are three main
unit testing framework in the dotnet ecosystem
these days, and unit, Ms test, and x unit.
They all fulfill the same purpose of allowing
you to write and run your unit tests in an
automated way. However, for any new project,
I strongly recommend you choose x unit. This
framework comes from one of the original authors
of the popular end unit framework. But it
was really meant to be more closely in line
with the dotnet platform and to help write
clearer tests. It is also more intuitive than
ms test which requires more attributes in
test classes. Some of them not straightforward
to use properly, especially for developers
new to the platform. Let's see now how to
implement unit testing and TDD in practice.
It's time to add a new test project for our
unit tests. But before we can do that, I think
we should restructure things a bit to give
our REST API a more specific directory that
will live side by side next to our upcoming
test project. So I'll start by going to our
explorer view on the left side, and I'll just
look for an empty section over here. And right
click, and I'll say New Folder, the new folder
is going to be catalog that API. And now let's
move most of the directories and files over
there except for the VS code being catalog,
API, and OBJ. So let's grab everything else
into catalog API move. And now that has all
the files for the catalog REST API. Now, let's
close this. And then let's delete this directory,
we don't need this bin directory or this OBJ
directory, those are gone. Now just to match
the folder name, let's rename the project
name into catalog that API. And then we'll
have to make a bunch of renames in a bunch
of files, just to match this new project,
right file name. So I'll copy this name here,
close this, and then I'll go to search and
replace. And we're going to replace catalog.
That's us broke into catalog that API CS broke.
So let's just replace all, they will do the
same thing with the DLL. So gotta look that
DLL, siapa DLL, it's gonna be renamed into
candidate API, that DLL is replaced these
all the files. Now let's look at the namespace.
So today, we have this namespace catalog.
And that should turn into base base catalog
that API. And then for every everywhere classes
that are using that namespace, let's make
sure they use the new namespace. So using
catalog should turn into using catalog that
API to that replacement. Now let's look at
our
to VS code. That's a JSON file, where we have
these a workplace folder slash catalog API
stand to change that, to replace these with
slash gallery, that API slash how to using
this file placeholder, all the entries. It's
all done. And now let's go to lunch that Jason
and do a very similar replacement, so workplace
folder into catalog that API, or three folders
slash catalog API, replace all this file.
And I think that's what we have to do. So
I'll just close these two. And then I'll do
a Ctrl, Shift B to make sure everything is
building properly. Yeah, looks like it is,
or close these around this one here, you'll
see that nougat packages are restored, but
everything looks fine,
or close terminal.
Now among the things that we modified, and
they'll collapse, this one is the Docker file.
So the Docker file is now pointing to a catalog
API that says broke. So I'll just, I just
want to make sure that this is still building
properly. So I'll rebuild our Docker image
now. So open my terminal. Let's open a brand
new partial terminal. And given this new directory
structure, I'll have to go into catalog API.
And here I can run my Docker build command
again. So just to Docker build, dash D. And
there's going to be Will you see slash catalog,
B three. And so B three, because we were creating
a new version of this Docker image, which
was B two last time, hit enter. Okay, so the
new image is created, I'll do Docker images.
So it is right there, the image was created.
So everything looks just fine. So this is
great. I'll close terminal and close this
file. So now we can actually create our display.
So I will collect this for a moment. So we
want to create a new display you could use
at the same level. So go back to terminal,
actually, and we're going to go up one directory.
And to create this project, you do it very
similarly to how you do for the creation of
the web API. So you choose to just use a dotnet
CLA. So dotnet new, and like I said before,
they preferred this framework for this project
is x unit. So I will go for x unit. Now let's
name this project. catalog that unit tests
hit Enter. And our unit display has been great,
because this one over here it has a project
file and an initial class, display class.
Are there. Now one interesting thing that
we have now here is that we need to build
a not one, but two projects, right? And so
anytime we want to make sure that everything
is really properly, however, our physical
environment has not been configured for that
yet. So if you look at the JSON alkalosis,
it is configured to be only the catalog API
CS Pro. So how can we make it so that anytime
we build it builds both projects. So there's
a handy way to do this, that I'll show you.
And what I'll do is I'll create a new file
at the root here, just add a route that's
going to be named, we'll call it yours, we'll
get proud. Okay, and then I'll collapse this
for a moment. And this file is going to allow
us to build all the projects in one shot.
So how do you how do you do? So let's declare
the following. So you will do Raju SDK. And
here we're going to be using the build trails
traversal SDK. So to do that, you just type
here, Microsoft dot build that traversal.
And this was the file operation. So because
he's actually going to pull a nougat package
down into your machine. The last version that
I found last time was 303. So I'll do that.
Okay, let's go ahead and also, close this.
And inside this section, you have to define
an item group. So I can group, close that
group. And here, you have to reference all
the project files that you want to compile.
So for that, you want to type like reference,
include equals, and then we'll just do this,
this expression. So everything, so star, that
star, so any files that end in Brock, are
going to be compiled by this file. Okay, so
with this file, ready, let's go back to Explorer.
let's actually go ahead and into task Jason.
And let's ask it to no longer just build catalog
API CS, but instead is going to build
build that block. All right. So with that
done, I'll do Ctrl Shift v.
Yep. And now it's close to East. Let's close
that. You can see that boat. Let me just do
this for a moment. catalog that API DLL and
Catherine, etc, they'll have been built by
these one comment. So notice that you don't
need a Visual Studio solution for these at
all. This is this is my preferred way of building
like all the products in solution in a solution.
So build Prague use include all the break
files, and that will do the trick. Right,
so close these two now. And then our test
break here, we'll need Of course, a reference
to our API, because we're going to be testing
the API controller. So let's make sure we
have that reference. So open terminal again,
I'll switch to my PowerShell terminal. And
then let's see, I'll go into catalog that
API service catalog does unit tests. And then
I'll do dotnet, add reference. And then we're
going to go into catalog that API. catalog
API. That's Yes, bro. Right. So that adds
the reference, we look at unit tests, close
these, it will have that reference right here.
Okay, so now the break the test probably can't
use any of the files, or reference any of
the files in their API project was that and
then we're going to need a couple of additional
nougat packages in this test project. Let's
actually open these again. And these are going
to be a first we're going to need the nougat
package for a extension plugin abstraction.
So let's do that. dotnet add Bakhash Microsoft
extensions that logging abstractions. And
this is because we are going to be using or
trying to test our controller class, which,
if you look at it quickly, the controller
class does receive a logger in constructor
over here. So we're going to be needing to
use these a logger class. And for that, we
need that to get package that we just added.
The other package is the net package is called
Mach. Mo Q. And this is this little framework
that can help you actually mock your your
classes, the classes you're using in your
controller. So So that you can a test only
the pieces that you care about in controller,
but you don't have to worry about how to create
or how or how the dependent or external dependencies
of that class a work. And we're going to go
into those details in a moment. But yeah,
those are the two nougat package that we need
for now. So I'll close terminal again. And
then let's start focusing on our desk class,
this case, you need this one. Let's rename
this class into a more appropriate name. So
rename these into items, controller tests,
right, so the convention that we're following
here is that if the controller is named itis
controller, that's a class name, we're going
to be using the class name with the suffix
of tests for this class is controller tests.
That's the one that we have here. And that's
the one that we're going to use for the, for
the class over here, titled The third test.
I'm going to collapse this Navigation Pane
now I'll do a Ctrl, Shift V, make sure everything
is building properly. And then, if you happen
to be getting any of these red squiggles here,
we should not be there. But if it happens,
let me just close these, what you can do is
use to Ctrl Shift P, and do only sharp is
dark, only sharp, or you can type that there
on the sharp, we start on the sharp, and that
should take care of that. Now notice this
fact attribute that was added to our audio
narrated this one method here. So fact is
the attribute that you have to use to declare
that one of the methods in this class is actually
this method. So that's the only way for the
test runner to recognize that it has to execute
these tests. So use Don't forget to add fact
to each of your test methods. There are other
ways to declare or to decorate your metals
assessments. But for this tutorial, we'll
stick with fact. Now let's go ahead and start
writing our first unit test. But before that,
let's look again, other items controller class.
And let's see what should be unit tested.
We will write unit test for all of our, all
of our methods are here. But let's start with
get it basic, just because there's a couple
of simple and nice cases that we can go across
these these methods.
In fact, after receiving an ad, as you remember,
we will reboot and we will try to find the
item in the repository. And if we can, if
we cannot find it, if it is no, we will return
not found. Otherwise, we will go ahead and
convert the item into a detail. So let's write
a couple of unit tests for to verify this
method. So going back to our test class, one
thing that I'd like to encourage you is to
use is to use a good naming convention for
the unit test. This is very important because
it helps it really helps to identify what
is this they're supposed to do what what is
it really verifying, without having to go
into the all the details about the unit test?
So one one good naming convention that I like
is the following. You want to use three parts
here, that's going to be unit of work. State
under test, and expected behavior. Right.
So first part you into the work. So what is
that you're testing? What is the function
that is going to be tested by this unit test?
That's unit work, then state under test. So
under which conditions? Are you testing these
these test methods, right? And then finally,
the expected behavior. And so what do we expect
from this from this unit, as we execute these
tests after we execute the action part of
these tests. So now translating that into
our guided async method, let me just copy
the name here. The unit of work is in fact,
the name of this method. So gate item async.
And the first case that I'm going to test
is what happens when we cannot find the item.
So the item, the item is full, right this
section here. So in that for that case, I'm
going to say with an existing item, so the
item does not exist, what will be the expected
behavior, then it's returned returns not found.
Okay, so that should be a good name for arguing
this refers to a test. Now, within the body
of the reading test, there's also some other
another good convention that encourages to
encourage us to write the test in this way.
So there's going to be three sections here.
The first one is called a range. Second one
is called tact. And the last one is called
cert. These also a be named as AAA. Arrange,
act assert. And the idea is that you're going
to first have an array section where you're
going to be much set up everything to be ready
to execute the test. So just before securing
the test, so this includes any sorts of marks.
levels and inputs that you're going to need
to be able to figure into this. Then we go
to the x section where we actually execute
the test, we perform the one action that we
are testing here. And finally, the assert
section where we verify whatever needs to
be verified about the execution of of the
of the action of the unit. Okay, so how does
that translate into a unit test? So we want
to test is controller. And for that, we'll
have to of course, create an instance of item
controller. However, remember that we need
two parameters here. So we need to have a
positivity and we need a lager. Now, one thing
to remember here is that for the purpose of
testing this unit, this get imazing method,
we don't really care about the internals of
how the repository for instance, accusatory
behaves, so we don't care what happens. Normally,
when you call get it basic, as you know, that
we'll go ahead and talk to the database, retrieve
the item and all those things. But we don't
want to test that we don't want to test a
repository, we just want to test the get itemizing
method, this is the one unit that we want
to test. So you have to make sure that you
find a way to exclude those dependencies and
the behavior of the dependencies from these
tests, and just focus on testing what was
right here. So to do that, of course, we cannot
use a real a real Idaho story or a real logger.
And here's what we have to introduce a what
we call a, what we call a stops. And so I
stopped is going to be a kind of a fake instance,
or a fake version of these items of these
classes that are going to be used just for
the purposes of the test. So let me show you
how that how that looks like. For this case,
I'm going to say so we need a depository,
right. So let's I'll say depository,
stop equals new mock. And then mark is a con
for the from the mock library that we installed
a moment ago, using mock. So this is a library
that allows us to mock any of the mock or
stop any of the different dependencies of
our class. So locally, our controller, as
we looked at the previous videos, we made
it in such a way that we can do dependency
injection in there. So the controller really
doesn't know what kind of repository is coming
in here, or the kind of logger comes here,
you just look, it's just looking at interfaces,
as you can see. So that gives us the flexibility
to fake these both dependencies from or from
the unit test. So I'll go ahead and say okay,
so this is going to be a new mock of items
repository. Okay, let's see, if I'm using
a meeting any space. Notice that I'm naming
this as a stop and not as a mock. And that's
a slight difference that I like to make, because
when you do stops, you will not verify anything
on the on the on this object itself. When
you do mocks, you will in the assert section,
you would go ahead and actually verify something
that happened to the mock accuracy test. So
it's a slight difference, but it is good to
it's good to to do the proper naming here
so that you understand what is the purpose
of the variable that you're using. Okay, so
now the expectation is that when we call this
call to controller, when we're going back
to our method, when we call the get imazing
method, the idea is that it will return a
no. So when returns No, we should return the
controller should return not found. So we
need to set up that isn't it? So how do we
set up this method in the mock so that it
returns No. Going back here, what you can
do is this repository, stop that setup. And
then you're going to say, let's say repo,
repo that gate item async. And then comes
the parameter. Now, at this point, it really
doesn't matter what's what's the item that
we are going to be passing in here. It's irrelevant,
because what we want to do it revelate is
what happens with the return value. So because
of that, what you can do is just say it is
a which is a function provided by Mark also
any COVID This means whichever value comes
in, it doesn't matter. So Mark will take care
of providing some value there. And then that
will do it should return a value of No, that's
what we want. That's the expected behavior.
And then, but just so that marketers doesn't
get confused, we have to cast this into the
item entity. And let me add Robert namespace
right there. Okay, so this is setting up the
scenario for artists. So we're saying again,
we're saying when whenever the controller
invokes get good at basic with any any code,
which mark is going to provide, you have to
return a null value. That's what we need for
this use case. And then similarly, we'll do
something With the logger, so we'll say logger
stop equals new mark. I'll say, Hi logger,
or items. I just control. Okay, let's see
if we're missing something again. Yep. See
dad remains in the construction space. Okay,
so now we have two stops ready to go. And
now we need to create the actual controller.
So now we can say, controller equals new items
controller. And then we passed it, this docks.
So if I posit Ori, stuff, what we need to
get actually the object property of these
because that's the real object that's going
to be passing out just a mock the mock object,
and then logger stop that object. So that
covers the arrange phase of this unit test
for the act phase. Here's where we execute
the action. And this is normally just one
line where you execute what you're going to
be testing. So I'll just say, sold, equals
await. And yeah, now that I'm using a Wait,
let me remember that we have to use a proper
return type for these unit tests, since we're
going to be calling an async function. These
days, it should actually switch to be an async.
task. C. So now we can do a weight controller,
that good idea may sync. And then, like I
said, it doesn't matter what what good we
provide here. So you'll say, cool, great.
And that's the action. And then finally, we'll
go ahead and do the assert. So we next unit,
you have a bunch of assert methods available.
So let's just use assert. And then what we
want to verify here is that what we got was
indeed are not found, and they're not found,
there's a class that is not found. So what
we can say is assert that is type not found.
result. And then let's see if we're missing
something. Yeah, add that. And then we're
going to pass here is result that result.
So the result object, the result variable
represents the actual result that we received.
And the result property inside that result
represent the actual type of result that we
got, which in our case, it should be not found
result. And now that we have that, we can
go ahead and actually execute the test. And
so there's a bunch of ways to actually run
this test. In VS code. One of the ways that
I use frequently is a via via using the kotlin.
So as you can see, over here, there's these
these set of annotations, which is, which
is introduced by kotlin is to code kotlin.
And you have to Will you have to do is click
on Run test. And that should go ahead and
run the test. Let's see what happens to running
test. And that this has passed, as you can
see, the one that we have passed, which is
good. Now, there's another way to run the
tests by using directly the dotnet. CLI. So
if you go to terminal, I'll switch to here,
make sure that you are in the catalog unit
test directory. And here, what you can do
is just do dotnet test. Yeah, so that will
go ahead and run not just not just one test,
but all the tests that you have across the
desk like so difficult, more handy when you
have you just are having more and more tests
for this test project. And as you can see,
it passed zero failed, one passed. Now, as
the number of tests increases, you may want
to have a better way to visualize the overall
status of your test suite, which is cases
are passing which words are failing, and so
on. So So to do that, there's actually a nice
Visual Studio Code extension that you can
install to provide the dissertation. So let's
go to our extensions hub. And let's expand
this a bit. And let's look for dotnet core,
this Explorer, just the first one here, I'll
collapse this for a moment that will cortex
explorer by June Han is the best one that
I found so far for these kinds of tests. So
go ahead and install it. And what you need
to do about this extension is to tell it where
to find the the test project. And if we go
to Explorer for a moment, you'll remember
that we have artists in this category test
folder, gather the unit test OCS proc, so
we need to provide that location to this extension.
To do that, you can click this gear icon over
here. Just click on that extension settings.
And if any chance these settings that you
see over here are not showing up for you where
you can Try is just closing close to the code
or closing the current folder and reopening
it. And then these things should show up,
it may happen the very, very first time, but
after that, it should be just fine. Then what
you want to do is go all the way down where
it says Internet Explorer display bad. These
are windows specify the path of this project.
But also, do you want to go not into the into
the user section, but into the work workspace
section. By doing that you are going to what
you're going to type in here is going to live
alongside your project, as opposed to so in
some place in the in your user profile. So
that's good, so that you can keep everything,
everything together. So here, what we want
to specify is just a simple expression. So
let me type that is a glob pattern where we're
going to say just search all over the place
inside of our catalog directory, and in all
directories, and then look for tests that
CS Brock, okay. And after doing that, we can
close this. And if we go to these three dots
here, there's now a test section. And as you
can see, there's our one test is already showing
up over there. And then to run it, you can
either click display icon here, or you can
just click the play icon on the top, and it
will go ahead and run all the tests that are
available there.
So aspect that is green. And you can see the
green bar also in on top of the test. And
if there was any error that you will get some
red squiggles in the location where we will
test failed. So yeah, so we're using this
extension across this video to to see the
status of our tests as we are adding them
and executing them. Okay, so now that we have
that in place, and we have a test for checking
for the existing item case, let's add another
test for the existing items. So what happens
when the item actually exists. So let me actually
collapse this for a moment. So I'll do hide
sidebar. And let's add a second test here.
Perhaps I'll just copy the header of this
test. So I'll copy that over here. Here's
a new this method. And this one is going to
be called get item async. Wait, existing item.
returns. expected it. Okay, now, just like
before, we will do the AAA. Arrange, act.
And assert now for these tests is very likely
that we're going to need a again, our our
capacity and our logger stop boat stops. So
instead of copying, then copy the instantiation
over here, why not just declare a class level
a couple of class level fields. And that way
we can reuse them in this test and in any
future test. So let me do that. So I'll go
here. So I'll declare by bait read only to
be marked off items repository, then I'll
just copy this base here, although I could
just do this. And then private with only mark
of a logger, or items controller. And then
it will be the loggers stuff we can use to
this. And with that, we can go to our initial
test case, and to simplify a little bit by
not having to declare it here, because we
stop there or they stop here. Okay, so going
back to the new test case, for this test case,
we will actually need to have an item that
we can use across the desk. Because let's
go back to the controller quickly, I this
controller IDs. And if remember, get item
async. In the case that we want to hit, which
is the one that returns the DTO we need to
have an item, we need to have the repository,
get the return an item. And then we need to
convert it to and return it. So to do that,
we'll have to set up that item beforehand
in our test so that it can be used it over
here. So I'll go back to the test. And instead
of just creating it on the fly for this test
case, I think that we should have some sort
of helper function that we can use not just
in this case, but instead of user tests to
create some random item very quickly. So I'm
going to go ahead and create a private function
to private identify to return an item. Let's
call it create an item
and this is going to say just return new And
let's specify all the properties for the new
item. So it will be ID, this make it good
that you go in, because we don't really care
what Id it uses the same way we don't really
care what name these random item uses, should
work with any any name. So new gu ID, to string,
them for the price we want to do is probably
just generate some random number so that we
don't get fixed into any specific price. So
for whatever, what I'll do is I'll actually
create a random a variable, and let's put
it at the top over here. So I'm going to declare
a private read only. Random and let's name
it yours around, it's going to be new. So
this will be with us in a couple of places.
So now we can go back here. And we can say
ran that next. And then I think we said that
the price should be between one and 1000.
And so let's just say a maximum value of 1000.
should be enough. And Rarity is going to be
the time of said that UTC. Okay,
so now that we have this handy method, let's
go back to our test case, over here. And in
terms of arrangement, what we have to do is
first prepare the item that we're going to
deposit or is going to return. So we're going
to say bar spec, this item is create random
item, then we have to do the setup for the
repository. And that's going to be a little
bit similar to what we did the previous test.
So I'm going to copy this, this first line
from the previous test there. So when we call
get item async, again, with any good on what
to do now is return that item. So returns
async. Expected item. Okay, and then we'll
go ahead and do pretty much the same thing
that we did in the previous day. So copy this,
these couple of lines over here. So we declared
a controller with the two stops, and then
we get a result, right by invoking get item
async with any GUI doesn't matter. And then
it is time to assert a what we got. So what
would we like to assert here, so probably
want to first make sure that we got the activity
or not some other a result, like not found
or bad requests or something like that. So
I'll do a search that is type identity Oh.
And let's add in a museum a space. And then
we're looking at result dot value because
it is the value property, the one that actually
should have the deal in this case. Okay. And
when we have asserted that well we can also
do is, what we should do is verify that all
the properties of the return to match the
expected item. So for that, let's first take
out that DTO. So we can do that by doing some
casting here. We sold as action result of
identity to that value. Okay, we can do a
ser equal expected item that Id should equals
do that ID. And just like that, we will need
to go through every single property right,
so x with the ID now expected item. That name
should equal the to that name. And, and well,
we'll keep going and going with the other
properties. But at this point, imagine that
you don't have just a couple of properties,
but you have dozens of properties, right as
objects can can get complex. So today is going
to be become very cumbersome to just keep
searching and searching and searching. And
in fact, it's not a very good practice to
be asserting too many things. In this case,
you should try to assert or get closer, just
one thing in each test, that's kind of the
best practice. And so to do that, what we
can do is instead of doing all this, we can
switch to a very handy assertion library that's
called fluent assertions. And davon will allow
us to do this in a much more straightforward
way. So let's bring in the terminal as well.
Ctrl J and l go to PowerShell and hoovering
we do so make sure that you are in the catalog
that unit tests directory, and that you can
do dotnet add package. fluent assertions.
Okay, so with that, I'll just close terminal.
So now we can do something a little bit different.
So let me show you. What we can do is now
we can say we sold that value And then should,
then it's important if your assertions namespace
be equivalent to the expected item. Okay,
and then I'll remove this. What this is expected
to do is that it should compare the values
of the properties of the resulting DTO. With
the properties of the expected item, the item
that we created over here, right? So that
way with this very handy method, we don't
have to go property by property, it will just
go ahead and compare the entire thing for
us. But that the only issue here is that seeing
suspected it is actually a record type. As
you remember, the item is a record type record
types already. Alright, the equals method
of the of the object, and that will make it
so that this method doesn't behave very well,
right, because he believes that you have to
compare the DTO to the entity directly, as
opposed to comparing the properties, which
is what we care about. So to address this,
we'll specify an additional option here.
Which is going to be Options, Options dot
comparing by members of the item of the item
class. Without we're saying, Hey, don't compare
the DTR directly to the to the item, just
focus on the properties that each of them
hum and as each of them have. And as long
as the property is the same name, compare
the values of those properties. So that way,
you will go ahead and and issue go ahead and
tell us that the objects are the same. Yep.
And so with that, let's go ahead and run this
test case and see what we get. So we'll go
ahead and click Run test. Yep. And this case
is passing. And just like we did this, just
to keep things consistent, let's also modify
the previous test to also use fluent assertions.
So in this case, is going to be result that
result should be off date. Not Found result.
that replaces the previous line. Okay, so
let's just verify that all these cases are
passing, I'll go ahead and run these in Data
Explorer here. And yes, it's all looking good.
Good. And so now let's move ahead into our
next unit test. Let's go back to the controller
briefly. And let's see what else we got there.
Perhaps this and back in the controller, and
what we want to test now is our first metal
here, the one that returns all the items available
in the REST API in the repository. So remember,
these items will just go ahead, retrieve all
the items, transfer them into DTO. And then
he returns and that's all he does. So what
we want to verify is that for any of the items
that we that we set up for the suppository
that we have to set up the depository, they
have to be returned as details, and they should
match exactly the IDs that will obtain through
depository. So let's go ahead and write a
unit test for that. So back into the test
class. Again, I'm going to copy the heater
of these this case. And I'm going to scroll
down here, Copy that. Okay, so here, let's
do the proper naming. So these are going to
be named get I get items a think are these
going to be just with exceed with existing
items. He will say, returns or items. And
again, let's bring in our arrange, act and
assert sections. And in this case, what we
need is of course to get a series of items
from the repository. So what we have to do
first is to declare such a set of items are
we will for that we'll create a simple array.
So what I'll do is I'll say bar expected items
equals new and this is going to be an array.
And we're going to be using our create random
item method here a few times perhaps less
bringing in three items. Yep, so that will
do it. Very handy method. And now we can go
ahead and set up the repository to return
those items. So I'll do repository stop, set
up where the repo where they bought the gun
get it and say saying so get one gig Titan
16 is invoked, which should return the expected
items. Then we have to construct the controller.
So I'll do it very similar to what we did
with the previous this case, I'll just go
ahead and copy this line over here. And then
we will go ahead and do. So bar, act two items,
equals a weight, controller, get items async.
Thanks, that should retrieve the items. And
now we have to do the comparison. So once
again, we can use that very handy method of
fluent assertions to do just an equivalence
of comparison. So we can say, items should
be equivalent to expected items. And once
again, we'll have to do the options. Because
we like, again, we're dealing with record
types. So otherwise things will not work,
right. And then options that comparing by
members, I. Okay, so with that, let's go ahead
and run this test. Let's see what we get.
Yep, this passing. Awesome, close that. Okay,
let's move forward back to ISIS controller,
it's time to test our great item async method.
So this is the one that goes ahead and creates
the item in the repository. So in this case,
we have to provide great identity as an input.
And then we can verify is that we should be
returning, we should be receiving as a return
added to with a graded item. That's, that's
what these metals is supposed to do. And in
fact, that return an item should include the
ID because it is not provided in there, create
that and do so return items will have an ID
and he will also have a graded date. So let's
write out a test that can verify all these
things. So back to items, control tests, they
may gain grab the heater off the desk, perhaps
so I grabbed the entire thing. Just copy this,
and then remove the space and and remove this
piece and I removed the solid piece. Okay,
now this method will be called just start
with the name of the method, which is create
item async. And then this will be in this
case, the current state, let's name it with
item to create, because we're going to be
providing the idea that should be created.
And the dissertation is that it returns the
Create a title. Right? Now in this case, the
arrange piece involves preparing the accurate
identity. So in this case, it's going to be
it will be tricky to try to use a created
random item, as we've been doing so far. So
we'll be we'll be explicit in this case. So
we will say I tend to create equals new create
item DTO. And here we'll provide the elements
of the query in detail. So we do provide a
name, which is just going to be cool nucleoid
string, we will provide a price, which again
is going to be just random next, with 1000
again, and I think that that will be. So let
me go quickly to create a new table with 12
to make sure I've covered the properties we
need. So he has a name and the price. Yep,
back here. And then in this case, I will actually
not need to set up anything in the repository.
Because it is not interesting. What happens
I mean, for the terms of of this test case,
it is not interested to see what happens when
the repository is invoked, if there was a
really simple act to create the item. So if
you look back at I just controller, what's
really going to happen here is that Jehovah
God needs to call greet, I are amazing. And
I will go ahead and gradiated. But I will
encourage you to be a bit careful about what
you're going to be testing here. Because you
could also decide that no, I want to make
sure that they created amazing metal is called
in the repository. Right. So that so that
yeah, I mean, it should get created. But that's
going a little bit too much into the details
of the test case. So you are getting you will
be making your test case to be very prone
to needs changes in the case of the implementation
of this method changes, right. So ideally,
you want to treat each of your test cases
in such a way that they only provide some
inputs to the method. And then eventually
they validate the outputs of the method but
they don't try to make Some just sort of what
is going to happen inside. So in this case,
we are not going to be carrying all this metal
at all. So in fact, we're not going to be
setting it up, we will go ahead and go back
to this case, we'll go ahead and use invoke,
invoke the action. So we will say, var greeted
item. Sorry, it's going to be bar result equals
weight, controller dot, create item aceing.
We provide the item to create. And then we
can go ahead and do the assert. And the first
thing we're going to do here is try to retrieve
that identity. So what I'll do is, I'll do
we did item is the result that result as created
an action result. Okay, that's the type of
result we're going to receive here is a created
action result. From that one, we want to get
the value. And that value will turn it into
an item we do a little bit convoluted for
for this case. And now we can do the same
equivalence thing that we've been doing so
far. So I tend to create
should be equivalent to created by, okay,
and then we provide options. Like we said,
there will be options that comparing by members.
And in this case, the data we're going to
use here is actually I can be deal.
Okay, which is the, the type of the object
that we received from the front desk
of the creditor. Okay. But additionally, we
want to do one more thing here, because a,
both of these a DTS don't have the same members,
if you remember, if we go to F 12, to identity,
Oh, this one has four properties, as you can
see. But if we go into great identity, or
this one has only two properties over here.
So that means that if you try to compare things
like this is going to fail, because you're
going to say, Hey, what are you writing has
more properties than the other. So this, this
doesn't make sense. So in these cases, what
you can do is say, only look at the properties
that are common between the two objects. And
that will simplify things in this case. So
that's all we can do. And then in the spirit
of fluent assertions, we can use to dot excluding
missing members. And that should do it for
that for that one assertion. Okay, so we're
comparing that the two objects are equivalent,
but we will not pay attention to any members
that are missing from for any other. However,
we may want to actually check for those additional
members. So for those who will be will be
a bit more explicit. So So credit item, the
ID should not be empty. Because the the method,
it should generate an ID for for the scooter
rider, and also create an item that create
a date.
Should
we don't know exactly what, what day we're
going to get in there. But we know that it
should be, it should be close to the current
time, right? Because this test just take milliseconds
to execute. So we will say datetimeoffset
UTC now. And then, just to be safe, we're
going to give it a range of precision, because
we don't know exactly how much time did basically
today, although it should be super fast. But
we're going to give it 1000 milliseconds to
for for the difference between the times of
when the item is created and the data we're
checking here. Okay, so that should be should
be it for this test. Let's go ahead and run
it from the test. see what we get. Test is
passing. It's looking good. Okay, so the next
test we're going to look at, but less case
we're going to look at is the case of the
update, update item async. Does remember this
method, it gets at the item to update, it
will get it from the database. And if it doesn't
find it, it will say not found. And otherwise,
it will create a copy of the item to become
the updated item with the updated properties.
And then it will go ahead and update the item
in the database and finally returns no content.
Okay, just to be to not spend too much time
here, we're only going to be covering one
case here, which is the case of where the
item actually exists. But you can you can
imagine how to test for the not found case,
which is a bit simpler. But then again, don't
don't get into the trap of verifying that
the item is actually being sent to the date
itemizing method of a depository. We want
to we will provide an input which is these
two parameters here. We expect the output
of no content of added that's everything that
we need to verify here. Nothing else, we don't
need to worry about the implementation of
the method. So let's go back to I just got
a test. And let's bring in again, just I'll
do a copy of our last test over here. And
so, this is going to be update, I think we
take existing item returns no content, okay.
And then we will meet these who need a controller
will need that, we will remove this species
at the end. So for the range base, as you
remember from this controller, we will need
a when good imec, Usain Bolt, you need to
return it right so that we can move forward
into this case. So, I think that that situation
we covered already somewhere else. So, let
me go back a little bit up. So this one here,
so, we will grab these from the get item async.
This case, let me grab that here. So, that
would allow us to have an item to be returned
by the by the depositor is done. So we will
name these one, please thing item ID, that's
the ID that exists in there. And now we need
to declare the the actual item that we're
going to provide to the methods. So they updated
it. So let's first grab the item ID as a variable.
So the item ID is system ID that ID. So we'll
grab that there. And then I tend to update
these a new update ID to
and so we're going to provide a name naming
scheme to be cool if you go it to string.
And perhaps
we download line. And then for the price we
can do is just pick the price of the existing
item price and just increase it a by somebody,
let's say by three. Okay, so that becomes
the updated paper from this item. So we pretty
much were changing the name because we're
getting really unusual, we're changing the
price by adding three to it. Then we create
the controller. And I started to do the the
action. So we'll say result equals await controller
that update async. And then here's where we
provide the item ID. And then we provide the
item to update. And then finally we go for
the assertion, the assertion is going to be
very simple, because like I said, we only
want to verify that we we get no content.
So result should be of type. No content result.
That's all it is. So again, we set up the
return of the item from the repository, we
prepare nine out of date, we modify the properties,
we invoke a bit of the async. And at the end,
if everything went well, we should be getting
the content result. So let's go ahead and
run this test. All best, I think we're missing
just one method at this point. Let's go to
IRS controller. So this is delete I basic,
right? It's got to be very simple. To verify
and very similar to update, we get an ID,
it will have to a Find the Item. Again, we're
not going to check all the cases, for this
case, just a case where the item exists. So
we'll make it so that it returns the item.
And then it should return no content. And
again, we don't care what happens with the
repository or any of the internals here, we
just care about the fact that it should return
the content. So back to I just adore tests.
I'm going to copy your lastest case, once
again.
This is going to be named delete it may sync
with existing item returns no content. Yep,
that's an appropriate name. The setup will
work just fine for this case. But then we
don't have to prepare any item to update us
do that. Create the controller with those
setups. And then we'll do the database sync
with the it will be just the existing ID and
that ID and then the assert is exactly same
as before. There's should be of type knock
on result. That's all it is. So I'll go ahead
and run this test now.
And Yep, it is passing. And in fact, if we
go to our test Explorer, now, let's go to
the test section here. And let's run this.
As you can see, we have a full suite of tests
passing at this point. Okay, so this is great,
we have a bunch of test cases covering many,
there's nothing in our controller. And what
this gives us now is actually a lot of confidence
or making any future changes across the, across
the REST API. So what I'd like to do now is,
there's there's been a few changes that I
wanted to make across the board. But I didn't,
I didn't have a way to make sure that didn't
break anything. But now we do. So I'm going
to make two critical changes here. One of
them is that I'm going to switch our entity
to not be a record type anymore. So remember,
he's here if you go to the entities item.
So the fact that he's a record type is actually
making things a bit inflexible, I mean text.
Because of this, we cannot use update existing
items in the update a operation in the controller,
and we have to create this copy that's not
really needed. So these entities should be
actively moldable. So we don't need these
any stuff here, really. So we'll switch this
to be a normal class. And we will also add
a description property here, so we can provide
some description for the items. So let's make
those two changes. And let's see if our test
cases can help us prevent breaking anything.
So like I said, This item is going to change
from record to class. And then we will not
be using it here. But we will switch it to
just set. So set in all of this. And now this
is a normal standard class. But also, like
I said, we're going to be adding a description,
description for the entity. So with that done.
The other thing that I like to do, actually,
is to simplify the way that we use videos.
Remember that we have these three files for
the three videos. But it turns out that there's
a much better nicer way to declare the video
such as record types, which actually provides
even more benefits that we are doing today.
So what I'll do is I'll actually just get
rid of all these files. Let me just delete
the CTOs folder. Perhaps collapse these a
bit, what I'm going to do is create a new
file at the root of catalog API. Let's name
it. videos at CS. Let's bring in some namespace,
right namespace, which would be catalog that
KPI details, we will declare all the details
here in line in a much more a nicer way. Let
me hide the sidebar. So for the first video
is going to be the item detail. So we will
say what do you record it to, then we will
declare the properties as if we were creating
like a constructor for for this property.
That's something that you can do that we will
say good ID. And then let's see if we're missing
this system. And they will do name the new
description property price, and they time
offset created date. Okay, so that's you know,
that's that's what you need to do to create
to declare a record type in this other syntax.
So as you can see, is much, much more simplified.
Now, let's declare the next one is going to
be only record, create item DTO. And then
this is going to have no ID but the name and
then the new description, property. And then
the price. Let's not forget that we had set
up some attributes here to make to make sure
that we get valid inputs. So in the case of
names, we want it to be required. It's amazing
the space and in the case of price, what we
want is 25 range. So the range Yeah, it was
from one to 1000 Okay, we will not require
description, and we will not require we will
not add the required attributes to price because
price is actually validate. So it cannot ever
be no, you will get somebody there anyways.
And we will just verify that the range is
correct. Lastly, let's add our last detail
that we're missing. I just copy that one.
And this is going to be updated in detail.
Yep. So that's all we need. So now in one
file we have we're declaring all the details
that we're using across the REST API as opposed
to three files. Let's see what else we need
to modify. So now that we make those changes,
let's look at extensions. Let's see what's
going on here.
Yeah, so I'll hide cyber. So now that we change
the way that we declared our details as record
types, they have become immutable. We cannot
go through this initialization anymore. We
must create the DTO via the constructor. It's
the only way to create instances of them from
here on. And after construction, nobody can
change the properties of the DTO. So we will
say new identity Oh, and then we will provide
it that ID. Id and the pain. Right? And that
scription. I think that price, an item that
created date, right? That's always Yep, we
got liquid in line these over here, but it
may be too much to read. So we'll just leave
it like this. Okay, let's see what else we
have to fix. If we go back, so there's something
going on in the controller? Let's see what
it is. Yep. So there's an issue with update
imazing? Yep. So we cannot use this syntax
anymore. Because the item is no longer a record
type. Now it is a standard class. And in fact,
this is this is good. This is actually exactly
what we wanted to fix here. Because there's
no need to create this updated item, we could
just modify the existing item. So we will
say, existing item that name equals item D
do that name, an existing item, the price
equals identity or that the price. Yep. So
we don't need these additional guy here. We'll
leave it like that. And then for the update,
we'll use invoke existing IRA. Okay, so yeah,
there's no more breaks around here. Let's
see what else. So because of API, everything
looks good in the unit tests. Let's see what's
going on. Okay, let's hide the sidebar. Let's
see. Yep. So great identity Oh, has to be
weighted to define the properties inside the
constructor. So we'll have to provide these
for the name. And they probably will do the
same thing for the description. And for the
price, the random number, perhaps, so I'll
delete this. And then I'll do it like this.
That is it is easier to see. There. Okay.
So let's see what else we have to fix here.
Just in case for update identity. Oh. So let
me copy this line here. So we have to provide
that then we provide a description. And then
we provide the price, which is going to be
existing item price plus three. Okay, remove
this. Yep. And with that, I think we don't
have any more breaks are not in there. I can
see actually. And so let's go ahead. And now
let's run our tests and see what we get. So
go ahead and run the tests. Yep. And, interestingly,
we do have something failing here. Let's see
what's going on. So great. It may sync is
the one that's failing. And as you can see,
we are getting the x over here, signaling
that there's a problem. We get the squiggles
here, signaling that there's something in
there. And if this if we see the message over
there, you can see it says expected member
description to be no, but found some value
in there. Yep. And then, so what could have
happened? So let's actually go back to our
controller. So I'll do f 12, from the controller.
And let's go to the Create method. Over here.
Let's hide this hide sidebar. And, yeah, so
what happens here is if you can spot that
is that we have not a percentage value for
the description. So let me actually close
this close these. So back to the test. Yep.
So when we declared the item to create, we
did add a description. But when we created
the degraded item, it does not have any value
for description. That is because we have not
specified that here anywhere. So that's something
we have to fix. And that's, that's a nice
thing about using these should be equivalent
to because as you add more properties, and
you don't have to be remembering to do the
proper checks in the test cases, right. Otherwise,
anytime you you add a new property here, you
have to go back to the test and other properties
in there to make sure that you don't Forget
what it is that this case is actually covering
you, making sure that you don't forget to
add those properties in the place where you're
implementing the Edit method. For this case,
I'll do description equals identity to that
description. With that, let's go back to our
test list, lets us run them again. It's all
green now. And then one minor improvement
that you can also do here is to change the
way that we're doing some comparisons across
a few test cases. So we go back to two lists
test case, erasing, we created a retrospective
item. If you see how we're doing B, A k be
equivalent to here, these options, we need
to do them because the item A during class
A we're able to actually record before, so
that was causing issues. Now that it's not
a record type, we can stick to the normal
behavior. So now we can just remove this and
do the equivalent to this way. And fearless
agents will know what to do. Because this
is just a standard plus the same way we can
go to the next case, and change this think.
And that should be enough. And this is only
because like I said, because what we're comparing
here is the other classes are not record record
type, you still have to do the other way.
So let's just make sure that the test cases
are still passing. So I'll go ahead and run
all the tests. And everything is still all
green. Okay, so that's working pretty well.
And now I wanted to I'd like to switch gears
into test driven development TDD. So we talked
about TDD, it has some very nice benefits,
because it allows you to start for the test
for the requirements really, and then move
forward to implementation later on. So let's,
let's see, how do they work. In practice,
what we're going to do is if we go back to
items controller, and I'll hide these for
a moment again, let's go back to our first
method here, get items async. So as you see,
this is the method that returns all the items.
But a new requirement to our REST API is that
we should be able to return a the items by
a by the name. So if somebody specifies a
name into into such a method, which should
be able to return only the items where the
name contains the specified parameter, right.
So So if the if the, if you have items that
have for instance, a word potion in them,
like a potion, potion, potion, all these all
these things, which are going to return all
the items that include potion in the name,
and not to the right, so it's a way of filtering
things. But let's see how we can go ahead
and implement such a method by using DDD.
So I'll go back to I just controlled tests.
So let's grab this, grab this method, get
it and pick it as a sink. And then I'll just
copy that just under it because there's similar
methods. But in this case, we rename it to
get either a sink, we will say, with matching
items, returns,
returns
matching items. Okay, so in this case, we're
going to go ahead, and we will not be using
the random item anymore, because I actually
want to specify a name for our items. And
in fact, that's the only thing that we cared
about, in the case of this test case. What
do we want explicit here. So what I want to
do is rearrange this a little bit, so that
instead of these, what we have is, let's name
these, all items are all items equals new.
And then I'll just move these to the next
line is going to be a bit more verbose. Like
this perhaps. And then, in each of these lines,
instead of these, we're going to create new
items, new items, so we will say new item.
And he will will provide a name. So let's
use something that we can use for these tests.
Like I said, Let's go for the potion. potion
case. So we will have a potion there. And
then let's add two more. The second one is
going to be named Let's name it something
completely different, like how to do it. And
then the last one is going to be highbush.
So in this case, we have two items that have
the same, the same term portion and another
one that doesn't have it. And then we'll declare
a variable here that we're going to say its
name, name to match equals Now notice that
we are already implemented this case for this
new method, but the method just does not exist
at all, he has not been implemented. And that's
the right way of doing DDD. So we will start
with a test case that will actually fail because
we don't have the method, and then we will
move forward implementation later. Okay, so
now we're depositary inbox, get items async,
we will return all the items that we have
prepared in here.
Remember, this is the call to the opposite,
it is not the call to the controller get is
async. So then we go ahead and prepare our
controller and then a constant time to make
the call to the act.
Now here, we're going to be a bit more explicit.
The first it will now go to us in bar on the
left side, because we want to signal to the
to C sharp and VS code, what we're going to
receive from this new method or method to
be created. So in this case, what we're going
to receive is an ienumerable. of item DTO.
Are these going to be found items? And are
we missing something? Yeah, system collection
generic was amazing. And then these are going
to come by calling weight controller, get
items async. But not the signature, we need
a new signature, where we can actually pipe
them async we need a new signature, we can
receive the name to match. So we're going
to pass name to match here. Okay. And yeah,
so yeah, that's got to be great. And then
as, as our assert, what we have to verify
is that we only got items that were their
name, match the name to batch in this case
potion. So to verify that we will say phone
items should only contain. And then we can
say item where item that name should be equals
to item, it will be items soup, sorry, so
this is all items, sub zero dot name, because
that's the first one, let's scroll up a little
bit. So we got zero, and we got one and two.
So it should be that one. Or, and then just
copy this should be I think name should be
equals to a lightened suit to that name. Okay,
so that's a way that you can use fluent assertions
to verify that the items in the collection
match some condition. So whatever we're getting,
we're getting four items, a, the item should
match either phusion or hipolito. In this
case, okay. So if we go ahead and build this,
I'll do Ctrl Shift v. Course it fails. Because
we don't have such a metal gate is a thing
that receives some argument. So that's kind
of the red face of DDD. And now to start moving
into the green phase, we need to move forward
and implement implement this is meant to do
that, or we can do is just click here, I'll
do a Ctrl dot. And that a presents his options
or we can do is use a generate method, I just
controller get get isolate async. So I'll
do that. And then if I do f 12. Here, the
method now exists. And I'll move this up just
next to the one that we have already the other
overload here. Okay, and then we could go
ahead and try to implement these. But as you
notice, these methods are exactly the same
thing. But one of them receives a parameter
and the other one does not receive it. So
I think it's better to just put everything
in this one method, as opposed to try to implement
the second one. So I'm going to just take
this parameter out of here and into there.
Are there Okay, and then we are not expecting
to always receive the name, it depends on
what the caller wants. So let's make so that
these a can receive no, so it is allowed to
receive. Okay, and so with that, let's go
ahead and run or this case a once again, let's
see what we get. I mean, at this point, you
should build just fine this verify that should
build Yeah, it does build. Now let's run the
test. And in our suspected it is failing.
It is failing because it is carrying a more
items than expected. And on this as a result
found items, just getting all the items is
not getting only the ones that have been specified
here. So let's see how we can fix this. So
let's try to get green. So what we're going
to do is something very simple after retrieving
the list Both items, we're going to apply
some filtering if we have to apply a filter.
So if string.is null or whitespace. Name,
name to match. That only list, let's just
rename these to name as opposed to need to
match. That should be enough. If name is more
whitespace if it is not known as whitespace,
then we will apply a filter on the list of
files we have already received. So items is
going to be items where item
height in duck name, contain corn contains
the me. And just to make sure that we don't,
we don't worry about casing here. Let's do
strings comparison already. Now, in our case,
we that it doesn't matter. If you're looking
for potions for with capital P or with smaller
p, it shouldn't matter. We don't we don't
care about that. So as long as as a name has
been provided able to use it to do a filter
on the items, so we get a filtered list of
items. And that should be enough to satisfy
the condition. Let's go back to the test.
Let's run it. And this time it is passing.
So we are agreeing, this actually confirmed
that this is true by running the entire test
suite now. And making sure that we have not
broken anything. Yeah, as you can see, everything
is green now. And so everything looks look
great. So that's how you how you can use a
DDD. We don't really need to do more refactoring
here at this point. But if you needed to you
feel free to go ahead and do more refactoring.
But we have gone through the red phase, green
phase. And now refactoring is not not dealing
this case. What we can do now is to verify
that this new functionality actually works
in the in the real life. So we will start
our host, and we will see how to use these
from postman. Okay, so I'll go ahead and hit
f5. And then going to postman are here. So
let's see. To start with, we'll see what we
have currently in our database. So I have
here the URL to get all the items in the database.
So I'll hit send. And at this point, we have
a potion and antidote. And we are ready verifying
that things are not broken, because we already
in both this method that has been modified,
it can receive a parameter now, but it seems
to be working just fine. So to properly verify
that the new functionality is working, I'm
going to actually add a yet another another
item here via the post action. So I'll just
copy the URL and say plus, I'll switch this
to post, pay the URL and in the body of the
raw. And I'll do Jason. And then I'll just
copy the body of something else here, copy
this, notice that the previous items don't
have a description, and that's fine. And the
new item will have one let's make sure we
can have one. So let's do this. That. And
then to keep things simple, I'll just name
this guy potion. And this is going to be stores
a small amount of HP. And the price is going
to be let's say seven. So let's pause this.
Okay, is there. And if we go back to our get
a operation I hit set, here we can see that
we have the three items now create now is
where we can see if the filtering is working.
So now I can say that name equals and are
we looking for potion right? So portion, so
they should only give me the mega petition
and abortion. So I'll go ahead here and hit
send. And indeed, we are only getting these
two items. Notice that it didn't matter that
I use a smaller p here and not a capital P
that we have earlier, he was still able to
find the items. So things are working as expected.
So yeah, that's how you can use DD to drive
your your process to add new functionality
to the REST API. So as always, I hope this
was useful. And if you're looking to dive
in deeper into what I have covered in this
tutorial series, please check out the link
to my full online course in the video description
that's been watching and I'll see you next
time.